[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to round eight of the
tata steel chess tournament my name is
fiona antony and i'm delighted to be
joined once again by grandmaster daniel
naradiski dania how are you today
yonah good afternoon to you good morning
good afternoon to everybody i am doing
great so excited for another round of
tada steel fiona this is the midpoint of
the tournament and so much is going to
be decided in the next two or three
rounds the field is so tight and i can't
wait to jump into the action indeed
today is gonna be a very exciting day
before we get to what awaits us let's
quickly check in with the results from
yesterday
unfortunately we had one game uh
finished by walk over daniel dubov did
not show up for his game against sanjiri
it later became clear he was awaiting
the result
of his pcr test and was not willing to
play
with a mask
but the great news is for today
daniel tested a negative both in his pci
test and
the antigen test he took just an hour
ago so he will be back fantastic news
for everyone involved elsewhere we had
three decisive results
magnus beating pragnanda karana beating
duda and jordan uh beating vidit and
danya that means that after seven rounds
we have a clear leader at the top
yeah having a hard time pronouncing his
name um is this a new is this his first
tournament lead i'm not really used to
seeing him at the top of the tournament
standing but some dude named magnus
carlson an imposter has made his way to
the top he's got five points out of
seven closely followed by chakriar
uh the hoodie
grandma we need to work that we need to
work the word hoodie into something
can we pretend i never said that we need
the chat's help but uh he's got four and
a half out of seven and then there's a
big peloton with four out of seven
uh a group of three and a half uh
including fabian and caruana and sergey
koryakin and that tells you how strong
the tournament is if jan christoph duda
and sam shankland are on three out of
seven
that tells you who they are up against
but a very very tightly packed field
fiona indeed a lot of these players can
still harbor hopes for the the final
victory we still have eight rounds uh no
sorry what am i saying six runs
to go and but let's look at
today's match up and i saw that sam
shankland he actually posted on facebook
last night uh he's very excited it's
been three years since he's faced off
against uh world champion magnus carlsen
so that's one to look out for obviously
the second one as well mamidiarov
against uh prague and as always i mean
every match up uh promises some fighting
and exciting chess
indeed karjakin report you have some
unstoppable object and immovable force
kind of situation or a moveable object
unstoppable force however you want to
say it s panko against geary that's a
very high level match up really all of
the games and i'm really interested of
course in mamidyaro of prague because
shakur is going to be gunning to win the
game and hit uh five and a half out of
eight but prague he's going to be
frustrated after yesterday's game can he
get it together and pull off at the very
least they draw with the black pieces
magnus will be following that game
closely fiona as well for sure and then
well another storyline is fabiano
carrana he beat yesterday do that today
he's up against jordan run for race to
out of his first seven rounds he's had
six decisive results uh so i'm sure we
can expect some action there and i'm
also curious to see how will evidet the
early tournament leader how will he
recover from the loss to jordan he is
playing with the white pieces against
neil squanders so i'm sure he will be
looking for the full point as well
he absolutely will be and all of these
players are so you know they're used to
having losses uh it's not a crisis for
anybody and a lot of these players have
showed tremendous resilience so far this
tournament as you've indicated including
fabiano caruana yesterday so very
curious to see
how things are going to unfold if it's
going to be anything like yesterday uh
fiona it's going to be a tremendously
entertaining day for sure and dania
maybe we can remove the pairings for a
second because i think daniel duboff
after uh forfeiting yesterday he is here
nice and early already sitting at the
board in the top right corner there just
behind pragnanda's
name we're gonna quickly show you that
so danny live with seven minutes to go
he is ready more than ready for his
battle
against the unkristov duda and danya
well we are looking forward to the
action here but our viewers at home can
also get involved in the action can you
tell us how do they do it indeed and get
into the action you should don't forget
to vote on the result of today's games
go to chess.com
events
navigate to the tournament select a game
click vote and select your winner you
could win a piece of the one thousand
dollar prize pool for best voters or
free diamond memberships voting ends
after the 10th of each game so don't
miss out and remember to vote on all the
games chess.com events jump into the
action and don't procrastinate it ends
on the tenth move
absolutely get involved and we are gonna
go on a very short break but we'll be
just uh back in just a couple of minutes
with the start of round eight here so
don't go anywhere we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it is round eight here in
vaikansi and we see daniel dubos and
young christoph duda
uh duda clearly not afraid we saw our
handshake as he arrived at the board
uh daniel dubaf he seems to be having a
good uh time not seems he doesn't seem
too taken aback from the forfeit
yesterday danya
no he doesn't he seems i mean he's i'm
sure he's happy to be back at the
chessboard
uh and he's got the white pieces so
uh could be worse of course john should
stop losing a painful game that started
to fabby so daniel is going to be
playing very ambitiously today it's
uh
you know pretty safe bet when it comes
to do bob and we saw there niels
grindelius and ishgiri and andre
essepanko awaiting
the signal the clocks are going to be
started any second
and pushing in this chair fabiana
caruana awaiting jordan van forest
yeah so it looks like jordan yet to
arrive uh we just saw a handshake there
between sega karjakin and richard report
maybe magnus's ways are starting to
influence his second jordan
it's very fashionable you know that's
that's that's what the cool kids are
doing nowadays they're coming 40 seconds
late
and there we see prague arriving for his
game against shaq and shaq immediately
saying okay while you're here now just
start the clock already let's get this
on
and then perfect timing
yes and fabiano also not losing any time
one e4 is on the board
we see sam has arrived for his game
against magnus carlsen in the background
the lady with the
the red hair very noticeable you can
follow her work her name is piage prong
and she does some great digital art so
she is doing a digital
uh painting of the the players on an
ipad we see play has gotten
underway but no sign of magnus just yet
surely he is going to be here in a
second
and i can only imagine from sam's
perspective how difficult it is
to choose an opening against the world
champion i mean you're going through the
options nothing seems particularly
appealing i'm really curious to see
what sam is going to put
in front of the world champion because
sam of course very well known really
across the world by now uh for his
uniquely dangerous opening preparation
and
he's going to try to make a serious push
for an advantage in europe do you think
magnu we might see magnus see something
see magnus play something
more offbeat from the start
i think that's entirely a possibility
magnus is aware of sam's tendencies and
there it is he saw sam stand for the
handshake very respectful of course of
his opponent magnus he had also waited
for magnus to arrive before starting the
clock and well one d4 is on the board
here
indeed it is and
it took me a second to realize that
magnus yes indeed he has two blacks in a
row
um and if he can pull off two wins in a
row that would be absolutely huge
indeed magnus he hasn't won here in a
couple of years he loves this tournament
it is his 18th participation that's a
lot of his life spent here
18 18 yeah oh my god
that's crazy
and he's not even old he's like 31. come
on
and also the tournament is so uh
so long i mean the the event lasts
almost
uh three weeks like two and a half weeks
so that's yeah a lot of his life i think
someone had done the maps on how much
time magnus has spent here but it is a
lot he loves this tournament and he is
very eager
last year jordan
the standout winner two years ago
fabiano with a huge score of 10 out of
13. so magnus he is looking to write
those wrongs
wrongs in his book anyway
i just like how casually just suggesting
his pieces okay so i'll take two minutes
on the first move he is completely
unperturbed and just like against prague
he goes d5
and let's see if he repeats the queen's
gambit declined
he does now prague played knight f3 in
this position magnus responded by taking
on c4 and they transposed into a queen's
gamut accepted
say i'm going knight to c3
and ooh
the tarash
variation with c5 fiona that is quite
surprised
at this level
do you remember magnus playing
this before like i think it's such a
rare guest uh indeed as you just said
it it really is and i think the proper
name for it is the taj defense i mean
there's a lot of tarash variations in
chess and this is one of them
i do not remember magnus having played
this opening
in recent memory uh now what i will say
about it it's named after zebra tarash
one of the strongest 19th century
players he was a rival to uh world
champion steinitz and nimzovich
and and he developed a lot of these uh
openings that have withstood the test of
time including the taurus variation of
the french and c5 is a move that
immediately challenges the center and
fiona it often leads to
uh a an isolated queen pawn structure
generally speaking white takes on d5
here the majority of the time
and
well i think magnus by playing the tara
she has achieved
maybe exactly what he wanted which is
getting sam out of
at least his main preparation for
today's game as you said earlier magnus
he has such a broad repertoire so it's
tough for some
um
to prepare very deeply against
everything it's not just tough it's
impossible to to prepare against every
single possibility so from that point of
view would you say uh that's a a good
choice by magnus do you approve
yeah i mean i think the next three four
moves are going to be interesting
because in this position c takes d4 is
also a move
and something tells me
and let's see yes magnus plays it and
this is a really really exciting line
now the point is that after queen takes
c4 black has this move knight c6
uh fiona and you can't touch the knight
and this is a well-known gambit it's
been
it's been pretty well explored for for a
long time so sam is aware of its
existence the point is that once the
queen moves away black plays he takes d5
and after queen takes d5 the box
certainly does not want to trade the
queen's black ghost bishop d7 and aims
for a very very quick development and a
lead in development i honestly do not
know what the current theoretical
standing of this variation is possibly
neither does sam and the last thing i'll
say for now
is that in this position white also has
the move queen a4 check inducing bishop
d7 so that after queen takes d4 you
cannot play knight c6 because there's no
longer a standoff between the queens so
would you say that the terrorist is an
ambitious choice by magnus
absolutely
absolutely i mean first of all this is
upon sacrifices sam does indeed play
queen a4 check
and let me again reiterate that sam has
studied and analyzed this line at some
point in his recent chess career
i think what magnus is banking on here
is
first of all the fact that sam did not
review this before the game
because there was no way of expecting it
and the second that
uh you know that magnus's new analysis
with the most recent engines
uh can perhaps find
uh new paths and and challenge sam's old
analysis
even if he remembers it so we'll have a
very interesting uh battle here sam for
now has been playing quite quickly uh he
hasn't sunk into a deep thing just yet
but as you say very likely he hasn't
reviewed this this morning but we talked
about roaches
as being one way for you guys to get
involved today you can get involved even
more actively because we have our online
amateur tournaments happening this
afternoon yesterday was the rapid but
today if you're a fan of blitz or bullet
then you can play the first event starts
in just 23 minutes that will be a blitz
event three plus two as the time control
it is free to enter if you want to find
out how just go to the link at the
bottom of the picture there just dot com
slash club slash tata uh hyphen steel
hyphen jazz hyphen tournament hyphen
2022
uh and in three hours we will be playing
some bullet
no get that away from me get that away
from me
you must get that away from me
i can't look i'm i'm averting my i'm
looking out the way don't shoot the
messenger this is of course a picture
courtesy of our producer
i have some major i already have some
major issues with the producer and he's
merely continuing to get on my bad side
conversation is imminent
and unpleasant conversation indeed and
uh well we are in the bird's eye view so
so far we've only looked at sam
shankland against magnus carlsen let's
have a quick look at uh what is
happening elsewhere what is catching
your attention at first well first of
all i'm just checking in the alignment
between the boards to make sure that
it's the same because i wouldn't put it
past pic
um but
what is catching my eye that's a great a
lot is catching my eye oh my goodness so
first of all um we don't have to go
there immediately caruana against van
forest is entering an extremely sharp
line of the rye lopez you know what
let's go to that game first and then i
want to check out vidit's game against
nils i also see that uh if i'm not
mistaken richard report has taken uh
played the french so robert has he will
be devastated
that he missed it
oh absolutely shout out to to robert but
let's start with
fabiano against jordan
yeah so fabian against jordan was an
open roy
and what is that you might ask well the
open roy is a variation where black
plays a6
knight f6 and then knight takes c4 that
is not the berlin the berlin is when you
take this pawn
without having played a6 bishop a4 uh
and the
inclusion of these moves changes the
nature of the game entirely because if
so white plays d4 and now black has this
additional move b5 whereas in the berlin
black drops the knight back to d6 and
attacks the bishop so b5 bishop b3 d5
black gives the pawn back this is all
very very well known
and after bishop c5
uh knight bd2
black goes for a an old variation this
has been around for a long time castles
bishop c2 and knight takes f2 this is i
believe called the dilworth variation
i'm not sure who exactly dilworth was
not necessarily a famous player but what
is the idea of this move well after rook
takes f2 black is not in a hurry to take
on f2 that pin is not going anywhere and
black plays the move f6 blasting open
the king side what black is saying is
that yes i'm giving up two pieces for a
rook and from a material standpoint that
might not be ideal but once i take the
stroke and f2 white's king is going to
be exposed for
essentially the foreseeable future and
with the f file being open black's going
to have long lasting attacking chances
this is a very theoretical line
and uh the main move here is he takes f6
but and daniel
taking his time
one thing that's interesting we actually
had this uh variation the open spanish
on the board just a few rounds ago but
with jordan being on the white side
against jachi ahmad mediarov
a game he lost and i was just looking up
in that game jordan with the white
pieces on move nine he had not played c3
but a4
so that's where that game uh deviated
but very interesting to see jordan maybe
get inspired
by
shakia's opening choice against himself
just a few days ago
absolutely and this is already very
interesting knight f1 is exceedingly
rare i only see three games in the
database but jordan not surprised by
this move at all he responds bishop
takes f2 and now he's going to play f
takes c5 what's really interesting about
what fabby just did there is that he
does not take on f6 he actually gives up
the e5 pawn
voluntarily and my guess is that he's
going to drop the king back to g1
and this looks like a line which
prioritizes king safety
over uh you know over material
so which camp are you in here
would you rather have
the material
or the safer king
um
well
i'm always a fan of two pieces against a
rook in the middle game
i i just feel like it's it's usually
easier to handle the two pieces so
material are safe for king i guess
technically black has deleted material
because now black has two pawns that's
true actually
as soon as i asked my question i was
like
maybe i couldn't phrase that the best
way
no but that's a formality because i
think in a middle game context two
pieces are still supposed to be
uh in most cases
superior and a case in point is that
white is already threatening bishop
takes h7 followed by knight g5 so i see
five games in the database now
and they all feature different moves
there's e4
queen d6 bishop g4 queen f6 and queen d7
all five of those moves have been tested
and e4 definitely being the most natural
among them
i i think this could just be a case of
both players uh being happy with what
they got you're then clearly the one who
initiated this whole line so uh well
surely he must be happy and uh fabiano
probably also uh i could picture him
being in the camp of being quite happy
with his two pieces uh for the work and
cons
indeed and jordan kind of looking off to
the side i can guarantee you that he has
had this position on his computer at
some point and he's just trying to
remember it the engine likes bishop g4
in this position which is one of the
moves that has been played so we will
keep an eye on on this game i'm very
excited to see how the next couple of
moves are going to unfold has fabi
succeeded in out preparing
uh the impeccably prepared uh yordum and
forest and uh dania we're back in the
bird's eye view and i think the next
game we're going to go to
has got to be visited against grand
delus what on earth is going on there
happening well let's have a look at that
game and let's look at it from the
beginning because craziness started
basically from move three
so knight f3 g6 knight bd2 now this is
still pretty normal uh this is a system
where essentially white wants to play e4
so generally black plays d5 and then
often white plays this move b4 to create
a clamp on the queen side this is
standard fare it's been around for many
years but uh neil's going bishop g7 and
actually allowing a transposition to a
perk
which is a little bit awkward for white
because of this knight on d2 and and
niels i think has played the perk in the
past so castles and
pushing that pawn through to e5 and
what's interesting is that niels decided
against playing the move uh d6 so he
tempted vaded into playing e5 and he
obliged and rather than knight e8 he's
got a knight h5
and again tempting vinid into g4 knight
comes out to f4 vivid goes knight e4 and
now i could not predict a single move in
this game you would think fiona that he
moves his knight rongo d5
attack the knight on e4
and
i guess the point is that if white had
taken on poisson in this position
black just moves the knight back to d5
and look at how exposed white's king it
king is look at how weak the g4 pawn is
black gets a big initiative here and the
engine agrees so vivid correctly
dropping his knight back keeping the
center closed but after 96 fiona an
incredible move
knight f5
sacrificing a whole piece but the point
is of course if black were to capture
the knight after g takes well what do we
see the knight on e6
simply has no squares so that piece uh
white is going to get back what a tactic
i mean i'm in shock i'm just sitting
here i feel with my my microphone like
what's going on in this game what is
surprising to me and i'm curious what
your thoughts are dania maybe we can
just get to the current position after
yes c5 and knight takes taking out the
bishop what's surprising to me is that
niels is the one who has been spending
time with um
vetted clearly not too taken aback by
this transposition
into what's more of an e4 opening and
with it being the one blitzing out those
moves i would have expected that the
surprise effect would work the other way
around and what's even more amazing is
that there are two games in the database
i'm shocked but this line has been
played before incredible
and clearly but it knows about that and
i agree with you i would expect
niels to somehow be more at home in
these offbeat
wild opening variations but
man is there nothing there is nothing
new under the sun
um and just optically speaking this does
look very good for white i mean
with the fiance bishop gone from g7
black is going to have permanent
weakness of his dark squares the main
weakness in white's position of course
is david has committed to the move g4
he's weak in the f4 square the pawn on
g4 itself is of course a weakness and
niels in french style is exerting
pressure on the d4 pawn so the key
question is how to take back on g7 you
can make a case for both moves fiona if
you take with a knight well you open up
the attack on the g4 pawn but you
relinquish some of the pressure on d4
vice versa in the event of king take g7
the king is vulnerable but you preserve
the pressure on the d4 pawn so big
decision early on for niels and
i would be terrified of playing a
position like this with black for sure
completely agreed with you and
uh well niels maybe he thought he was
gonna spring a surprise but very clearly
uh so well prepared
and
well what an exciting game in store for
us actually just before we went here and
can we bring up the bird's eye view
just one more time because from the
corner of my eyes suddenly i spotted
another game which was looking
absolutely wild i don't know if that's
just going to peter out but let's go to
yasipanko and aneesh giri
oh i think that's a i think they're
following
don't quote me on this i feel like
they're following a game from the us
championship between fabian wesley so
but
i saw something very similar so let's
break down how this happened and what
what is going
on in this position uh so this was an
italian like all good things it started
with a juco piano
okay so mainline italian and geary
opting for a very ambitious system he
goes d5 of course black can play this
with d6 or you can play it with d5
okay takes takes this is very
theoretical and very very sharp rookie
one bishop g4 knight bd2 still lots of
games in the database knight b6
h3
bishop h5 bishop b3 the other move here
is bishop uh b5
queen takes d3 and now knight takes e5
now how this works is that black takes
white's queen and white takes black
screen and white has an advantage in
that end game basically
bishop takes b3 a takes b3 white has
nicely centralized knights and white's
got white's got a pretty steady plus
here so uh geary refraining from that
instead he drops his queen back to f5
now he's hitting the f2 pawn so you
can't fork the queen and the bishop
isapenko moving his knight back giri
bringing his rook to e8 and now zepenko
going g4 of course this is a sacrifice
not a blunder bishop takes g4 you take
two pawns for the piece and white's king
is basically wide open as effectively
king h1 and knight e5
is i believe a novelty according to the
database now the idea of fiona is that
if white blindly grabs the knight
then
okay then i think it's a draw i think
the point is queen h3 check oops
apologies for that uh knight takes c5
queen h3 check
king g1 and at the very least black is a
perpetual with the move queen g3
so
that's one of the lines is there a way
for white
um the question of course is first of
all does jesse panko want to avoid the
draw i think in general and again i'm
curious to hear your thoughts especially
as a competitive player yourself my
feeling is that very often the day
before the rest day tends to be a bit
more peaceful and i think that the round
four here which is uh the last day we
had before the first rest day i think
was the one with the least decisive
results with
the most uh
like uneventful draws let's say and i i
think a lot of it is down to the players
not wanting to go into the rest they uh
on the back of a loss so what are your
thoughts and your experience with this
without without question fiona i agree
with that there's nothing worse than
entering a rest day having lost a game
particularly having lost to the white
pieces
so if i had to predict i would predict
that andre takes the 995 and that we
have our first result of the game now
the alternative just to lay it out on
the table is knight h2 you can drop the
knight back and the king
is relatively safe the problem isn't
that white's getting checkmated on the
next move it's just that what black
plays queen g6 and you know black is the
threat of knight d3 black has a lot of
long-term compensation for the
piece and coupled with the fact that
gary is clearly still in his preparation
you can kind of see a wry smile there
yeah i was gonna say
yeah
i think he's he's leaning toward taking
that knight and
in that way taking the draw
i mean it wouldn't be a terrible result
uh for either player uh anish would be
getting a lot of rest days after not
playing yesterday today potentially a
quick draw on the cards another rest day
coming up tomorrow he will be ready for
those last uh five rounds
oh he definitely will be and i just
wanted to point out one more thing about
this position after knight takes c5
uh it may appear that black has the move
queen h4 track
and that might look deadly right black
takes on f2 but it's a paper tiger
because white can just go king h3 and
black quickly runs out of checks
remember that white is now up two minor
pieces that is a lot and after queen f5
queen g4 black's so-called initiative
evaporates so gary will have to take the
draw
after knight takes e5
i saw a question in the chat and i'm i'm
gonna read it out uh from duffin hero
can dania give us his opinion on early
draws is he so passionate as has and
before i pass it to dania and i think he
will be able to elaborate uh robert it's
not early draws i think that he is
so passionate about i think it's draw
offers uh when the game is getting to
the height of excitement but danielle
let you answer
yeah i mean i think anybody who's
watched sort of my stream or knows uh my
chest playing tendency knows that in
general i'm not a fan of draws i've lost
a lot of games having taken unnecessary
risks at the same time i respect the
fact that sometimes the way that the
game unfolds right you know given the
uh the current state of
opening theory there is inevitably going
to be a just a good amount of games
today and quick draws and very often
players have considerations like being
tired like not wanting to lose before a
rest day and i think that has to be
respected you know for example i took a
quick draw in the last round of the u.s
championship i was just exhausted
you know and i didn't want to end a loss
and i i feel like that has to be honored
as legitimate
in terms of draw offers when the game is
reaching the height of excitement i
agree
completely i think that
draw offers in those kinds of situations
can result in
you know tremendously anti-climactic
situation and a lot of frustration for
chess fans but
i'm not talking about a situation like
this i don't think andre is under any
obligation let's say to go knight h2 and
i don't think players
uh should bear that in mind i think they
should make a decision based on how they
feel
and what they think is best but at the
same time i i agree that you know quick
draw offers and and draw offers to
diffuse
tension in a very interesting position
should be frowned upon
yeah so um
we will see
um we'll see what andrei comes up with
if he wants to play on
and did we look at uh rook takes
e5
rook takes e5 aha so i guess
after rook takes c5
it's funny white has i mean why can play
knight takes e5 and this is still a
perpetual
why does the q bishop takes f7 check but
unfortunately black is not going to
cooperate and after king h8 if you
decide all right i'm making the draw now
no you're not your queen is hanging so
it has to keep the bishop on b3
yeah all right all right i'll give you
the job now
something to avoid yet so basically what
we think is if andre
is happy to make a draw he will probably
take with the knight and if he wants to
play he will go for knight
h2
okay so we'll come back here we'll keep
an eye on it uh we'll let a.s.a panko
make his own decision
and
well danny my eye is going to the board
next door
i mean today there's things happening
everywhere there's an age for pawn in
karjak and i guess that's more
theoretical but what is going on in
mamedia of pragnanda why are the players
not developing any pieces why is the
queen out so early dania this is not an
opening uh like what do they say
don't
what's what's the saying don't do this
at home oh don't try this at home don't
try this at home
well the first move that really has not
been tried at home
okay so this is in english c6 is kind of
a reverse alphan variation d4 e force
totally e4 is a little bit less common
than
he takes d4 and bishop b4 check but it
it still is very well known the move
queen a4 has only been played two times
and
this is a prophylactic move white is
trying to discourage
black from uh from playing d5 the point
is that after c takes d5
uh black is unable to recapture with a
pawn but pratt going d5 anyway and now
going b5 chasing the queen away and i
think his point is that he's insisting
on being able to take on d5 with a pawn
is this preparation i don't think so i
mean prague has an hour 28 which means
he spent 12 minutes and mamadiarov now
has an hour 30. so
both players might be out of preparation
by move five perhaps for the first time
this
tournament and i just wonder fiona what
prague is intending against queen b3 uh
because
i mean do you sacrifice the pawn
and then here this is very awkward
because you can't really cover the check
on d7 or is frog intending to
to play queen takes d5 which
i don't know something about this looks
a little bit off but it's interesting
yeah i mean queen d5 uh i'd rather
definitely play that than give up upon
uh on on b5 also i'm not entirely sure
because it looks weird after if we go
back to that line after queen b3 queen
takes b5 but i guess one of the problems
for white is you just don't have so many
pieces in the game yet
and um
i don't know can you take on d5 and play
knight c3 then
how does black defend the two pawns what
is going on there yeah this is
definitely a good option i guess black
has to play bishop b4
and
white can adopt
several interesting setups here i mean i
think the straightforward move here is
bishop d2
and that kind of forces black to give up
the bishop which
frankly is not
particularly desirable i mean if you
look at these dark squares
if white plants a bishop on b4 that
might cause
a lot of trouble in terms of
black's coordination
and after knight c6 white can play e3
with the nice detail that if black
pushes this pawn down to b4
white responds with bishop b5 and then
takes the knight and wins the pawn so
i think this is a this is how mom and
dad should play he does play queen b3
i'm very curious about this game here to
me it feels like
shaq said i'm not interested today in
any
theoretical uh debate when this kid was
born and i'm saying this jokingly no
disrespect meant to pregnant but shaq
was probably already a
world junior champion one of the top
players in the world uh when frank was
was born so i think uh what shaq is
saying okay let's just get this on to
some new third
territory here and and play
and this is very much up shocks ali he's
always likes these somewhat offbeat
openings but not
openings that necessarily violate you
know tons of principles although i guess
both players
uh you know quote-unquote violating
principles of development and what's
interesting is that prague has just
played the move knight f6 and that was
the top engine recommendation i was just
going to mention it something tells me
that perhaps even though he spent a good
amount of time
maybe he did that to full shock into
believing that he's not in his
preparation this is not an easy move to
come up with fiona if you're looking at
this position for the first time now
what is the idea what happens if fight
just takes on c6 well i think the point
is that after knight takes c6 this is a
garden-variety
uh sacrifice for a lead in development
black's got two knights developed
bishops coming out to e6 and if you keep
grabbing
i mean just look at this position the
white is going to get toasted on the c
file and on the queen side
yeah so this definitely not a pawn i
want to take on b5 maybe instead can i
play e3 i'd defend my panel on d4 which
i feel is very important and attack the
bishop at upon on b5 with the bishop
and yeah
yeah i mean a6 and then
i suppose you can develop with bishop g2
but now the issue is i'll go night
before knight t3 so it's white's kind of
stuck in molasses here and this pawn on
e4 gives black this very very nice
positional blockade
uh making it difficult for white to
develop
properly
yeah and i don't know if shaq would be
so happy about the speed at which knight
f6 was played because that seems to
indicate that indeed maybe
prague
is still in somewhat familiar territory
by the way meanwhile andre has played
knight h2 so that game is going to go on
uh
a little bit longer
shall we go back to the words i
view and see what else haven't we
looked at uh just yet
absolutely yeah first of all knight h2
by andre and you know even though i said
nobody should be blamed for taking a
draw on such a position we should
absolutely take our hats off for anybody
who decides to play on even though andre
knows that gary is still in his
preparation we will see if that
very gutsy decision pays off uh drawing
your attention to dubai against duda
that seems to be the most
uh symmetrical slash mainstream position
perhaps of the day so far uh fiona we
have sort of a catalan structure we can
get to that one later but let's take a
look at the surrogate karjakin game
because i don't think h4 is actually
common
um and it's giving rehard report pause
yeah he hasn't moved since we last
stopped by here so our first french
of the tournament but i believe richard
report uh from him that's not a surprise
right he's played it before
he's played it before i mean he's
probably played every single available
move in the starting position
and he has reigned it in a little bit i
mean there was a stage in his chest
where he was literally playing like a6
and
g5 and all sorts of crazy moves and it
was working for him uh but he's dialed
it back just a tad
uh okay so playing the french and sergey
going for the advance which by the way
fiona is also not that common at this
level i mean normally we see knight c3
and
less commonly but
knight d2 is still more popular than the
advance
and
in this position queen b6 is the
traditional way of playing but knight g7
is one of the most reputable
alternatives and in this position
the main move for white is knight a3 and
bishop d3 h4 has been played
once
according to the database
[Music]
i mean what is it today
i feel that today is such a weird day
we've gotten
offbeat openings on almost every single
board and in a lot of them from very
early stages
and i think today
really is epitomizing the way that chess
opening fashions
and chess opening styles have changed
over the last couple of years i mean if
we were commentating this tournament in
2005 this would be unthinkable we would
have mainline night orbs we would have
maybe a grunfeld we would have a [ __ ]
slav uh you know or a bot vinnie a
lovely berlin wall
a berlin yeah and and even think about
five years ago tons of berlin's nine
orbs now we have all of these offbeat
openings and i think it's tremendously
exciting because the way that i think
the philosophy of the opening has
changed for a lot of players is that
they are no longer necessarily trying to
quote unquote win out of the opening
they are trying to get an offbeat
position that they are more comfortable
with than their opponent and also an
offbeat position that's
kind of anti-computer in the sense that
uh a lot of players are trying to choose
positions with a type of center or
with a certain type of structure that uh
even the top computers have a hard time
properly evaluating from a practical
standpoint
i think it's very interesting uh what
you're saying and i i think it's such
welcome news and not just for us as
commentators but also for us as transfer
just fans for you probably as well as a
chess player
as well and
yeah it's been a very exciting
development and i'm very much welcoming
that we have such a variety of of uh new
moves and new openings to look at rather
than just the same old and here well
after h4
he took quite a a big thing and decided
on knight f5 in the end
yeah which is which is totally normal
but he is provoking the move g4
and uh i guess his idea is to play
knight h6 and he's claiming that white
is going to be
quite a bit overextended on on the
king's side although after rook g1 you
also have to reckon
with the fact that the knight is now
fully excommunicated from
from the game so i have no idea what to
make of this position we'll cross that
bridge when we get there when we get
there and of course sergey
i don't really see too many alternatives
because now if you revert to mainstream
waters i i guess you could play bishop
d3
and meat c takes d4 bishop takes f5 but
something tells me that sergey might
combine i mean if you've already played
h4 the russian expression goes having
said a
you kind of have to say b and i think
where we can expect g4
well we'll find out
shortly but for now we're going to take
our first quick break of the day but
seven hugely exciting games to look
forward to today don't go anywhere we'll
be back very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think the first time
i heard about
the tournament here was um probably
sometime in 1999 uh but the first
tournament that i actually followed was
the one in in 2000 so i would say that's
my like first firm memory of the
tournament here
probably my best memory from the village
here
was the year that i i won and
people of baikon say song sang a nice
little song for for me i really
appreciated that
i think there are people in
my team who are better than me at
working with
with engines so i would say
i'm not so
good at finding ideas with it so i
generally prefer thinking on my own
solving chess is way way out there and
frankly i hope that it won't be
in a very very long time
my goal for this tournament
is to have 13 days of good preparation
and um a good mindset when coming to the
board hopefully i'll i can get back to
to my best after a couple of uh
um let's say frustrating performances
the last couple of years
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
here at the tata steel chess tournament
and dania what around it is shaping up
to be indeed we have really interesting
openings all across the board we have a
great variety of moves of variation
variations we have gimbals i mean what
what don't we have
and uh one of the most exciting games is
that of the world champion who is black
against sam shangland
and magnus playing uh an opening it
started out as the tarash defense but it
transitioned into and we were talking uh
during the break the proper name for
this is the
gambit that
sounds about right you you said you were
familiar with it i had never
never heard of it so let's see that
gambit and you can tell us daniel if
it's any good
i think it's really interesting so sam
did go for queen a4 check as we
discussed inducing bishop d7 now he
takes the pawn magnus takes on d5
now he goes knight f6 and basically the
point is that of course taking another
pawn uh just like in the
uh
which which
featured a bunch of mummy diaries
is not a good idea and actually i think
the move here's knight c6 and then the
knight comes to d4 this is obviously
very dangerous so sam going queen b3
magnus developing his knight to a6 the
knight heading for c5
and after knight f3
the knight swinging to c5 the rook
coming to ca to x-ray white's queen and
the position on the board
uh is this one sam has just played the
move e3 now of course the engine in such
cases almost always prefers white and
it's giving white a pretty sizable edge
but if you look at this from a practical
standpoint what does black's
compensation consist of well first of
all black has really nice piece
development he's going to put his bishop
on d6 he's got an x-ray down the c file
fiona i mean there's ideas like knight
a4 knight e4
uh and sam also has issues with his dark
squad bishop which is now going to
remain
kind of behind bars
for a while so i don't have any doubt
that white is probably objectively
better but this is exactly what magnus's
point is he is very clearly playing for
a win today
and he is making no qualms about it i
mean he's not hiding that fact with his
opening choice for sure and i mean we've
seen him i think lately taking more and
more liberties
with his material
and
it's been overall serving him well and
clearly magnus he's out for blood if you
saw me
smirking away from the corner of my eye
there's this chat meme i don't know
magnus was thinking hand in
um head in hand and it looks like
they're
not like this so chat always goes a
little a little crazy but thankfully
magnus has now
adapted his thinking pose
yeah this is this is just classic magnus
and he is deciding
i think between
developing his dark square bishop to d6
and
immediately trying to exploit the c file
pressure with the move knight c to e4
both of these are feasible
yeah
um what do you think which would be the
move that would be
tempting you the most
i would be more tempted by my bishop d6
just sort of keeping the tension
and well how is the game likely to
unfold here i think sam is probably
going to go bishop e2
we might have castle's castles and then
maybe a a a neutral
uh developing move such as queen e7 kind
of completing completing black's
development and then perhaps going for
a6 v5 it definitely seems to me like
black's position
uh is is easier to play and that doesn't
mean black is better magnus is about to
make a move
and of course he waited for me to say
this he's waiting for me to say this and
he's playing knight c for the second
candidate
you have to make me look that nice don't
you i'm sure it was a close toss-up
between the between the two i have to
say i am very curious to see how this
game unfolds because it's one of the
kind of positions where i've always
as a player struggle to understand how
exactly do you create the compensation
here when everything looks symmetrical
it looks like white is going to be able
to castle so i'm very curious i'm sure
magnus will answer my questions for now
let's go back to the the bird's eye view
uh
well in the essay panko against kiwi the
queens have
come off maybe we can quickly update
that
yeah what an interesting i don't even
know what to call that endgame queenless
middle game we have in the
as a panko gear game andre of course
going for
uh the win with knight h2
uh onish dropping the queen back to g6
and uh bishop c2 knight comes out to d3
essentially forcing the trade because
black threatens checkmate
okay so trade on d3 queen takes d3
knight d to f3 and onish still with over
an hour 40 on his clock trading queens
and taking that third and final kingside
pawn
holy smokes i have no idea how to
evaluate this end game and probably
neither does esapenko i mean how do you
start
uh evaluating this because
i mean
it's so tough to judge if there were
less pieces on the board if we were
closer to a pure end game then maybe
they would be more general and more
general wisdom but here how do you start
evaluating uh what is stronger the three
black kingside pawns or the white piece
yeah i mean
i guess there's a couple of questions
that that you can ask yourself to
clarify your understanding of the
position and i don't know what the
answers to those questions
are but one of the questions is who
benefits in the event of the trade of
one pair of ropes who benefits in the
event that both rooks are traded and
probably my gut instinct would be black
i think if both pairs of brooks are off
the board
it seems to me like black's pawns are
going to
uh start moving and knights are not very
good at stopping past funds i think that
white probably needs to keep the rooks
on the board and i think that for white
it's absolutely crucial to develop
the rest of his pieces and to involve
everything as actively as possible so
for instance
one way to play here would be bishop f4
i mean anish probably will go c6 and
then this knight from h2 could jump into
the action
with knight g4
and
probably the position is closer to
dynamic equality than it is to a big
advantage for either side
but the next five seven moves fiona are
going to be absolutely crucial they're
really going to set the tone for the
rest of this end game very interesting
before we move on one final question to
you you talked about the rooks which you
think white should try and keep on the
board does that also count for the the
minor pieces or uh do you think white
should be looking to maybe trade bishops
or knights or should white try and keep
as many pieces on the board as possible
that's a great question that one i think
is a lot less clear and a lot more
dependent on
where the trade occurs and under what
circumstances i think trading bishops
would be an interesting idea although
that would only leave white with knights
and as i indicated
knights are just aren't very good at uh
preventing the motion of past pawns in
the long term so
it might be an interesting idea to trade
uh one pair of knights just so that
black doesn't have his knight which can
sometimes be used as a support figure it
can jump out to c4
but man these determinations are are so
hard to make and you kind of see uh
estepanko very hard at work you're
trying to make heads or tails of this
incredibly complicated end game
absolutely and really kudos to him for
for not going for dearly
draw
there but anish well as you said he's up
a time from his clock so he has clearly
looked into this end game before and uh
well very interesting to see how things
unfold here let's go back
again
there's one game we haven't looked at
yet that's duboff against duda if
there's nothing that catches
your eye before that maybe we should
take a quick look there let's have a
look at it let's have a look at it it
does seem to be
hurtling
furiously toward a draw
but these types of positions can
actually be deceptive and if anybody has
a a slight little something then it's
it's definitely white uh also look at
the time situation daniel has only spent
a couple of minutes and
uh jkd is taking a pretty sizable
portion of his clock should we go back
to the beginning and see how we got here
it was a catalan
surprise surprise
i know never seen that one before and c5
which is one of the most reputable
variations of the catalan
and in this position white has three
main moves there's knight e5 there's
pawn takes c5
and uh dubai going for a third move
which is queen a4
okay so bishop d7 queen takes c4 and we
have a mass trade in the center c takes
d4 d4964 rook c8 essentially trying to
trade on black's own terms
which duda does he takes on d4 he
develops with tempo and then he puts the
other bishop on c6 this is a very very
important move because it disarms the
catalan bishop which is uh the surest
path to equality dubai obliges
he centralizes his rook gouda moves it
away and after bishop b3 castles
uh again dubaf trying to train on his
own terms and jan has just taken that
bishop on d4
fiona the position is very symmetrical
the likeliest result here in the early
going is a draw but
i i do think that white is a little
something something just because black
is a tiny bit cramped and after rook
takes d4 white has better control of the
d file and i think jan will have to be
accurate for the next three four moves
in order to avoid sinking a little bit
further into this slightly unpleasant
position yeah i will see
how much duboff can get out of this i do
that probably happy to get to the rest
day with a solid draw with the black
pieces he hasn't had the best start to
his event
um
so well we'll see i can do both make
something happen but definitely i think
that the most quiet and the most in the
balance game we have today so let's not
dwell here too long i bring back the
bird's eye view and i'll let you choose
anya where to go next
ah man there's so many interesting games
to explore
um
i wish we could just like look at all of
them simultaneously but we'll get to all
of them
let's have a look at how
uh the vivid game has has changed
because we're now in a very unbalanced
end game
in that game
uh we last looked at the position after
knight takes g7 after a pretty long
thing niels decided to take on g7 with
the knight
vidic playing h3 defending the pawn on
g4 nils takes on d4
and the way that the queen trade happens
is white plays bishop h6 so wait not
rushing to take back this pawn
neil's throwing in a check and vidin
blocks it with his queen we have a trade
knight takes d2 knight c6 f4 so why this
basically said i'm not
worrying about winning this pawn back at
all instead white is focusing on
creating
a intimidating pawn mass on the king's
side i love what vivid is doing because
fiona in the long run
i don't think white has to worry about
this fun white's gonna win it back you
know the knight's gonna come to b3 and
white's gonna castle and black is very
passive here i mean niels
probably has to push his f pawn maybe f6
or f5 to create more space
but if anybody's playing for an
advantage here it does seem to be white
i think this one is such a big opening
success for vidit also if we look at the
clock times vidit has barely spent any
time and neil's already down to an hour
and i'm loving
with its position
as you said usually i'm a little
concerned when i give up a pawn here i
don't need to be worried
even i can see that black isn't gonna be
able to hold on to it
and yeah just black so crammed
i agree with you that probably f6 i5
will have to be played because i don't
really see any other alternatives but it
it's also not really a move that we
love to make
no it's further weakening and okay so
ef6 if ef6 i think white's just gonna
castle and then play
yeah i mean play knight b3 knight takes
d4 this bishop on h6 is so nicely placed
and
i mean niels kind of had that type of
arrangement yesterday in sergey um he
had the like night on where was the
knight on h7 bishop on g6 there's
something
along along those lines and if you play
rook takes f6 which
uh the engine suggests then
again white can still castle long
and if black goes pawn hunting with
knight e6
why does the very nice move bishop g2
and this leads to a forced line knight
takes f4 we have a liquidation takes
takes
takes captures capture sculptures
and uh white can just take on c6
go rook hu1 and just look at how
terrible the pawn structure is the
knight's coming to b3 this is already
close to loss for black so
concerning very very concerning for nils
endgame i think some imme as you just
pointed out some immediate concerns for
nils and
even from from the camera it is clear
that niels is is not happy
with how things have gone here and um
[Music]
vidit well he is bouncing back in the
best uh
possible way at the moment he is looking
very focused and he will be looking to
get back on his winning ways
whenever i'm known sometimes on my
stream when i get tilted i i always say
that my opponent sees everything
and the word vidit or veget in russian
means he sees it's like a conjugation of
the verb to see
that's interesting i didn't it's a very
very good last name
yes for sure and well what he's seeing
here is a very pleasant
position so uh with it will be happy
here
let's move on nils uh he is thinking but
he has some big questions uh to answer
here
and
read it
yeah well we can say
if there's a tactic does he deceive the
tactic
okay if we are back anyways
in there anyways moving on swiftly
um
maybe we can check in with fabiano and
and jordan
i was thinking exactly the same thing
because that was a very interesting
variation and a rare move by fabi uh and
in particular the rare move that we were
discussing
was knight f1
uh so after f6 he goes knight up when he
gives up the e5 pawn and we fiona had
stopped at this moment jordan going
queen d6 which was indeed one of the
moves uh which had been previously
played
and uh fabi continuing his development
bishop b3 rook 88 queen e1 another very
logical move getting the queen over to
the king side jordan responds by
disarming the light squared bishop and
offering a trade which fabi accepts and
fabi has gone rook d1 this is the
position on the board
it's clear that neither side
you know is going to launch an immediate
attack against the opposing king i think
the battle has kind of transitioned to
more
positional territory as white tries to
apply pressure on black center and
jordan tries to do everything he can to
consolidate and to disarm these knights
as much as you can let me ask you you
are highlighting the two pawns in the
center and i think it's always such a
difficult question to answer over the
world but how do you deal with the
tension
in the center here as black at which
point do you want to push one of the
pawns if ever which pawn how do you
determine that
yeah i mean you kind of have to manually
consider e4 and d4 on every move i feel
like e46 comes to a really nice well
first of all e4 gives up this juicy
juicy square on d4 but i also think that
white is the move knight g3 counter
attacking the rook but more importantly
if the rook drops back you can snap off
this pawn on e4 due to the pin
the move d4
is also premature i i just don't see it
working
i mean d4 is quite interesting actually
but
i feel like
so if y plays cd4 and then knight d4
this works out for black after rook d5
but fabi can just move the bishop away
from g5 we have a move
and jordan has gone
h6 and i think partially he made this
move in order to prevent bishop g5 and
he's thinking about breaking through
with d4 it might be time for fabi to get
that knight to g3 and kick this rook
away from f5 so that it can't go to d5
at any moment
yeah very interesting
moment here
so you're saying d4 if we make a pass
move uh for white maybe we can take
another look at d4
yeah so but even here the engine seems
to
be a little bit cold toward this move
uh due to the move bishop f2 and i guess
the point is that this e4 square is is
now a tremendous weakness and white can
occupy it either with the knight or with
the queen so maybe it's still premature
maybe black should play more
you know in a more measured style move
the rook back go queen e6 uh make small
improvements to your position and
ultimately uh prepare something
resembling a essential breakthrough but
interesting so basically what you're
saying those tensions in the center and
the possible pawn pushes they just have
to be calculated basically at every turn
uh by both players
yeah virtually at every turn i mean
you know
i don't see e4 d4 being particularly
good in the next three or four moves but
that's also how blunders happen you just
kind of assume that i will d4 is never
going to be a problem uh and
you know the way that these positions go
things can change in the span of a
single half move like
white can make one little inaccuracy
and the landscape of the position can
change entirely so yeah you need to be
testing uh testing it basically on every
move
very interesting dania we are gonna go
on a short break in a minute but first
let me put you to the test if we bring
back
the overview and can you maybe in a few
in a couple of minutes tell us what is
happening in each of the games and what
are we looking forward to
when we come back after the break
absolutely let's start from the top left
the world champion magnus carlos one of
the black bases he played uh a very very
interesting gambit line he has
sacrificed upon for a long-term
uh initiative
and uh we will see if that uh gambit and
gamble pays off and mamidyar of prague
is just a crazy position uh they're
already in new territory but it may seem
like prague
has outprepared chakra so we'll keep an
eye on that one as well in esapenko
geary
anish sacrificing a piece on the king
side offering a drug via a perpetual but
yes panko kind of declining it opting
instead for a very unbalanced endgame
he's got a piece for three pawns very
unclear a french in karjakin report
sergey playing in advance they have
opposite colored bishops and the
situation has stabilized quite a bit
there gujarati did it he's got a pretty
sizable advantage in the end game after
a very unorthodox opening he's got a big
pawn mess he's got the two bishops great
position fab event for us we were just
looking at that it's a situation of two
pieces for a rook and two pawns uh a
battle over the center can jordan
preserve his superiority in the center
or will fabi uh get the upper hand by
attacking that center with his minor
pieces and finally in dubai against duda
it's a very very balanced catalan jana
kristoff should be able to make a drop
but he's going to have to make a couple
of careful moves he's got a little bit
of an unpleasant position
that was really impressive and well as
you've just heard plenty to look forward
to uh when we come back during the break
our producer big we'll be checking in
with the challengers and letting you in
on what's happening there so don't go
anywhere we'll see you shortly
[Music]
yes welcome everyone to check in with
the challengers my name is walter bick
i'm the esports producer for chess.com
and also the producer here
in waikanse and today we're checking in
with the challengers again each day
we're checking in with them because next
to the master section we also have the
challenger section and the winner of
that section will be facing in the
masters section next year uh tata still
2023 so there's a lot to play for
last time my mic was bad so i'm looking
at your chat we we do we do take these
things seriously i try to improve on
that so let's see if we can also improve
on the games that we can show and today
i'm proving by picking daniel darda
against gina zoo they were playing each
other in round number seven and boy
wasn't a manager uh or one of them we're
gonna show that right now
after the move g4 this is only 13 moves
into the game we're not that deep yet we
had b4 and look at this knight
it went to e2
after a5 it jumped to d4
and after a short castle it jumped to b5
this knight is dancing around like i'm
kind of dancing usually when i dance i
then it's like an unattended garden hose
so you don't want to see that in public
but this knight took quite the route 2b5
which was
a blunder according to the engine
because after bishop takes b5 bishop
takes
the pawns start rushing down you can see
him going it's like there's a black
friday sale in the dollar store and
these guys are going absolutely hem and
this is actually not
uh the best continuation and what is the
best continuation that's actually a
funny line after kingdom b1
a4 was actually the incredible move
c4 in this position now it seems very
odd that you push that pawn up everybody
is probably screaming on passant already
you can take your one c3 we're going to
talk about that in a bit
uh but c4 is the best move why if you
play a3
we play b3 and you're perfectly locked
in there's no way for black to pull
through all the way around you play b3
we play a3 again there's nothing going
on for right we are actually in a very
good position here so
what happens if we go on poisson
great question we actually take here on
c3 and now we have this a2 pawn which is
a very important pawn in these kind of
structures well defended with the knight
and the king
if you push the spawn we actually don't
care we're just going to move back if
you try to take it
this is where we go knight d5 pulling a
lot of pressure on this pawn and as you
can see the king hasn't castled yet so
you cannot just take
we will take with check you're gonna
have to go outside of your way and now
we can start hammering down in the
center and white is actually
a lot better so
c4 would have been the perfect move here
uh apologies after king b1
a4c4 the only line that we didn't look
at right now is queen takes c4 but this
is a very interesting one you can
already push through with e5 you cannot
capture because
we see the battery
we take this knight
we take the bishop back and we end your
chess career with queen takes d7
probably not that but it does look
sounds very menacing at least we have
that going so e5 is a very strong move
here obviously you also cannot move the
knight anywhere let's go knight to
knight to d5 which looks like a very
obvious move we will just take these
these take on d6 with the knight with
the queen we can start hammering down in
the center as well let's just go with
the queen here and
very very big nuisance now what happened
in the game
was like i said this this knight was
prancing and dancing around
like it was woodstock and after a4
king b1 we're going to see the issue
here
b3 was actually the best move here was
that plato was just a huge oversight
by the white player bishop to e3 and
this is where the fun begins for black
we take on b2 with the pawn
and after we take here
we finally up d5 we're attacking the
queen
these rooks are coming in facing the
king and after queen d2 rook b8 the
queen goes to e2 to defend and here
comes the final nail in the coffin
coughing is like i'm
playing pokemon again the coffin i do
know how to pronounce english even
though by a terrible accent you wouldn't
say so rook takes a2 and it's absolutely
over
what happens if we take our excellent
question
we give a check
if you go back
it's a shah khabat and if you take the
pawn here
there's actually a very cute little
scenario here where you go bishop a3
check
if you go
where we're going to go let's go to a2
you give another
check you give another check
and this is where the fun is going to
end
the queen is going to come in
and it is a forced mate so a beautiful
sequence there rook takes a2 and it's
all over the best move for white here
is actually
i believe c4 trying to make some room uh
in this position but as you can see we
are just going to hammer down on the
position we can already take this bishop
as it is but we can also play rook a8
and make sure that this pawn is actually
going to promote bishops coming in and
it's going to be all over so a beautiful
miniature by daniel darda who had played
two games before this
both going in the 140 move so he's
probably very happy to have uh won this
game very very soon team gets uh half a
rest day as they would say he's home
early and uh
that's the game wow
that's i don't know that was really good
i like the small miniature these
aggressive style attacks and the
challengers are going very strong let me
quickly pop up the standings here i
should have checked it but i didn't and
it's probably no uh
it's probably
no surprise that arjun aaron guys he is
still at the top uh but there are
someone in the engine is in the lead
in a chasing pack with five points so
anything can still happen in the
challenger section i've spoken enough
you guys want to go back to the master
section we're just gonna right do that
let me bring it back to fiona and daniel
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
big thank you so much for the check-in
with the challenger is always good to
keep track of what's happening there as
well but dania our main focus is of
course the master section where today i
thought we might have a quieter day
before
the rest day but at the moment the
players are certainly proving me wrong
indeed all signs fiona are pointing to
i mean already we have very interesting
positions in virtually all of the games
we have a very wide variety of different
openings uh of course it's impossible to
predict what the results are going to be
but the player is definitely feeling
very ambitious going into
uh going into the rest day as we look at
our bird's eye view here we just see all
sorts of positions on the board we have
gambits we have catalans we have a
french
we have an unnamed opening and fitted
against grendelius and this is this is
so much fun
yeah for sure and well maybe the first
position that i'm curious about to do a
more deep dive is mamedyarov against
pragnanda we left that off a while ago
and some things have been happening
my goodness i mean this position is
what is going on here i mean there's
it's like the pieces are splattered all
over the board and there seems to be
very little rhyme or reason behind
why they are where they are so let's
have a look at what happened now
you'll recall that uh in this position
pride went b5 and the knight f6 we
suspected that he might still be in this
preparation chakra ended up going bishop
g5 so he didn't take on c6 prague
checking on a5
the knight blocking on c3 b4
okay that makes sense chasing the knight
away so that black can take on d5 with a
knight and now bishop h3 by mamedyarov
and this has given
prague quite a bit of pause so the point
is that in the event of a trade
this knight from h3 is going to come to
f4 and it's going to contest
uh prague's best place piece which is
the knight on on t5 and
you know black can go knight d7 here but
also you have to bear in mind that this
pawn on c6 is a pretty serious weakness
fiona this could end up quite shaky for
black
yeah so after bishop h3 how do we as
black try and uh maintain the knight
um
so the
the engine
actually suggests keeping the bishop
unseen alive with the move knight d7
but the concerning thing for me is this
move f3
and after e takes f3 white actually
doesn't have to take back why you can go
e4
with massive complications the knight f6
and now the bishop on g5 is hanging
so we could have a trade on f6 and then
another trade on c8
and after knight takes f3 a again very
very unbalanced
position that the engine assesses as
equal
that's
in the position where you took in the
position where you took on f6 just a
couple of moves ago here in this line
i guess we could not have taken on f3
because the pawn was simply hanging in
so amazingly the reason i also thought
it was knight takes when i take c4
walks into queen e3 with very very nasty
pin here this forces f5 and that's very
weakening no the move is insane it's
knight c5
and after dc5 bishop takes h3
white has given up a very valuable light
squared bishop and white's position
starts to collapse
this game is uh
a little too messy almost i mean the
pieces are absolutely
everywhere it's once again it reminds me
a little bit of a chess 960 game rather
than normal chance because it just means
like there's pieces everywhere i'm not
sure where they've come from what they
are doing
but
i'm sure shaq will be right at home
in this and well prank he's also been
very impressive uh in how he's dealt
with things so far would you rather play
whiter black in the current position on
the board than i'd actually rather be
white i mean
i changed my mind at first i thought
okay this knight on d5 is very strong
but then i kind of realized that black
has more static weaknesses black's pawn
structure is not very healthy uh there's
a backer pawn on c6 this pawn on e4 can
also be targeted and as you as you said
fiona i think shocker are feeling great
right now because
you know he has always distinguished
himself as someone who is able to
successfully navigate you know not just
complex positions but i would even call
them chaotic or irrational positions he
is like a fish and water in these cases
so right now the ball is in prox court
and he needs to be very precise
you know
on this move and and on the next couple
of moves yeah a big fight ahead here we
see prague at the board shakia currently
away plenty to figure out i think he
will take some time so that gives us uh
the time to go back to to the overview
and see what's happening
else uh where i see that that french has
uh changed quite a bit between karyakin
and rapport i see niels has decided to
play f6 which we thought he probably
should and what
else yeah andre sepenko did indeed play
bishop f4 getting that bishop
out from c1 and
in dubob's game jan has just made a very
accurate move you can see he played
rookie 8 threatening a fork with e5
and and forcing duboff to compromise his
piece activity
just a little bit so my guess is that
that's game that game is hurtling uh
quite rapidly toward toward a peaceful
result but we can definitely look at
karjakin report and see how that's
transformed and in whose favor yeah
let's go there
very exciting position first thing i
noticed i'm always a little bit
surprised when h4 has been played and
then white suddenly castles
yeah and you know that's another that's
like a classic symbol of modern chess
this this would be unthinkable in capo
blanca's time for example and we will
remind everybody that karjakin played h4
and i was wrong i was pretty sure that
he would go g4 maybe he should have gone
g4 but sergey going for the more
conventional approach bishop d3 bishop
takes f5 and this particular structure
is very typical for the advanced french
where black plants the bishop on e6 it
blockades the pawn and although this
bishop is not good in and of itself
black's position is tremendously solid
it's very very hard to access
uh black's position he has no targets
and
then report decided to trade the other
bishop for sergey's knight
okay that's interesting
and expanding on the queen side with a5
and this is where sergey deciding to
castle in spite of playing h4
guess what rehard
immediately goes h6 and he absolutely
wanted to play g5 which is why sergey
went queen d2
queen e7 and a4 the position on the
board
is this one
i have a few questions here um if i'm
black ideally i don't want to cast on
kingside what i want to do is get g5 in
and get my king out of the way get the
other rook to g8 and try and crash
through
on the king side how realistic is my
dream danya
oh i mean you're talking to the wrong
wrong person i have a very bad influence
in that regard i'm totally contemplating
rook g8 in this position
uh but you could end up in a you know a
kind of duda situation from yesterday
where you burn all of your bridges and
before you know it your king is kind of
stranded so
uh what why can try to do is prepare his
own pawn break and white can go rook fb1
and then you have a fascinating
case of opposite side attacking g5
b4
and one issue with black's attack
is that it's very very difficult to play
g4 i mean it's not a good idea to play
g4 because look at these dark squares
look at how weak they are and if white
controls the dark squares
white disarms the attack and i think
rehard decided
even if you can take the colony it's not
worth it
yeah even if you take the pawn to nature
because i'll go g3 and then i'll lead
this knight from g2 to f4 yeah and it's
going to be very hard for black to make
further progress and reheart has castles
it has castle
i mean i get it but
and rook fb1 anyway sergey still
orienting himself toward the queen side
attack with b4
now that uh all my dreams have been um
they've been squashed they've been
yesterday
so what is my
as black what is the new plan now that
g5 is out of the picture for now
do we want to get upon breaking on the
the queen side is black ever going to
look for b5 himself or is he just going
to try and
uh face white's plans
yeah there's a couple of ways to
approach this um black would love to
play b5 but if black does the same thing
um
sergey beats him to the punch it's as
simple as that white just gets before
him first and if black insists on b5 uh
this doesn't work out i mean takes takes
and then simply b takes a5 the rook is
hanging and after rook takes b1 rook
takes b1 the pawn cannot be recaptured
so concretely this doesn't work out for
black
and that means that i think black's time
is better used in a prophylactic manner
i think what black needs to say is okay
sergey is going to go before anyway i
need to prepare myself for it there's a
couple of ways you can do that you can
play the move b6 taking some of the
sting out of b4 and using this
opportunity now to get the rook to c8
i think that the position is much closer
to equality than to any advantage for
white but this is an important moment
for rehard to tighten the screws a
little bit and make sure that b4 doesn't
come with with great effect and dania
there's a question uh in the chat
from mr goat what is the difference
between rook f2 b1 and rook a to b1
that's a great question and it's always
an important question to ask
in this case i think that the answer is
pretty straightforward
when you play a to b1
anytime you play b4 subsequently you're
going to have problems with your a4 pawn
now
the engine likes rock ab1 as well
because the thing is
let's say b6 happens and then white
plays b4
um after a takes before
bishop takes before knight takes before
rook takes before the rook actually does
protect the a4 pawn but i think sergey
just wanted to make sure
that he never experiences problems with
that pawn i really think that's the only
consideration
behind rick fb1 the rook on the f file
at the moment wasn't doing anything
there and it's hard to see maybe on the
c file there could have been something
but
yeah the apon being the main
consideration here
so we'll come back to this one i think
things will start happening soon
for now um well we can bring back the
bird's eye view for a second and i think
at some point soon we can check back in
with a certain magnus carlsen maybe
i think we should i think
there have been some really interesting
developments
so
let's
see what those developments were and
magnus has it appears reclaimed
the sacrificed one very interesting so
let's rewind a couple of moves we left
this not too long ago
when magnus went knight to e4
right and now
sam deciding to prioritize king cytobelt
and bishop t3 magnus chopping the knight
and then going after the pawn with
knight d5 so magnus delaying his own
development and instead going right
after white's c3 pawn sam says be my
guest take it
magnus says you know what i will
and this is the position on the board
wow and i saw in the chat that some
people are concerned of course there's a
lot of magnus fans in the chat and maybe
they saw the evil bar go up a little bit
i don't know what it is and does magnus
have reason to be concerned here do you
think he's happy
well it's hard to say and i think sam
should probably start with the move
bishop b2 notice that there are no
dangerous discoveries along the c file
if you play knight takes a2
that's not going to turn out well i mean
just look at black's king it's going to
be caught on the crossfire here so in
this position magnus is best advised to
play bishop b4 and maintain that knight
on c3 no i think
this is just a very complex position sam
has some issues with his queen placement
um because if you play queen b3 here
magnus supports the knight with a5 and
guess what uh a very cool line if white
plays a3
bishop a4 and the queen is literally
trapped that's pretty crazy line
i love the sound effects
well you know it has to be sufficient
sufficiently illustrative of what
happens when the queen is trapped it's
taken away from you so amazingly the
engine suggests
drum roll please wait for it bishop
unbelievable move i don't think sam's
playing that he is about to make a move
i didn't even notice that pawn hanging
there in the corner like my eye i didn't
either
oh my goodness how often do you take
that pawn like one time out of a hundred
uh in a situation where black hasn't
castled yet okay sam plays bishop b2 i
think we'll see this on the board
i think we are likely to see this this
position on the board magnus magnus can
move his knife back but that's a huge
concession fiona because that gives the
bishop just a monster diagonal but
things are really heating up here and
getting
more and more concrete
i think sam probably has got to be happy
i mean he said he was so looking forward
to his match against magnus carson and
he's got himself a big fight uh which is
certainly what he was hoping for
yeah absolutely sam likes concrete
positions he loves complex positions
uh positions that are heavy on
calculation he believes that his uh
ability to calculate these types of
positions out is
uh you know is he's one of the best in
the world at it and uh he's not
delusional he's right he's got the
rating and the results to back it up
um i think he is excited about having
this kind of position against magnus now
another possibility after bishop b4
um
white can go queen b3
a5 and then
if he wants he can take this knight on
c3 this doesn't this is not out of the
question rook takes c3 as a fork but the
queen can drop to d5 and
obviously protect the bishop it looks
precarious no
it does but but here white has the move
queen e5 check
and if you cover the check with a queen
you're gonna lose the pawn on g7 so
black will be forced to to move the king
to f8 white can go bishop before it is
extremely precarious but i think this is
where sam excels i think he's not afraid
uh to walk on hot coals so to speak if
he believes in his calculation
and he could just well magnus he rarely
loses any games
but who knows sam he will be very eager
he had a big win in vikenzie a few years
back
beating kramnik in his last competitive
game in classical jazz and he will be
looking for another big scalp today we
can see him there working hard at the
board there is so much to calculate but
he is hyper focused
a very exciting game we'll come back
here very shortly
yeah you're right on the money sam
doesn't really play for draws and he
knows that if you beat magnus carlsen
once in a classical game that's an
achievement you can look back on for the
rest of your life as as one should
and
he'll be working hard at this
opportunity yeah
for sure
we see jordan there looking a little bit
perplexed on the live
camera his game hasn't changed too much
for now he's dropped the rook back
uh i'll swear
oh we had a trade and this is
interesting espanko geary did indeed
trade bishops
let's go back there let's update uh that
game
yeah let's see how that how that has
impacted uh the state of affairs on the
board so andre
in in the position we were looking at
here played bishop f4 c6
and i had mentioned knight g4 as a
possibility he goes rook d2 uh inviting
a trait of bishops which on ish accepts
bishop e3
takes takes
and
again i i sort of
thought that the trade of bishops
doesn't necessarily favor either side
it's hard to say
uh what can we expect here from andre
well rook ad1 is is very tempting here
and then probably onnish will go rook 88
you know fiona i'm a little bit worried
about white white's position here
because once these pawns start rolling
things get hairy pretty darn fast i was
thinking about this last time we left it
off especially if andreas depenko it's
always tough you always have this
thought at the back of your mind
i could have made a draw here a long
time ago if i wanted it and could have
been
back in the room or having a walk on the
beach you know looking forward to a rest
day and
well now that pawn
mass is gonna start moving at some point
one question that i one thing i was
wondering about uh
can we somehow as white start putting
pressure immediately is there something
to be said for bringing a work to the g
file maybe to the f file
and just trying putting some pressure on
these pawns or will that not lead anyway
absolutely it should be considered i
mean
i think the point of doubling rooks
could be to induce the move g6 well why
is that good for white well it you know
black now has to deal with the weakness
of the f6 and h6 squares unfortunately
i'm just not sure how to exploit that
and this is where white's passive pieces
come into play because you can't play
knight g4
um you have to burn a tempo to move the
other knight out of the way
but now black can just ignore everything
and go knight c4 after a knight g4 it
looks like black's blundered because
white's threatening a fork but no rook
h3 check
and after for example rook h2 we have a
trade
and i think black can disarm white's
initiative with the move
uh king g7 defending the f6 square so
it's an interesting idea but and maybe
andre is trying to make it work he's
down to 42 minutes
and in a position this complex that is
not a lot of time
no indeed um anish here displaying some
nice preparation also i think a nice uh
psychological choice by anish who he got
a free point yesterday today no question
about it he probably would have been
happy uh with a quick draw with the the
black pieces and uh when he plays that
line while the onus is all on yasipanko
to make the big decision for the two of
them is it gonna be a quick draw will
they play and i think sometimes
um
it's almost like a little gamble where
you're asking your opponent well what
are you gonna do are you just gonna call
it a draw without trying with the white
pieces and do you sometimes feel and
that's what there is almost a little bit
of pressure on the white player to be
like no i ha i sort of have to play i'm
i have the white pieces after all
oh absolutely and i think openings like
the berlin also inherently contain that
pressure because first of all white does
have a horse draw
and white has you know why can play
rookie one in the berlin and essentially
get a risk-free position you're also
probably not gonna win
um but but this type of way this way of
playing it is very very effective
because
uh you know every anybody's gonna be
torn drawing any scary is that's not a
bad result and as you said andre is
probably thinking it could be in the
warm
uh heated hotel room watching a nice
movie under the covers watching the rest
of the games
and he's a big football fan as well i
think it's a premier league today
yesterday he pretty much ran off
from the inter
so
could be thinking about that as well
could be watching iceland i think he's
actually an arsenal fan i was just
looking arsenal
arsenal's match ditches start half an
hour ago so maybe that's something else
that's on his mind right now
yeah i could have been watching i could
have got the whole game
but no i had to go for the win and now
i'm i'm suffering in an end game i don't
think he's suffering i don't think white
is worse and the engine is giving
uh equality which which makes sense i
mean uh these positions tend to be quite
balanced
but andre
i mean he he has to be very very
cautious the next couple of moves maybe
knight d4
is the right approach you're trying to
swing the knight over to f5 kind of like
your idea attacking lex kingside before
the pawns get rolling i don't know
yeah well he has his work cut out for
him
i don't think he'll be watching any
football today this isn't gonna end
anytime soon at this point
um meanwhile
elsewhere where should we
maybe update
well first of all i'll point out two
things in the kuryakyn report game
they're heading down the line we
discussed rook fc8 b4 b6
so report keeping the tension on that
queen side carlson did indeed uh respond
with bishop b4
and
yeah duba versus duda continues to look
more and more symmetrical there are some
up developments in the karwanov and
forest game let's go there then
let's do it and andre does go knight d4
by the way
mm-hmm
okay
ooh
this might actually be a repetition i
want to say so let's see we we joined
the game
we last looked around this moment jordan
played h6 right
um fabi responds with bishop f2 clearing
away space for the night jordan dropping
the rook back prophylaxis against knight
e3
fabi going bishop g3 and the check on c5
and the petition you're just mentioning
i guess means that fabiano could play
bishop f2
um but you're then dropping back the
queen to d6 so that's a possible
repetition now the question is fabiano
with white pieces going into the game of
course would never have agreed to an
early uh repetition but here what are
the alternatives if not bishop f2
first of all you're contracting h1 but
here i think jordan
will play d4 i think he's gonna push
that pawn
and his pieces are very nicely
positioned uh to support not only this
pawn but also the c7 pawn which is going
to be defended by the rook after a trade
and see the thing is white has a hard
time exploiting the weakness on e4 if
you if you just stick a queen there
that's not really gonna content black's
gonna play d takes c3 and why is that
dangerous well after rook takes the
knight takes d8
bc3 queen c3 black's taking another pawn
look at black superiority on the queen
side black also has f-file pressure this
is not very appetizing
um
so i'm not too enthralled with this
option i think fabi's going to repeat
once
and
i think that the big decision is going
to be whether uh to play bishop g3 on
the next move my guess if i had to
predict is going to be that we're going
to see a repetition by the way jordan
can play d4 even here not out of the
question but i think fabi might choose a
different move here such as knight e3
well very i'm very curious to find out
what happens here does the game go on uh
does fabi go for the repetition does
jordan go for the repetition we will
find out uh after the break we're gonna
take a quick breather but don't go
anywhere very exciting round and we'll
be back very shortly
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight at
the tata steel chess tournament a
tremendously exciting day ahead of
tomorrow's uh rest day dania there is
maybe a couple of games where we think
they might end peacefully but elsewhere
uh there's so much going on
yeah well again dubai
against duda is rapidly
hurtling toward the draw i mean you see
knight t5 there that's there's going to
be a trade of knights and there's very
likely going to be a draw for
uh shortly
so that's really the only game that's on
the cusp of ending
um as for the other games i mean let's
mention just uh the karana van forest
right where we were thinking we repeated
once yeah they repeated once hopefully
not more than not more than twice but we
will see
yeah we'll see i mean
fabi
has a pretty big choice to make of
course he doesn't want to over
uh and and that's always a difficult
decision to make he's on 50 so my gut
instinct would be that he he's probably
going to play i mean
he he needs to take a lot of risks if if
he wants to finish uh closer to the top
of the tournament standings and white
against van forest is a game that he
really has to try to win so we'll see
uh whether fabby goes for it
we also have a couple of developments in
the sergei karjakin game
shall we go to that one because in the
other games i think they're still
uh
you know
basically at moments where we looked
let's go to karjakin and immediately the
first thing we notice is some pressure
on that pawn on a5
yep rook swinging out to b5 attacking
the pawn so just to remind everybody in
this situation report i think he played
correctly rook fc 8 before and now just
b6 keeping the tension
sergey deciding to release the tension b
takes a5
bishop takes a5 and rook b5 so
um
i think black has to defend the pawn and
he probably has to do it with the move
queen a7
when okay sergey is going to be likely
to go rook b1 doubling on the b file
maybe preparing for b7 and
the engine is giving an interesting move
queen a6
prophylaxis what is it prophylaxis
against well it kind of immobilizes the
rook because if the rook moves up the
queen swings to c4 and that gives black
unnecessary activity
uh so this reaches kind of a weird
standoff
where black also kind of wants to play
rook c4 i think the position is quite
balanced it looks good for white but if
reheart is careful i think you shouldn't
have any problems here yeah so looks
like he is nicely neutralized we didn't
get the pawn storm we were hoping for
early on with g5 he had taken a more
solid
approach but it looks like things are
under control here for him at the moment
so let's go
let's go back again uh maybe you can
quickly check in actually with duboff
and duda
and see uh the pieces come off there
maybe we'll even catch a handshake who
knows
we are likely to catch a handshake now
um what happened here i i think duda
made a very accurate move uh in this
position let's rewind five or six moves
rookie eight i mentioned it he's
preparing e5
and this kind of forces dubois to
initiate further trades
okay so he trades on d6 now duda
reclaims uh the d file while there's a
lot of words that do that
uh then he makes some luft and then he
goes queen c6 and a6 and knight d5
forcing the nitrate
uh completely symmetrical position no
weaknesses for either side
and you can kind of see
i think dubois looking up at his
opponent
you know those wordless exchanges often
mean
we're about to see a handshake i think
the simplest for black is to play queen
d2
this forces a queen train in fact i'm
quite confident that we're going to see
this queen takes c2 rook takes d2 and
now it looks like white loses a pawn but
no he doesn't he can give a check
and basically do the same thing the
black is doing rook c7
and
you know basically mass liquidation is
is inevitable takes takes takes
uh something like this is likely to
happen and around this point i think
a draw will be very likely yeah and i
think you're absolutely correct when
duboff made his last move b3 we sort of
saw him look up i had to do that which
very often is a sign of a peaceful
outcome to follow shortly
for now duda is still thinking so we'll
move on from here but
yeah very likely this game will end
peacefully soon um
maybe we can well not much has happened
in shankland against carlson but the
players are starting to spend
a lot of time
um
yeah sam is yeah sam is taking
a long time after bishop before which we
kind of anticipated because
uh his queen doesn't have
any clear spots to go to we were
discussing queen b3 a5 and duda just
made a move by the way and it
is it queen d2 it is queen d2
it is queen too yeah maybe we can go
back to vidit against grandelias
let's do it yeah there have been a
couple of moves in that game
okay so
f6 e takes f6
now neil's deciding to take with a pawn
there's really no appealing option here
and vivid castling long so to remind
everybody the idea i think for white is
to ultimately reclaim this pawn
uh by swing swinging the knight to f3 or
to b3
black would love to meet that with
knight e6 but it's not easy to do i mean
i guess black could try to go rookie 8
but after knight b3
96 white goes bishop g2 and now he hits
him where it hurts on the d5 pawn
black's position just starts to crumble
here
i mean it looks so tough uh for niels
who is also lagging behind on the clock
only 45 minutes already we're only on
move
17.
is there any way that black can look for
some active counter play maybe on the
queen side
that's a good question i mean
like could i suppose try something like
a5
but i'm not entirely sure where it leads
i think that
rookie 8 is probably a reasonable way to
start controlling the e-file
and oh my goodness after knight b3 there
is an insane idea
bishop f5
wow
and it looks like it fails for two
reasons first of all looks like you're
running a bishop but no you're not after
knight takes that f5 the bishop on h6 is
trapped
but the secondary reason seems to be
bishop takes g7 and here there's the
bishop before counter-attacking the rook
the rook has to move after king takes g7
black is completely fine so it turns out
that knight b3 is actually a serious
mistake and in this position white
should start with the move bishop g2 to
avoid that my goodness that's an incred
i mean bishop f5 is such an incredible
move
it really is and it comes out of nowhere
i mean that bishop on h6 looks perfectly
safe in conjunction with the g4 pawn and
knight f5 is never possible and that's
exactly the point you're trying to get
rid of the jeep on
uh to activate the knight
that's a cool resource incredible
incredible stuff
there
so
after rookie 8 but bishop g2 seems to
keep things under control
and yeah vintages with a a comfortable
uh advantage here it seems
yeah the engine move fears f5 also makes
sense kind of to your point trying to
create counter play yeah on the king
side rather than the queens but white
just goes rook g1
and the key
for white is to keep this pawn alive on
g4 because it totally limits the knight
and again black has to solve
you know this just procrastinates on the
problems black is facing which is that
you know white threatens to win this
pawn and then win the d5 pawn basically
just win the game
i am
grenellis is in is in dire shape here
he's in big big trouble
for sure and uh well dania let's quickly
bring back the bird's eye view because
mr big he is wondering we thought we
were going to see a quick handshake in
in or in dubai of duda
but he is wondering has duboff slightly
misplayed this can do both have uh can
duda have something here
uh let's have a look let's go back to
that game uh because again we don't have
too many other developments uh we have a
couple of moves in chakra's game and
shanklin's game but let's let's very
quickly revisit the do bob game and then
we'll move on
um do you see how how nice i am to to
the producer i'm sure he appreciates it
he's sending some
hearts
and so we left this one off after queen
d2 and we were expecting
uh a quick liquidation
so the queens did come off
the queens did come off and
duboff did go rook c8 track but rather
than going rook c7 he went thing f2 so
he offers the a pawn
and in return he wanted to go rook c7
but duda doesn't take it dude it goes b5
and i guess the point is that if white
plays a4
if y plays a4 oh duboff might have
missed this white takes on a4
and now it looks totally drawn right no
rook d4
a5 rook d5 you lose the pawn
you lose the pawn and you're going to be
tortured here for another three hours
that's the time
this is a serious inaccuracy by daniel
now he can go rook c7
but black still goes king g6 i think he
just lost the pawn i think and i think
we can tell it from his body language as
well like maybe there was just one
moment of inattention and
he thought the game was pretty close to
to being over
and sometimes it just happens i think
you let your guard down for one second
and uh yeah you must have just missed
this resource by baiduta this is a
shocking oversight because
you know the move b5 is is something you
you have to consider you know it's
prophylaxis against 67.
and i don't think everything has been
lost here for duba but i think he has to
go for that position i mean i would
throw in this move just to force black's
king onto an awkward spot
and i would basically go for
for this position maybe throw an a5 just
uh you know why not
and and you can you can make a move like
g4 expanding on the king side
and perhaps even h4 just trying to stop
black's king from
uh ever making any progress and then he
parked the rook behind the pawn it
should be a draw
but
it's a very frustrating thought
defending this when you literally just
had
this position i mean un seemingly
unlosable is
you know requires tremendous
psychological gumption and
my goodness if duda wins this game that
would be absolutely ridiculous that
would be crazy i mean uh duboff he's
gonna have to recal recalibrate because
one moment you think this game uh is
over will will sign the drawing in a
second
and then b5 appears on the board and you
realize you just completely missed this
and now well the game is nowhere near
over and you're gonna have to defend
this work ending upon down uh for the
coming maybe a few hours even
yeah no this is definitely going to be
a very difficult a struggle session as
duboff takes off his blazer there
preparing himself for the long road
ahead
man and i think he's just rushed and i
think he played too quickly you know he
has over an hour on the clock just kind
of i think he kind of automatically
assumed that duda was going to take the
pawn and he was looking forward to a
draw for and you know this happens to
everybody you
in your mind the game is already over
you're
not losing there's no way to lose it
it's going to end in a draw
and you lose a little bit of your
objectivity as you into that
yeah and well hopefully for him
he can hold on but now it's going to be
a whole different story here we'll come
back to this i thought i think we both
thought we were never coming back to
this game it was gonna be over by the
next time
but now we'll have plenty of time uh to
come back to it um and we do have a
result elsewhere though as the game
between sergey kowyakin and richard
report has ended in a draw
it has and they did find a repetition in
the position we last looked at uh rehard
deciding on
queen c7 we were talking about queen a7
he makes a very similar move and sergey
deciding that he just doesn't have
any targets the pawn on a5 is safely
defended and there's always this idea of
going bishop d7 and skewering the a pawn
if the rook leaves a one and so deciding
uh sorry deciding that the best course
of action is just to repeat rook b5 rook
c5
a handshake a solid game i think a good
job by rehard to deal with that move h4
uh
and i think that sergey maybe will look
back and say that perhaps uh
the move g4 on move seven would have
been a
you know a more ambitious try i mean the
engine approved of it and i think after
bishop d3 this just gives black such a
solid position a good job i buy report
drawing with black to go into the
resting yeah pity we didn't see the the
g4 action but indeed a solid game here
looks like both players were happy with
the draw in the end so we can go back to
uh to the bird's eye view and see
some of the players we've had some moves
in shankland against carlson so maybe we
go back they are also mermaid against
pragnanda seems to be heating up
yeah let's start maybe with a shankling
game
and then we'll go to shakuryar's game
so sam
deciding in this critical position we
were discussing queen b3 and then bishop
takes c3 he plays bishop take c3
immediately
magnus recapturing with the bishop and
sam going rook 81.
now it's quite clear to me that magnus
has solved his opening problems i mean
material equality has been restored
uh and i mean he can go b6 if he wants
but sam's idea might be bishop a6 here
and then a very nasty check on e4
so
magnus might be better advised to get
this bishop out of the way first just so
he doesn't have to worry about it then
after queen e2
either rook c7
or b6 and i would actually prefer to be
black here yeah i was just gonna ask you
now that the material balance has been
restored
and the bishop pair here it looks like
an open position uh where the bishops
should be doing well so they're what's
there not to like for black
yeah two bishops and a
distant upon majority so that virtually
any pawn end game any end game at all is
going to be troublesome for white
because of the possibility of an outside
passer uh for black and i always like to
talk about who's got the numerically
smaller pawn majority both sides have
their upon majorities but white has a
four on three and black has a two on one
the smaller the total quantity of pawns
the easier it is to make a pass spawn
right black just needs to go b5 b4 a5 a4
and then he's ready to create a password
for white
it's going to involve you know moving
tons of pawns forward
uh and
it's a lot less certain so the engine is
still giving equality due to this move
knight d4 fiona and sam probably does
have to find this move uh if he wants to
be completely fine and after castles the
point is that white can go knight b5 and
very importantly force a trade otherwise
a7 is going to hang and this is quite
close to a draw
because of the opposite colored bishops
yeah so maybe a crucial moment here with
some uh having having to find uh this
knight d4 idea
um well magnus to play first of course
we'll come back to here let's uh check
in with shakhem ahmedarov and pragnanda
indeed and they're following a path that
we
kind of discussed as being rather
undesirable for prague who by the way is
31 minutes now after
only 13 moves that's crazy so after
bishop h3
he decided not to refrain from the trade
in fact he took on h3
knight takes h397 chakrillar hitting
where it hurts rook c1
ragnanda chasing the bishop away and
then going rook ca and this move f3 i
think might have been underestimated by
prague
once again if he takes f3
i think chakriar he can go e4
immediately or he can take with the
queen and very quickly play e4 if you
don't know this gets really unpleasant
like that f file and e4 is coming i mean
black's starting to get blown off the
board here the king that's still stuck
on the eight it's nowhere near castling
yet with the bishop still on
on f8 and we both said that i think
shakia he um
well he played an offbeat uh
early queen a4 and i think he got just
what he wanted he he got prague out of
book he got all his pieces into play
prague has made a move uh he has played
knight f6 yeah but
night hf2 i think simply knight hf2 this
forces he takes f3
and
after either e4 immediately or queen
takes f3 black is in huge trouble here
huge trouble and there's so many
weaknesses
white can probably just castle anytime
he likes uh bring an extra piece into
the attack by uh the rook will be on the
f file white has the center
black has all these weaknesses you're
highlighting and i would not want to be
prague here
no it's just bad it's bad and obviously
black can take on a2 but this is the
pawn chakra cares about least
e4 knight b6 castles and
first on 93 knight f5 e5
i would go so far as to say that this
is looking
probably not completely lost or anything
like that but
incredibly troublesome and he's also
doesn't have a lot of time on top of
that so
well let's remind you all at home that
he is only half a point between uh half
a point behind magnus carlsen
so he will be looking uh he'll also i'm
sure have an eye on the magnus game from
the corner of his eye
but he has been
very impressive in this event so far and
he is firmly in control here uh well
more than firmly in control he's much
better against prague
and i'm i'm quite confident that he's
going to play knight f2
he is an excellent form this tournament
and for prague
you know that game yesterday might be
eating away at him that move knight g5
probably wasn't his dreams or nightmares
this morning
and despite some really enterprising
opening play it just seems like things
have once again taken a turn for the
worse
for the young indian grandmaster indeed
we will come back here later like you i
expect shaq to play and knight f2 but
for now let's go back to the bird's eye
view
we see that uh danny duboff he has gone
down the path you suggested he will have
to defend
this
with a minus pawn
uh yes i panko he hasn't doubled the
rooks on the g file but instead on the f
file maybe we can quickly go back there
let's have a look yeah that's an
interesting idea
uh adopted by andre
so he has gone
all right so we had the trade on e3
he played knight d4 on activating his
knight as well
and then doubling up his rook so both
sides have doubled their ropes
and i think andre's point here
is that if black plays f6 i think f6 is
a very serious mistake why is that
because it it weakens the king's side
just enough to give white
okay maybe serious mistake is an
overstatement but this gives white a lot
of activity i mean rook g1 is coming on
the next move
on the other hand
black can play rookie too but i really
like what geary just did he went knight
d6 he said you know what i'm not
weakening my king side one bit and this
knight on d6 is discouraging andre's
knight from coming to f5 he can still
play knight f5 but i'm not sure that the
trade of knights necessarily favors
white here i would take black here any
day of the week especially given the
time situation yeah anish has got to be
very happy uh with
where the opening has brought him what
i'm curious about if i'm here sepenko
now um how do i proceed to i try and
activate my king i'm also concerned a
little bit about that knight on h2 i
would love to get that into the game but
uh i'm not sure what the best way is
yeah if you just sort of throw the
knight in with knight g4 it's not going
to get you much because of rook g3
and
the knight has nowhere to go white is
forced to go rook g2 and
at the least black can take
take and then play h5 and here come the
pawns
the knight is totally limited by this
very nicely placed rook on the open file
this is not the end of the world for
white the game goes on but geary can
continue with c5 and this just shows
that knights aren't very good in these
types of positions
when they're when they can be attacked
by pawns they're constantly jumping
around
and you know it's just hard to find an
anchor point for for the knights in this
position
and i'm not gonna lie as soon as h5
appears on the board if i put myself in
yes panko's shoes this is where the
doubts start creeping in then the fear
at least for me i would start getting
fearful that is only the first pawn but
the other two won't be far behind
and so he will have to
i think find some very accurate
moves here to stay in the game against
uh anish and yeah as you mentioned the
clock situation
another thing to watch out for
but for now let's move on again from
here where do you want to go back to
well first of all um
i should point out that fabian i think
is still thinking
about whether or not
wait is he thinking about others
so i think
or did he make a i think he made a move
yeah he did make a different move he
chose not to repeat so let's have a look
he played the move
queen e2 in this position
which is kind of a neutral move just
getting his queen
to a slightly more active square you
know fiona i'm not sure about this i
think after rook dfa black might be a
little bit better i think i agree with
the evil bar here
and the reason why
is is that if you play bishop g3
uh black can give a check
and if you decide to repeat now the
queen can swing back to e7
the point being if you take a pawn on d5
then after e4 white is busted i mean
look at those minor pieces they're all
the f file and they're all sitting ducks
and suddenly we see that pawn center
come to life in this line we've been
talking about you have to watch out
for for d4 and e4 at every turn while
here which would already be too late but
yeah you're the nafta rook to evade that
pressure along the f-file
um
i would be concerned here as well i
would definitely
take take black here
and i'm curious how is how is fabi going
to to proceed
uh is there already a concrete threat in
the position here if white makes a a
pass move yeah yeah e4 e4 is already it
is a threat because well if the knight
moves you take on f2 and if white goes
bishop g3
fabi put the queen on e2 just now and it
will really hurt him in this scenario so
he has to do something about this i i
think it's likely he goes bishop g3
and he might
repeat and hope that jordan goes queen
d6
and against queen e7 you can still play
bishop g3 here
because now the movie four is met with
knight d4 and the knight and f1 is
protected i think
i would give it about a 40 to 50 chance
that we actually see a repetition in
this position
well we'll see i'm i'm curious dania
yesterday in the interview jordan said
you know he felt that he was trying to
play more solidly and that maybe overall
as a player over the last couple of
years he'd become more solid but then
clearly this tournament proved him wrong
as you know as i mentioned earlier he's
had six decisive results out of seven
games
and i saw a comment here uh in the chat
by edge cadet
saying jordan trying to be solid but
somehow he somehow finds himself in a
volatile game once again
i don't know do i agree um
if you're then try to be solid in this
game what do you think dania isn't
jordan the one who initiated all this
with this line in the the open spanish
yeah and you know i think that some
people have an overrated perception of
to what degree this intention to be
solid is actually impacting players
decisions i think it's a lot more about
uh the kind of objective analysis than
it is about playing solidly or playing
sharp lines i don't even think that
these players necessarily categorize
their opening choices like when jordan
was analyzing knight takes f2 right i
think it was more that
maybe jordan and his and his second
just found that black has a good
position there all of these players are
capable of playing any position whether
it's solid or sharp so i really don't
think it's factoring all that much into
jordan's decision making it's not like
he's consciously trying to produce more
decisive games uh you know all these
players they play the position
uh rather than trying to steer things
into a particular kind of direction that
was more feasible maybe 30 40 years ago
when opening theory was more limited
somebody like tigra and petrossian
really could steer the game uh pretty
reliably into positional territory let's
say um nowadays it's uh everybody's
universal and it's just harder to do so
i think it's just how the tournament
tends to go more than a conscious
decision
i think that's a very good point i am
still curious here fabiano still
considering his options will we see
a repetition now in this position i hope
not but we will come and come back here
we see that
if we go there for one second because
only one one move has been played oh no
actually a couple more so maybe we can
update a disaster this is a disaster and
it's and it's becoming more of a
disaster with every move i think here
prague
um according to the engine he did have a
chance
uh to play the move queen b5 i mean i'm
sure he saw this move this move is
straightforward you're threatening mate
after queen takes f3 the point
is that the knight can actually swing
back through c7 and try to go to e6 to
at least pressure perhaps the only
target in white's position the pawn on
d4 black is still much worse here but uh
i think this is a little bit more
double-edged instead
dropping the knight to b6 after castles
i don't think the evol bar is
overstating it if black plays bishop b7
here
this knight from d1 swings over to f5
fiona the king has nowhere to go it's
going to get mated on the king side
this is looking closer and closer to
just being lost for black yeah i mean
this is an absolute nightmare for prague
it's
once again it was a weird game where in
the opening he seemed to be the one i
remember when he played knight f6 we
were quite impressed that he would still
be familiar with this position and then
suddenly things turned around so quickly
and i don't know danya if you can
pinpoint the moment uh where it all went
wrong for danya because somehow
for prank because somehow it all
happened so quickly
it really did and i think you're asking
the right question it is a little bit
hard to to understand like how did
things go wrong so quickly
and i first of all i think chakriar
played
divinely i think all of bishop h3 was an
amazing move
and i think the the key moment was here
i think the move knight d7
uh would have preserved
a double edge because although 97
there's always this f3 move and the
engine keeps swinging on its eval but
practically speaking i just think
white's having a lot more fun with all
the center play
so we might even have to go back earlier
it might just be fiona that prague's
entire opening campaign
is just not practical and this move
bishop g5 might be the the practical
refutation
and if chakra found this over the board
then that's even more impressive
that's crazy yeah what a strange game
you have got to feel for prague who i
mean as we've just seen never really got
into the game uh prague uh shakhtar is
putting pressure from the get-go taking
him out of known territory and right now
he is in his element
he has got a
near-winning position
and
[Music]
tough spot for prague but we will come
back to this game and the remaining five
after a short break so don't go anywhere
and we'll be back soon
i just want to say i know it's early
yeah it's early for all of us but fabi
you're looking fresh no thanks danny
chad likes it man looking good
what about me
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go and fabi this video series
was great by the way people love it
i really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man i love
your new haircut makes me good
[Music]
i don't even recognize myself you know
the whole new me
[Music]
hey fabi dan how's it going hey robert
hey man
you know i'm just trying out a few new
things here and there the day's
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey danny yeah forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you yeah
thanks man
cool
appreciate it
serious
what does a guy gotta do around you to
get noticed
what are you talking about
i
seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without him what more does he want
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a very long tournament that
actually i mean if you manage to do well
in the starting like four or five rounds
and it's very interesting like you're in
costa contest for something you don't
you don't even know what exactly but it
feels like you're fighting for uh for
something maybe as a first place even if
you if you do badly isn't and then it
can be depressing yes but in general
like at the end of the day you you
always have to play chess and you need
to be
like ready to play those long games
yeah i think my first experience
was when i was like 17 i guess
i played the b tournament
yeah it was tricky
you actually have to love love chess
very much to you know to feel
comfortable here uh which yeah which i
hope is my case
here there is no real alternative so you
are actually fine with playing long
games and i mean okay it's your favorite
game you just play moves and you yeah
try to enjoy it
when i came for the first time like i
saw the sun exactly three times there
were exactly three three sunny days and
this was funny like it was very
very easy to to predict my results so
this time i'm also like i i really want
to do well but i know that when i see
the sun it's probably time to
you know to to give it a shot and when
you don't see the sun you should to be
in super strong mode and
you know like
better times will come yeah
interesting to hear daniel do both spots
on the sunny weather in waikenzee and
well at the time this was filmed before
the start of the tournament he couldn't
have known but danya i can tell you it
hasn't been a very sunny year here in
vikken they have seen the sun maybe a
couple of times but that's about it
yeah i remember my first time in
vacancies
walking out of the hotel and it's pretty
it's especially windy near the main
hotel
and i had a hard time just making it to
the playing hall i was like wow
and uh
yeah it's not sunny on the chess board
either for for daniel dubov who is in
this situation
through
some sort of sorcery from the part of
yom chistop dude that this game should
have been over 10 minutes ago and that's
probably what's going through duboff
said i should never
put myself in a situation where i'm down
upon you can see the frustration uh in
his body language but let me be very
clear this game should still end in a
try he should still be able to hold this
together
yeah i guess one of the big questions in
this spot is how
and how quickly do you recover mentally
from the frustration that you're still
at the board that you now suddenly have
to work to defend this uh ending upon
that i think daniel strikes me as the
type who will not let it affect him too
badly um how easy is it to to draw this
position objectively speaking
it's hard to say um and i just want to
kind of give a
overview of how these types of end games
are likely to go i mean there's a whole
category of end games where you have a
three on three or four and four on one
side and then the other on the other
side there's a pass pawn that's
supported by a rook
just like it is here
what i think duval's approach should be
first of all i think he should play g4
he needs to build up the pawn chain so
that all the pawns defend each other and
what will happen if black advances the
pawn to a2 well let's test that out
let's say that dubock puts his rook on
c7 and let's say that jan just pushes
his pawn and pushes the spot and again i
would not trust the eval bar i would not
trust the computer evaluation even
computers require a lot of thinking time
to make heads or tails of these kinds of
positions so the key question who
benefits
and who wins in
the event of this position the hard part
for black is to figure out a way fiona
to get this rook out of a1 if you do it
at the wrong moment then white will just
capture the pawn on a2 if you try to
walk the king to b2 what's gonna end up
happening
is that as soon as the king reaches
b2 white gives a check and then the
moment the king disattaches itself from
the pawn the rook goes back to a7
but what black can try to do is make
progress on the king side and try to
worm the king around let's say to h4 so
there's a lot of complexity that occurs
in these types of positions and dubai
has to set himself up in the right way
knowing that this kind of situation
might occur he decided to play f4
for an interesting
decision
i guess one of the the question is how
do you keep the blacking out and the
line you were just showing one of the
problems when you're on the defending
side is
black has so many different tries and he
can come with the king then go back and
you are always doomed to passive
defense so one of the things that i
would be worried about is i want to keep
the black king out
[Music]
of the the king side or not allow too
many weaknesses
um
f4
uh i'm a little surprised to see that
move what about you danya
yeah it's a little strange but i guess
he
the point is that if duda moves his rook
back to a1 i think
dubob is actually going for for active
defense he wants to play g4 and then g5
check
and and get that rook to the seventh
rank and really lock the king out uh so
this essentially necessitates i i think
that duda should push his own g pawn i
think he should play g6
and build a little bit of a of a pawn
wall uh to discourage duba from pushing
his own pawns and how now king takes g6
this is proposed by the computer
but in general this particular trade
should favor white because now black is
left with a weak pawn on h6
uh and probably duboff should now swing
his rook
behind the pawn and initiate uh the main
defensive setup so we'll see what duda
does here there's a couple of options
yeah well we'll come back here but uh
duda definitely getting a second chance
after the opening lodges looked like a
dead draw he's gonna try his best to to
convert of course the extra pawn into
full point
elsewhere the the bar in the shakhia
game just keeps going up and up and up
and um
i think shakira probably the first
player who will get a win here today we
see prague there on the the bottom
camera things are just not looking good
and maybe we can go back for starters to
shankland against uh magnus carlsen
before we do that and we will do that i
just wanted to point out that this
bishop f5 resource was missed by both
players invited against grendelius
vivid played knight v3 and
niels could have played bishop f5
basically equalizing but such a
difficult move to see cannot blame him
he's gone 96 and he remains in very very
serious trouble but yes let's go go to
the shanghai game
rodney we'll show that moment when we'll
return to vetted against grandelias
and uh missed opportunity for sure
um here we left it off just a few moves
ago
yes so we were examining so magnus did
indeed decide to dial the bishop back
from c3
and then he went rook c7
so he decided on rook c7 rather than b6
i guess he didn't want to weaken the
light squares
and sam
uh pushing that e pawn while he still
has a chance while black has not fully
completed his development so e4 e5
magnus dropping the bishop back and
sam centralizes the knight with knight
t4 so the knight potentially coming out
to f5 and the second idea is to play e6
so for instance black could try to go
bishop c5 here and attack the knight
and white could go
e6 in this position the point is that if
you take the knight you walk into the
devastating e7
and so black is forced to take on e6
and then he's forced to take again
because it's a fork
and this should probably be a draw
opposite colored bishops but
you know black has some pressure on f2
if i were to choose a side i would
probably choose black here
yeah but i like i like the way that sam
han has handled this it felt like maybe
the momentum was shifting ever so
slightly in magnus's favor when he
managed to win back his pawn suddenly
he's got the bishop here life is good
and uh
i think it's very good to see sam take a
very active approach he's going forward
with his pieces
and um
i think he's been playing a very nice
game so far
he definitely has and he knows what to
avoid against magnus like he knows that
he cannot afford to get something like a
slightly worse end game or one of those
positions where magnus has
uh endless grind chances you know
because those positions magnus just eats
people alive
uh and so i think sam realized in this
moment wait a second magnus got two
bishops he's got the uh upon majority on
the queen side i need to get something
done i need to change the course of the
game e4 was an excellent practical
decision by sam and if you're just
looking at the computer evals
uh you don't think much of it because
there's there seems to be several
equivalent moves but i i really like the
way that sam has approached this task
and
uh if he makes a draw then
uh you know part of the reason why i
think will be his uh proactive thinking
in that situation magnus
oh jedubing right there and i think we
could hear it and we could like at least
we could see the words on his his lips
making sure yeah he's not knocking
anything over
and making sure he doesn't press the
clock
right that is of course
a common problem
don't we all want to do that when we
adjust a piece
um but yeah magnus i hear also
i'm very impressed how sam has held his
own on the clock we see that the magnus
is actually the one with slightly lower
time
right now the time isn't a problem yet
but we're only on move 21 so
it could become an issue at some point
oh it absolutely could 36 minutes and
magnus is going to take a while here uh
he knows that bishop he has bishop c5 in
his pocket i can guarantee you that he's
calculated bishop c5 e6 and he is
looking for
a more ambitious option if he doesn't
find it then he's going to go bishop c5
uh and and then we're going to
very likely see that e6 move yeah and
then one of the questions will be can
white withstand uh deal easily with the
pressure on f2 we'll come back and find
out about that maybe we can go back to
vidit against nils and dania you can
show us one more time the incredible
resource that was missed by both players
absolutely and as i open up that game i
will mention that fabian manforest are
the process of repeating the position so
we might see a result there soon we will
keep an eye on that for you and we will
bring that to you if they continue
repeating but back to neil's uh visited
against nils
in this position vivid castles
uh niels indeed went rookie eight and
now the moved ip3
and here neil's missed the incredible
move bishop f5 for just joining us this
resource we had showed earlier
what is the idea well the bishop is
migrating over to this juicy juicy
square on e4
if it's captured then after knight takes
f5 black is simply better because white
loses uh the bishop back and if bishop
takes g7
then black has the inter mezzo bishop e4
attacking the rook the rook has to move
uh and after king takes g7
if anything i would probably already
take black hair because if knight takes
d4 black can start doubling on the e
file and that bishop on e4 is just a
monster but in any case this is
obviously a massive improvement over
what neil's had but instead and trust me
niels
he's hard on himself he is going to be
furious with himself after the game if
he loses for missing bishop 5 he's going
to be furious
and just how bad is the position now
it's defensible it's not it's not losing
by any means
uh and the reason it's not losing is
because after 94 94 rook d4 black can
essentially use the technique of saying
hey take my pawn because that'll reach
an opposite colored bishop position the
move f5 here can be tried uh to create
some counter play on the king's side but
after something like bishop f3
man is black cramped here niels just
might have to hunker down and you know
maybe try to get the bishop to c6 it's
incredibly nasty fiona but
you know given how he defended yesterday
i think he's still got some chances
yeah of course the clock here as well
very likely to play a role at some point
we're only on move 19 and we are getting
closer we're just now in a half away now
from that first time control maybe let's
bring up uh fabiano against jordan
where you see the players
i started repeating
and
so let's just go back couple of moves
well fabi yeah so so after rook dfa we
mentioned that once again there's a
potential repetition bishop g3 it
happened jordan did have the possibility
of going queen e7 here as we discussed
but you can't really blame him for
wanting to play more solidly and being
okay with a repetition
uh against fabio with black and fabby
you know he's now down to 28 minutes
i really don't see a way that white can
play because the e4 is being threatened
and doing something foolish just to say
that you're playing for a win is not
objective and it's not how fabby treats
things uh the only move that i really
saw here was knight g3 but it doesn't
work and there's a beautiful refutation
black can still go before looks like a
blunder that walks right into 1964 but
no look at this queen
that move queen e2 by fabi has caused a
host of problems and here black has the
move rook e7
pinning the knight and after knight d6
rookie two black is just gonna vacuum up
all of these pawns this is terrible for
white i'm
betting a silver dollar that fabby's
going to repeat here and just to be
clear jordan of course he could still
play on himself um he still has the
opportunity to go uh if fabi goes bishop
g3 queen c5 bishop f2
i think he's still in time or is it
already too late no i think that's two
time and and you know i think that
if fabi takes another 15 minutes uh and
then plays bishop g3 and says all right
draw
jordan might very well decide to
continue playing so
that is a consideration fabi must take
into account as well
we see jordan there looking calm and
collected waiting for fabiano
to make his decision
i agree with you i think a repetition
here is likely but fabiano of course he
was looking
for more today but he never really got
much out of out of the opening here
no
he did not and uh
that decision to take on f2 and follow
it up with f6 even with fabi's
innovative
knight f1 idea it just didn't
lead anywhere particularly promising and
if abby's going to be frustrated with
this results i mean he's remains on 50
and he's going to have to make a you
know a serious push in the second half
of the tournament but first of all of
course we will
uh wait to confirm that repetition
actually happens maybe fabi finds some
way to keep playing i i don't see it
though we'll we'll find out let's bring
back the bird's eye view for now
um
so what haven't we updated in a while
um well there's a pango geary but not
much has happened there let's look at
mamidyar's game because a lot has
happened there
and it looks like chakriar is well on
his way
to scoring the point or is he let's see
who the transformation has favored now
what happened here
is that in this position
prague offering the queen trade between
a4
and the engine seemed to think that
after queen d3 queen b5 again offering
the queen trade
the engine seemed to think that chakriar
should have gone for knight f5 that's
not a very human move though
because it allows queen takes d3 knight
takes d3 knight takes e4
the point here is that rook ce1
is winning for white this is crazy
knight takes d2 and now not rook takes
c7 but knight takes c7 fiona this is
wild and the point is that the knight is
threatening to spring back to g6 with
the discovery and if black takes the
rook and white takes the rope then white
takes one knight and then of course
white takes the other knight on obvious
line i don't know how this could have
been missed by chakriar but he decided
and once again we also see the problems
that can happen when the king is still
in the center
yeah i mean all sorts even in the end
game and instead chakriar
uh went for this position he's still
winning i think he should play the move
knight d3 uh centralizing the other
night and maybe pick up the pawn
some chances for programming this is an
incredibly nasty end game chakra has
this massive
uh pawn center that's incredibly mobile
and he's got much better pieces but
prague is incredibly resilient and i'm
sure that he's going to make chakra work
for it also
has now caught up on the clock with both
players being down to around
uh 35 minutes and yeah prague we have
seen him
uh put up some great uh resilience
before he's been mature beyond beyond
his years and let's not write him off
just yet although shahid
of course then has a clear advantage
here
let's go back um should we go back to
magnus and and sam
let's go back to magnus and sam and
let's see if anything has happened there
um
absolutely nothing
he's still thinking and i just by his
pose i think that he is
slowly but surely surely accepting the
inevitability of bishop c5 e6 and the
reason he's disappointed at that is
because he feels like that position is
too simplified to give him serious
winning chances i'm just getting that
sense from the way that he's handling
this he's now down to 28 minutes as well
which you know starts to enter
concerning territory for sure he's gonna
have to make up his mind soon i agree i
think what we're seeing there and we
just saw a frown his frustration
add to um
he's struggling to see how to avoid uh
these simplifications and leading to to
the position with the opposite colored
bishops we'll come back here let's go to
the overview again and see
uh if we had any updates
fabi is okay so jordan has the choice of
repetition here and he's thinking about
it now maybe we should just watch that
game because we might see a result right
about now jordan can repeat it three
times if he wants to and there it is we
have a result and jordan understandably
has decided uh to repeat and opt for a
draw a very very good result
for jordan going into the rest day for
sure uh after only making one draw in
the first uh seven rounds and we see the
players walking away fast after their
game today is not a fun day it is the
pcr test for everyone
before the rest day so that happens
right after the game you're black and
you just drew against fabiano carrana
you get rewarded by a pci test
no better gift indeed another result
we've got two of them now um and not the
ones we thought we would get we thought
that uh dubov and duda would end in a
draw and the other games would keep
going but it turns out that that game
has kept going
and um
these two have ended in dress and look
at anish giri yep those pawns are
starting to move up the board this is
exactly what i was talking about
if i was white here i would start being
seriously seriously
concerned and you know you can lose a
game like this in five more moves if you
let the pawns go any further if the pawn
gets to g4
and then let's say the king gets to g5
once black starts pushing the f1 it
becomes essentially resignable so
esepenko
has to make something happen here and i
don't know what it is i mean he can go
rook d6
but yuri is not going to just repeat
moves here i mean rookie 6 he's probably
going to go rook 3 e6 in order to be
able to meet rook d7 with rook e7
otherwise the rook would just toggle
between d6 and d7 and
a trade is definitely in black's favor
definitely and this might just be losing
for white because
of how bad the night is at stopping the
progress of the pawns especially when
they're supported by the king
uh
not good not good for andre and
the situation keeps deteriorating yeah
and i looking at the camera you got a
feel for him because i think in those
spots it's just it's so hard to keep the
fault out of your mind i had the chance
to just uh go for a draw in the opening
maybe we can very quickly bring put that
position
on the board again in the opening
when andre had a choice sweated to go
for a draw
so yeah here after g4 takes takes queen
takes king h1 knight e5
knight h2 was the move that he did play
but uh if he had captured on e5 that
would have just led to an immediate uh
perpetra
queen h3 queen g3 using the pin
and black has nothing more than to
accept the inevitable i mean admirable
for sure
but a little bit overzealous and anish
has
turned out to be very very well prepared
in this line i feel like in his
preparation he probably
studied a similar type of end game so he
was aware of the ideas he's been playing
quickly he has 50 minutes on the clock
he is in excellent shape here
and
i would say it's about 50 50 between
drawing and winning chances i'm very
concerned for andre daniel we are going
to go on a break very shortly but first
can you maybe recap for us in a couple
of minutes what's going on in the five
remaining games certainly fiona well
starting again on the top left we just
saw magnus playing bishop c5 sam is
gonna play e6 we're gonna have an
opposite-colored bishop situation where
magnus has
a little bit of pressure but that's
probably likely to end in a draw chakra
armamedia with an overwhelming position
uh a technically winning end game
against prague and amazing opening play
but uh prague is going to keep resisting
and he's got some off chances to save
the game uh anish geary we just talked
about that he's got three pawns for the
piece he's got great winning chances and
andre regretting his decision not to
take that early opening draw sergey
koryakin has drawn against report
vidin
is in fantastic shape against niels
after nils missed that amazing
opportunity to go bishop f5 i would say
that vidit's winning chances outweigh
uh niels destroying chances a draw in
fabiano caruana against jordan van
forest and finally dubois with a
shocking blunder in a dead drawn
position he's blundered upon that
endgame should still end in a draw if
he's careful if he can calm himself
uh and and play objectively he should be
able to save the half point but jan
christoph duda will continue torturing
dubov for the near future
so plenty of intrigue here
will shake my medial catch magnus in the
lead can magnus somehow get a win we'll
find out so don't go anywhere we'll see
you in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the longest running tournament series in
online chess is getting a huge update in
2022 titled tuesday is doubling yes
doubling the number of tournaments and
tripling the prize fund with 5 000 in
prizes every tuesday and over 250
thousand dollars annually this change
comes with a big schedule shift as
tournaments move to 8 a.m pacific
11 a.m eastern time 5 p.m cest and 9 30
p.m ist
and 2 p.m pacific time so there will now
be two separate tournaments at 8 a.m
pacific and 2 p.m pacific on tuesday
this new schedule is designed to best
serve the global chess player base and
audience ensuring that all of the best
players in the world of strong
opportunities to compete watch live
coverage every tuesday starting february
1st right here on chess.com this is so
exciting everybody loves title tuesday
and it's great to see it expanding into
two separate events
great news fiona for sure i'm looking
forward to that and myself always a nice
opportunity to try and get some scalps
great news indeed for now let's get back
to round eight here
um we see what do we see let's go back
and start with shankland against carlson
where at the position we talked about
earlier on has appeared on the board
it has it has now it's a reality
and uh the position is greatly
simplified we now have opposite colored
bishops so in the event of a queen trade
uh the position
will really simplify into what is
probably a draw even with rooks on the
board sam first of all has to defend his
bishop there's two ways i see him doing
that the first is to drop the queen back
to e4
okay well that threatens checkmate
magnus will play g6
the second way is to play rook b to d1
involving the rook and also x-raying
black's queen
again the one concern i have here on
sam's behalf is that magnus will somehow
find a way to let's say get his rook to
f7 and get a screen to h4 but it's
definitely not happening immediately if
you go rook f7 in this position you
actually lose white has queen e4 and
watch this
after you play g6 everything's fine
right no it's not bishop is on c5 it's
undefended and that is what we call a
fork
so
rook bd1 works concretely it's the
computer recommendation and if sam
preserves
uh maintains his composure and caution
fiona for the next two three moves this
should be a draw it looks to me like sam
isn't exactly in a state of panic i
think he will
keep his composure i think this is
probably the number one game in this
tournament that he was most
looking forward to he has taken it to
magnus carlsen who is actually the the
player who's low on the clock at this
point
and magnus might just
have to agree to let us peter out here
shortly because
well as you just highlighted he could
end up in some danger if he decides to
overpress here
yeah and the one thing i was trying to
uh
get get uh my head around is
what exactly happens in the event of a
queen trade is it really a draw so i was
contemplating a line such as
uh rook bd1 queen
let's say queen h4 gt let's just say for
the sake of illustration black plays
queen f6 and we have a tree let's let's
say black plays queen f6 immediately uh
is this in fact a dead draw and
the answer i think is yes and the reason
is that white has this very nice
maneuver bishop e2 and then the bishop
comes to f3 and this entirely blocks any
pressure that black might be able to put
down the f file and so if sam is able to
do that uh
it's just symmetrical i mean that
there's
there's no real way to make progress for
either either side here i would take
black but it's it's a draw
yeah and well we'll see if if magnus can
find a way to
either avoid or delay the the trade of
queens for now it is some to move we can
go back again to the the overview we're
expecting a peaceful result here but not
expecting a peaceful result in mahmoud
against pragnanda
no we are not let's check into that game
because
stuff is happening in that
very unpleasant end game
for prague and what has happened here is
that chakra has gone e5 he's put that
knight on f5
and then in this position he threw in
the move rook c1 hitting the knight on
c8
knight b6 and he has decided to take the
bishop but i think what chakri are first
of all the b4 pawn is going to be
hanging
on the next move second of all the dark
squares for black look at those dark
squares d6 f6 this diagonal black could
get checkmated in the center in a matter
of just a couple of moves
and it's a matter of time before chakra
puts a knight on e4 he can get his king
up to f3
i'm just not seeing it happen for prague
no uh
it's also the problem for prague is
there is no active counter play there is
barely any weaknesses that i can see in
the white camp and the pawns are all
solidly defending each other there's no
isolated pawns no double pawns and no
really no holes so i think shakia
he is not gonna let this one uh slip
and from here i don't know do we go to
vidit and grendelius or let's do it
so let's go there
and it's funny that we should have this
pawn structure on the board because
robert and i saw this exact same pawn
structure in a game i can't remember
which one but in one of the early rounds
of the tournament and we thought this
pawn structure doesn't have a name yet
the best the chat came up with was goal
posts
but i think goal posts are pawn
structure that in general you should try
and avoid but here
are things open up opening up in a good
way for nils
goalposts are you supposed to kick a
soccer ball down the e file or something
like that
this is really an interesting approach
by vidit so once this resource was
missed
i was
you know expecting knight takes d4 but
made it playing f5g takes f5 rook hf1
and what i think he's saying is uh mr
grandelius i want to checkmate you
uh because if niels starts grabbing all
of the pawns so vidit probably wants to
take on f6
and he wants to move the bishop away and
go rook g1 now
bishop takes h3 is the fanciest way of
doing that but here's the interesting
thing fiona this looks like it has to be
a checkmate right i mean just look at
this position there's there's got to be
some mate well there isn't a mate uh the
bishop doesn't sound hard to believe
there is nothing here
there is the move rook f3 though
vacating uh the path backward for the
bishop this actually does threaten
checkmate bishop takes d4 will be made
but black can send over the knight
uh and cover the g-file just in time
this leads to
this kind of end game knight g6
and white preserves an initiative here
but black is up a pawn and
the worst will definitely be behind
kneel so and the engine confirms this
black should actually just start
grabbing all the pawns but 20 minutes
remaining much easier said than done for
sure and well before we move on from
here with neil's having some big
decisions as you mentioned very little
time we have a tweet ready i think i
know what it's going to be i saw it on
our last break
anton squared me the genius he's a great
friend of mine go follow him
he's back with his photoshops he used to
be very active and then he got life got
busy um but he is back with
a somewhat dramatic uh photoshop there
dania
that is
wow there's just there's a lot going on
in that photo let me put it that way
and it's funny because i was just
talking to dan a few days ago he told me
why are the lights so dimmed in the
playing hall i need better lighting to
do a new photoshop this is actually part
of a whole thread that has been going
for years so go check him out on twitter
he has some great stuff
out there and i'm glad he got the
lighting he wanted and he's back
producing
those uh funny pictures
we meanwhile are back in the bird's eye
view and um what i see i see andre
sepenko one rook has gotten in but you
were talking about white doesn't want to
trade works shall we go there is anish
just going to
interpose a rook and if so which one
yeah i mean
anish can make a draw if he wants i mean
there's a repetition
on the cards if he so desires and
the way to do that
uh is is to cover with
well i guess you can cover with this
rook
and then after rook d6
rookie six this type of repetition where
the rooks kind of follow each other
right
um you know i know some people think
that unusual automatically go for this
option because it results in a draw but
uh i think he's gonna be more ambitious
than that and i think that black is
really not risking
in either case here and so the way to
avoid that
is
to cover with the e3 rook
then to cover it again and then bring
the other rook up to e7 so essentially
you keep your rooks on e7 and e6 the two
squares from which white can attack a
black pawn
and here essepenko will have to decide
whether he wants to trade a pair of
rocks probably the answer is no he'll
play rook d8 i'm not claiming that this
is an easy win for black but after
something like king g6
the rook can cover a check on g7 and
black can continue trying to make
progress on the king side andre also
with 12 minutes
for seven moves so not ideal but should
be enough i mean
you shouldn't be
he's not a crazy time pressure i would
be shocked that anish goes for a
repetition here i think at the very
least he wants to
to test andre until mu 40 and it feels
like
um unless he starts blundering and his
kingside pawns he shouldn't really be in
any danger so
anish here
um
we see once again i haven't mentioned it
before but the opening a little gamble
with
the indirect draw for paying off i think
and uh well let's see how is uh duboff's
flight going he is also defending a
worse endgame from down
yeah let's see whether he's been able to
stabilize the position
and
i think he has i actually think that
duda might have not chosen the
absolute most testing option
so what happened is that after f4 due to
going a5 daniel going king f3 and here i
think okay so rook a1 and g4
now what is th what is dubop's point the
point is that if white plays or black
plays a4
white's gonna go g5 check and
white's just gonna start harassing black
rook c7
king e8 and at the very least white can
just put the rook on a7 and black is
never going to be able to make progress
that king is never going to escape the
eighth rank so that's one possibility
uh duda can try to prevent that by
playing g6 and opening up a loft square
for his king on g7
but i'm worried that after g5 check
there's just a mass liquidation on the
king side and the more pawns are traded
generally speaking the closer the game
gets to draking g7
let's say hg6 king g6 gh6
and
this should be a drum maybe white can
walk the king up toward down the middle
but
if white just does nothing here fiona i
think that
uh duboff should be able to should be
able to hold this one
yeah and i
like this suggestion i think dubaf will
be looking to to trade
um those pawns so after g4
unexpected g6 he's gone you're not a fan
of g6
no i'm expecting it i think are you
expecting
g6 and and then
some puns to be traded i think duda
himself probably he knows that this um
that this end game is a draw with best
play but of course
he
is trying he has been given a very
unexpected opportunity
in this game
but most likely the income the outcome
will still be peaceful
let's go move on from here
um and we are back in the bird's eye
view
okay so
did we have a repetition in the jesse
panko
anish
hallucinating
um
yeah we have had a one-time no not yet
he's gone
essentially what he has done
is he's gotten the rook from e3 to e6 so
it's sort of a semi-rep it will be a
repetition if he goes rookie seven so
he's deciding right now in real time
whether to make the draw
and i would vote
no i think he's gonna go rook 87 but the
way he's leaning back in his chair
maybe he's thinking you know
there is a little bit of risk of course
associated with white's knight getting
active and black can somehow lose these
pawns although i don't really see that
happening
it's hard to predict but i don't think
he's making a draw here i think he's got
good good winning chances after rookie
seven i would be shocked yeah i agree
with you so
we leave him to think about it he still
has plenty of time
on the clock and maybe we go back to
to sam shankland and magnus carlson
unless things are happening elsewhere
yeah so sam has chosen a very
interesting
approach um
so in this position he went queen h3
defending the bishop and threatening
checkmate this forces h6 but that in
turn weakens the g6 square which sam
tries to exploit with the move queen g3
he is threatening queen g6 that needs to
be prevented
um and he's also aiming at the rook on
c7 which prevents moves like queen f6
i suppose magnus could go queen d6
and i would say that that
is quite likely uh magnus likes these
kinds of moves but this end game is
basically unwinnable and here sam could
expand a little bit on the king side he
could play the typical move h4
the engine gives total equality and i
tend to agree with that i think that
and also sam could try to plant this
bishop on g6 this could get a little
unpleasant for black even if white
anchors the bishop with h5 so
yeah maybe magnus maybe queen d6 isn't
the best after all because the last
thing magnus wants is to start uh
suffering in this position
yeah the other move here is rook d7
dropping you know getting the rook away
from
uh from the queen's gaze and attacking
the bishop
sam can defend that with rook bd1
and then you could go rook d6 and once
again you have to prevent queen g6 so
this
white's got some issues to solve here
again what bothers me is always this
pawn and f2 it's annoying it's annoying
because you can never really move the
rook away from f1
yeah i mean i really liked what you said
earlier about the bishop coming to to f3
i i was completely on board with trying
to close down that f file
but here right now it doesn't seem
to be possible just yet
first magnus will have to to deal with
the threats to his king and but yeah
both sides still seem to have some play
here some threats
do you think we'll see a queen exchange
soon and then some simplifications or do
you think this will
be a time scramble battle
yeah it's hard to say i think because
the position is so wide open uh that
raises the likelihood of a queen trade
i and i really think that magnus is
deciding right now between queen d6 and
rook d7
and if he really is ambitious if he
wants to squeeze the absolute most out
of the position then the move is rook d7
but
i i think both choices would be
understandable here
and we see magnus and deep and fought
23 minutes remain we are on move
2026 and he has as you just said a big
decision on his hands uh one that will
lead
leave a lot more life in the position
than the other so we'll see which one he
chooses
uh for now where would you want to go
next tanya
well um let's try to get
first of all if we go back to a
bird's-eye view for a second just to
point out that dubov
interestingly duda did not push his jeep
on he has allowed
as we have a look here at anish
contemplating
what to do but uh he's allowed g5 check
interestingly jan schistoff has
so maybe that is a better winning chance
that's something we can explore
we'll keep an eye on geary and see
whether he in fact plays for the win or
goes for the draw
um magnus has just gone rook d7 so there
it is
let's have a quick look at vidit's game
because nils did not end up taking that
g4
and he has slipped back into
a very very nasty position
let's go there so
let's rewind a couple of moves and see
how we got here
so f5 gf fabric f1 here niels had this
chance
to take on g4 fearlessly but he ended up
going king f7 allowing vidi to recapture
the pawn
rook g8
rook d2 and oh by the way there was
another tactic here fiona there's a lot
being again
bishop takes up five again
oh my god it's a completely different
reason but this he had to see this king
g6 and maybe he rejected it
because he saw rook f2
king h6 or f6 but guess what after rook
g6 this is uh
this is defensible let's not forget the
black is up upon here
and this is much much closer to a draw
than the text
very sloppy by both players here and my
guess is that vidi might have missed
that as well the point is that white
could have avoided this
uh or at least white could have gotten a
better version of this with the blue
bishop h1
the point is that after bishop f5 rook
out 5 king g6
white has the move bishop f4 in this
position
and
this attacks the knight on c7 and the
reason you can't do that
in the event of rook d2 why can't you go
bishop f4 here
amazingly black has the move 96
and um
there's a couple of differences so with
the bishop on age one
uh what's the actual difference i guess
why i would have had some sort of
something related to the rook g1 check i
don't want to bog down too much into the
details the bottom line is that this was
uh a possibility for black and niels
could have gotten more drawing chances
instead he went 95
uh fiona reclaims the pawn and now he
goes b3 fully limiting the knight on e5
this is now
very very bad for black niels
is kind of out of counter play
but those complications were crazy
on the one hand niels for sure he will
be kicking himself when he turns on the
engine tonight to have missed bishop f5
uh as a counter
blow or like as a resource not just once
but twice
and now 14 minutes on the clock we're
only on move
25 and
the situation is looking dire for nils
once again i wondered can we do
something active uh can i as black maybe
try to to
push those pawns on the queen side and
create some chances
yeah b5 or maybe a5 is definitely a try
though a5 is going to be shut down by a4
niels has gone
rook a to e8
rook a to e8
yeah i mean that's as good a as good a
move as any i think and you know it's
not going to be easy to break down
black's defensive construction right now
everything is protected and yeah you
have this very nicely placed knight on
e5 the issue is just that in the long
run vidit has a bunch of improving moves
he can push the pawn to a4 he can get
his king to b2 this bishop on h6 has
done its job i think it probably belongs
on f4 where it pressures the knight
and just in the long run i'm
you know i feel like white's winning
chances
are are going to grow as he improves his
position can you explain and i think
this is something that isn't clear to me
and i think very often it isn't clear to
the viewers and material is even yes
black's position looks a lot worse but
we see the engine says plus 2.6 which is
a a big advantage so how come it sees
neil's position as so bad
so i think there's two things that play
i mean first of all i would argue as
vidit does indeed play for i would argue
that this is a slight overestimation i
think the proper practical assessment is
something like plus 1.5 maybe plus two
but i would not say that this is totally
winning or anything of that nature
um but i think part of the reason is
that uh
this is a situation where black
literally has no plan you can see that
the one of the computer's
recommendations is just to go bishop c87
and i think those types of situations
are interpreted by computers as being
very very bad because
as white improves his position
inevitably there's going to be a point
where white has some way to cash in and
to convert his advantage so situations
where one side is completely devoid of
counter play uh i think are our scaled
up evaluations evaluation-wise by the
computer
um so that's something to keep into
account like does black have
an active plan here
uh and does white have a way to improve
his position if the answer to the first
question is no and the answer to the
second question is yes and the advantage
is just going to keep growing
yeah and especially so as nielsen's time
takes down he's now
under a minute
per move for the remaining
remaining 15 moves still i will come
back here for now let's bring back the
bird's eye view we see neil's just about
to make a move i think a6 was played
here so we'll come back here uh unless
you want to say something about that we
can move on maybe up now yeah
yeah let's look at tracker i'll just
indicate that anish is still thinking
about
uh which rook to cover with on e7
very interesting and sam is also still
thinking after uh rook d7 so indeed
players going in the tank but mamedyarov
against prague we've had a few moves
there
and
is losing his advantage yeah what's
happening amazing
so
we were looking at this position we
still thought that it's overwhelming
knight b6
knight takes c7 knight takes c7
chakra took on b4 which which is fine
but in this position he made a move that
the engine absolutely hates
um i also thought that bishop d6 was the
most natural anchoring the bishop
and then after kane d7 it's time to get
the knight in via e4
it's possible that chakra was afraid of
knight f5 but it turns out that the
cold-blooded king f2
stops all of the threats if black takes
the pawn on d4 then there's knight c5
check
shooing the king away and now look at
these knights they're aligned white can
pick one of them off with the mover of
d1 but that's not so easy to see when
you look at this nine on a five you get
a little bit scared but you're going to
lose d4 so shocker are deciding to
simplify and giving the bishop away for
that night and following this up
most probably with the move 94.
although he's still thinking huge
decision that bishop was looking so good
uh down the the dark squares also
restricting the black king so do you
think shakia is just uh very confident
that
this is enough i guess he's going to win
the pawn on f3 at some point
i mean he's playing the long game here i
think shocker air first of all is is
really enticed by the possibility of
getting a knight to d6 and he's also not
too concerned about black's blockade on
the d5 square because white does have
the move rook c5 in fact it's a
candidate move in this position
uh but i would imagine that 94 is the
most
flexible and the most appealing move
but uh black can start chipping away at
white's center with the move f6 this is
suggested by the engine
and this works out tactically because
after ef6 knight f6 it might appear that
rook c7 is incredibly strong and here
it's very important to avoid king d8
because of the very elegant rook takes
a7 and you're going to skewer
the king and win the exchange but
black can simply go king e6
well there's a skewer this wins the
knight no it doesn't black has king d5
and the knight on e4 hangs at the end of
the line so
chances chances for prager absolutely
and i think prague has got to to breathe
a sigh of relief when shaq took on e7
because
i think to both of us it felt like he
wasn't gonna survive the onslaught in
the middle game
shark's pieces looked like they were all
over prague's uh
position and now yes he is still worse
but at least he's not going uh to get
blown off the board
yeah i mean they it was overwhelming and
he you know it did really seem like
prague's days were numbered in that
position but uh
absolute credit to him he
i think that idea of training the queens
was very very wise he changed the nature
of the position
and i feel like shaq didn't fully adapt
well to it although let's not overstate
the case i still think that white's
winning chances are
fantastic here and the defensive task in
front of prague is a very intimidating
one indeed so we'll see
for sure let's bring back the bird's eye
view again i'm so curious uh to see what
anish is doing but he's gone
we see that the g-pawn has advanced
further so let's go back there
he has gone after about 15 minutes of
thought and i really think it was never
fully in doubt it's possible he was
really thinking about this position
after rook d8 and deciding what to do
and here comes the pawn
i think for andre i think andre has to
go knight f1
and try to activate this knight asap and
if geary continues to push
then these pawns do have the capacity to
get over extended rook h8
g3
and
there is chaos on the board rook f4
rookie two check king chief one
black could start eating up the
queenside pawns or he could go g2 first
but then after knight h2 white is
hanging by a threat but this h pawn is
limited by the rook and the rook can't
give a check on e1 because then you drop
g2 rook takes p2
there's a rook trade with h7 check
this is given as a
as equality by the computer it's
anything but equal it's chaotic so
that's just one way that the game could
unfold but it does seem like black is
having all the fun here fiona
for sure and uh especially given the the
clock situation although thankfully for
for andre having said that we are
already on move 36 so he's only got four
more moves
to make but regardless are completely
right he's not having
any fun here he needs to figure out how
to best deal with these pawns marching
up
at the board and yeah he's probably
still thinking could have been long gone
by now and the best i can probably get
from this is just a draw anyway
right no it is a very demoralizing and
the same thing happens after you decline
you actually decline a draw offer and
then you end up getting into a bad
position you're kicking yourself
uh you keep rewinding rewinding to that
moment and you can replay it in your
head like man i could have taken the
draw i could have taken the draw it's
like
you know it's like when you uh
when you lose a tooth or when you uh
your tooth falls out and your tongue
kind of goes to that place like
constantly thinking about it it has to
push it out of his mind and i think
knight f1 is actually a crucial move
here without it
uh black's pawns kind of continue to
roll down unabated
yeah so we'll see if andre uh goes for
knight f1 we are back once again in the
the bird's eye view
um
[Music]
maybe we quickly check in with sam and
then we can also update the do buff do
that ending where do you want to start
tanya well i'm actually let's go to do
bob's game because i'm a little bit
surprised by duda's choice but the more
i've been thinking about it the more i
kind of understand
what he's going for
although i think daniel has a forced
draw here
okay so
we stopped last in this position and we
were thinking about g6 but jan should
stop going a4 allowing g5 and rook c7
and getting his king back to e8 he wants
to push the spawn all the way down to a2
so here's the thing let's assume that
white does nothing
the point that duda is making is that if
duval allows this pawn to get to a2 the
king can actually get out of its cage by
walking to b8 remember that the rook can
never leave the a file and so it's going
to have to drop back down allowing the
king passage forward so duboff has a
couple of tempe before that comes that
becomes a reality and he can use those
tempe to play g6 here you know
the point is after fghg
uh a3
now i can play rook a7
after eight two the king does not have
to drop back down black is threatening
work off one check the king can march
forward to e4
and if black starts to push the other
passer
white fearlessly activates the king and
white is in time
to create very powerful counterplay
against black thing in fact this is
already dangerous for black so duda has
to deviate earlier but
not an easy sequence to play this
requires
tremendous amount of calculation and i
think that's what dubob is burning all
of his time
to do this is a very big decision for
why does he take on h6 does he play g6
or does he make some third move
i mean from the line you showed us it
looks like g6 is working but of course
uh daniel i think he's going to invest
most of his
remaining time here we'll move 38 so two
moves from now he will get an extra 50
minutes he has already played recklessly
fast once in this game he got punished
so i don't think he's going to repeat
that mistake he will try and calculate
here
pretty much to the first draw if it is
there but i i think he's done a great
job recovering after losing the pawn
playing some precise moves and i think i
agree with you i think this is headed to
a draw
we have time for one more game before we
go for the last break before the time
control dania which one is it gonna be
um let's
let's update everybody on the shankling
game
let's do it
or the magnus game i guess
should i refer to the game by the
sanctions
oh hashtag or
carl
carl scarlet
that would work doesn't really work
as well
okay so
uh after rook d7 sam
uh deciding to defend the bishop with
the rook rook b3 i guess he didn't want
to move the bishop because
that would have potentially allowed the
rook to infiltrate to the second rank uh
magnus going rook f6 getting his own
rook to the six rank and of course
stopping queen g6 and sam creating some
loft with h3
i think magnus is just going to keep
playing i think he's going to go b6 he's
going to make small improving moves and
at some point sam has to be very careful
about the possibility of rook f7
and uh the pressure on f2 continues to
mount so
magnus has made a move
and it is b6 and it is let me tell you
fiona these positions are exactly
up his alley it's like looks like a draw
but it's a tiny little something he's
got
black is a tiny bit better here without
question
and uh
nobody is as good as him at nursing
these kinds of positions
i think he will also sense the the
momentum now we thought the players were
always very close on the clock but
certainly sam i don't know if it was on
h3 or rook b3 where he spent his time
but suddenly that eight minute deficit
is a huge because we're only on move 28
which means
12 moves still remain to be played and
magnus he knows he is magnus carlsen he
knows he's the world champion he knows
there is a certain magnus effect of
players uh you know being so eager to
get a result some nerves kicking in
maybe more than against
other opponents and he is going to use
that to his advantage and try and put
really maximum pressure here on sam who
i think is going to have to be very
accurate
to get this position
first of all to the first time control
without
losing any ground
yeah and you're on the money he's got 11
and a half minutes for 12 moves
and when you're playing anybody but
magnus that sounds manageable when
you're playing magnus in a slightly
worse position
it doesn't sound particularly manageable
and this is truly amazing sam
seemed to do everything right he really
hasn't made any major mistakes even any
major inaccuracies in this game and yet
it feels like he's slipping slowly but
surely into an unpleasant position let's
see if he can hunker down
and uh neutralize magnus's play before
things get out of hand yeah i'm very
curious we will find out what happens
here after
a
short break and huh
yes the game i guess this is a duboff
who has played g6
okay so we'll come back to this to
magnus and to all the other games that
are still ongoing after a short break
don't go anywhere the time scrambles are
coming up and we'll be right back with
all the action
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round 8 here at the tata
steel chess tournament and you too can
get involved actively over the board
even if it is online two of our three
events are done and dusted but one still
remains it is the bullet uh which always
makes was so much fun that is starting
in just five minutes everyone can join
it is free to play there are prizes for
the top three uh finishers with
some signed chessboards and signed books
by the players here from tata steel so a
lot to play for
if you want to play
you can check out the link at the bottom
right there and if you are watching us
on twitch the link will also be posted
in the chat so um
whatever floats your vote stay with us
there is plenty of action in coming here
or go and play
some bullet come back later either way
dania plenty of fun to look forward to
absolutely i am bullet absolutely that
is my favorite word in the english
language
uh and these tournaments definitely a
great way uh because i can imagine a lot
of people watching kind of get that
hankering you know when you watch
classical chess for a while you want to
play you want to jump into the ring
and you've got the perfect opportunity
to do that as we have a look at our
bird's eye view two games already in the
books both of them
draws caruana bun forest and kuryakyn
report all of the other games still
going and the positions on the board in
those games very combative fiona
anything can happen for sure and then
there is well dude both duda which is
looking uh very familiar because you
might have just shown that exact line
unfold before we went on break
yeah let's uh remind everybody of what
that line is and
what they are playing into so daniel
very i mean the discipline to spend
however long you spend you know 15 20
minutes really hammering it out on not
just tilting his way to a lost end game
but hankering down hunkering down
finding g6 and the point is that after
takes takes a3 now what does white not
want to do do not
under any circumstances take this pawn
because after a2
rook a7 black steps aside with check and
of course the king will be able to stop
the pawn uh from f7 so that's not the
way
uh the point is that you stop the pawn
from behind and then when black plays at
you are just in time to get this king
out of the checking zone of the rook and
the king is threatening to go up to e5
and then take the pawn on e6 and once it
does that not only will white be
threatening mate but white will be
threatening to push the spawn down to f6
uh break through and then create a far
advanced passer of his own
in fact black is probably best advised
in this position to just go rook b1
and give up the pawn and go king e7 and
this is
a draw if white
remains cautious so i can go rook a6
anchor the rook to the e6 pawn and that
way g6 is essentially safe
yeah so a duboff not losing his cool
here it looks like he is now steering uh
the game onto drone territory uh
territory we will have a look um at this
a little bit later on if the players are
still here because this could be
ending in a draw quite soon now uh let's
bring back briefly the bird's eye view
[Music]
and uh we'll see where to next because
there is stuff happening everywhere
everything else
stuff is happening in chagri's game and
it's also happening in essepenko's game
we haven't looked at that one in a
little a little while so let's start
with uh isabenko geary if that's okay
with you let's do it
cool
so the situation i think keeps kind of
deteriorating for white andre did not
end up playing
uh the move knight f1 he instead went
after the h pawn rook h8 rook g8 check
and then rook f8 so he's just trying to
prevent black from pushing any of his
pawns
and it's kind of hard to say
how black should make progress here of
course black would love to play rookie
five and f5 can't do that you're gonna
blunder the f-pawn
uh black can't play h4 because you
blunder the g pawn
maybe king g5 should be considered ng5
does prepare it yeah i think g5 is the
move
because then you prepare h4 and
soon after that you'll be ready to play
g3 they are one move away from the time
control which is a relief for andre who
has three minutes on the clock to make
one more maybe it's short it's gonna
help him a short moment of relief only
because you make move 40 you get your
additional 50 minutes and then you look
at the board and you realize even with
your extra 50 minutes you're still
in
what looks at this point like big
trouble on the board it
i think it's just one of these positions
dania it starts out by just looking
uncomfortable but you feel like it
should be a draw with best play but then
with every move which is the position
gets more and more dire
yeah i mean with every push of the pun
the situation gets worse and worse white
runs out of breathing room on the king
side
uh and andre you know he'll have to find
some way to set up
you know some sort of a of a fortress uh
or create active defense based on
black's king position
uh so
all of that is possible and doable in
certain cases but anish will have so
much time on his like he's got 25
minutes now
uh and that's a perfect amount of time
to have in a position like this he's
going to work through
every single variation here i just don't
really see this happening for andre
and anish well after a slow start
to his tournament yesterday of course he
was helped by the walk
over win against daniel dubos but let's
not forget the day before that
he beat fabiano carrana with the black
pieces so he could just be making it
three in a row here which would leave
him
on five out of eight going into the
second rest day on plus two so
aneesh uh he
is very focused and he is looking for
that uh all-important win with the black
pieces
and he is about to make a move
or is he that is
that kind of hovering sometimes persists
for about five minutes before the move
is actually made nope he is pushing that
king up king g5 there it is
very natural and very strong and andre
he has one more move
before time control and guess what it's
a very important move it's not
easy for white to find a move because if
he goes to f1 now
well then anish is ready to play h4 and
once these fonts hit h4 in g4 man oh man
are things nasty here for white it hurts
me to even look at this position i'm
i think anish is just going to to win
this game and well we'll we'll come back
here for now let's go back to the bird's
eye uh view other things happening i was
reading in the chat here there's been
some big developments in sam shankland
against magnus carlsen and it looks like
sam has done a great job holding his own
yeah
let's have a look it does look like
uh things have completely fizzled out
and neutralized
what has happened
it did seem like after b6 magnus uh is
building up a
a sizable edge but sam playing this very
tricky move bishop e2
magnus quickly responded to the rookie
tune maybe this was an oversight because
sam immediately going rook d3 enforcing
the rook trade
and after the rook trade sam recaptures
with the bishop i feel like with only
one pair of rooks on the board it's
harder to create chances but the engine
was indicating this move queen d5 and it
was still giving a pretty sizable
advantage for black the point is that
you attack the pawn on a2 and if the
bishop drops back and defends it all of
a sudden there's this tactic rook takes
f2
rook takes f2 queen d1 checking at you
and now simply queen takes b1 the point
is that the rook can't move because you
get checkmated on g1 if you give a check
on b8 the king escapes and escapes to
age seven whatever it was magnus almost
played that move but no he went for a
queen trade but then he did a castle's
favorite tactic which he's been telling
me every day about he's
stopped one short one square short right
he stopped one square short and now sam
has gotten his king out no this is a
draw i don't think magnus has any
realistic winning chances anymore
one defensive approach for samus to play
f3 and create an anchor point for his
bishop i think magnus is going to try
but
sam should draw this 100 times out of
100. i agree with you i think this one
we can leave
for now uh i think some he has had some
much more serious questions to answer in
this game than this end game uh where
the opposite colored bishop should make
his task quite easy we also see magnus
there who seems to be already resigning
himself to only getting a draw here of
course he always wants the full point
but today it probably won't happen but
le that leaves the door open for one man
to potentially catch him in the lead and
that is shakira mom and daraf
it is and
we will take a look at his game and it
does seem
unfortunately for prague that things
have once again taken a turn for the
worse
for black how has that happened and why
is that the case yes i think prague is
just losing here
so
yeah this is the key moment we were
discussing this move f6 prag playing g5
so he's trying to go g4 my medaroff
stops him and now prague did go f6 but
after rook c5
there is a very important distinction
between the pawn remaining on g7 we're
sorry the pawn remaining on g6 what is
that distinction so after f65 let's
figure it out
here
oh
i see it
here after rook d8 he takes f6 knight
takes f6 rookie five trick you go king
f7 everything's fine right
now let's compare this to the same exact
position with the inclusion of g5
imagine if the pawn is on g5 here do you
see a difference
well there's rook f5 and that one's at
night
and i'm pretty sure that that is the
reason that maybe something uh prague
overlooked
rook d8 you have six knight f6 let's
check
yeah that's that's the subtlety the
presence of the square is what disallows
black from
the knight because of course the the
night the white knight is covering d6 so
wow sometimes dany it's incredible these
pond pushes you just push them one or
two squares and it makes such a huge uh
difference huge
pawns are the soul of chess and you see
why i mean these square square control
is so important prague was forced to uh
double clutch it with f5 but now
chakra just comes around he takes the
pawn
the situation stabilizes he's got
connected passers and see the knight on
d5 is just not stable there's no pawn
that anchors the knight but it's really
only a matter of time before white
dislodges it it might take
chakra a good amount of time
uh but he brings his king up he goes
rook c6
and now prague's position starts to
collapse he's gone rook c8 i actually
think either rook takes h6 but probably
even better is to take on c8
and now
you probably don't want to go
d5 due to knight b6 and white's
overextended
but the engine was suggesting a really
strong move h4
the point is that after g4 you redirect
your knight either to f4 to e3 you get
control over the d5 square and
essentially you
essentially and eventually
you're going to play d5 and once you do
the game is over so chakra is on the
doorstep here
yeah he is going to take some time still
has 13 minutes on the clock to the side
does he want to trade rooks here and
other moves might also be appealing but
i think he will go for the work trade
yeah i mean the the alternative is rook
takes h6
and this is quite a bit more messy after
rook c2 i think shocker is calculating
this
but uh
these positions these positions can get
a little bit hairy i mean black
wants to take on a2
and then black will have his own for our
advanced passer i i think chakra is is
trading
yeah i think this is not something you
want to allow even if
even if you knew that objectively it is
still winning um i think yeah the rook
trade is what's gonna happen here prague
also has close to no time at all on the
clock still six moves to make but i
don't think it matters here um
i think shaq is headed for victory and
let's go back to maybe to visit and
niels we haven't been there in a while
for sure let's see how a bit it is going
about process of improving his position
is he making progress
it appears that he is making some
progress
by the way look at the clock situation
here and we still have 10 moves to make
10 moves yeah this is basically a blitz
game in the next 10 moves
um viditz
okay so he won b3 he expanded on the
queen side he decided to get oh yeah he
did get the bishop back to f4
rook f2 reinforcing the bishop once
again and then he got his king to a3
and this is the position on the board
now
white could continue the process of
bringing the king up
nils i think is trying to get his knight
around to e4 so he is doing his absolute
best to create active counterplay and
that is what you have to do particularly
given that it is quite low on time white
does have the very interesting move
bishop f3 here
with the idea of meeting knight d6 with
a
check on h5
forcing the king onto an undesirable
square either there's going to be 96
check
or if king e7 white's going to take and
then shove that pawn down with f6 knight
e6 and f7 is coming up and of king f8
you get mated
that's a very cute check mate
wow yeah so that f pawn suddenly
dangerously close bishop f3 definitely
one option for vedic can he also
continue the king is king before an
option
it definitely is and knight d6 has to be
evaluated and calculated
if you keep pushing with king c5 man i'd
be scared i'd be scared of this
i'd be scared of something like this
and white could definitely get mated
here i mean the engine is giving a
pretty unclear assessment after bishop
ah so in time pressure i don't think vin
is going to go for it
but bishop f3 is not an easy move to
spot that's kind of
a weird maneuver and
you have to realize that knight takes f3
of course is in white's favor because
that would involve giving away black's
only good piece
yeah and also i mean we talked about
this the last time we
we were here i asked you why is the
engine giving such a big advantage now
it's giving an even bigger advantage
close to plus four and well i'll ask you
later because with it has just made a
move and it's cf and magnus is drawn by
the way officially sorry to interrupt
you fiona no not at all let's see if we
can still catch the players at the board
no they were made a fast exit but a
great result uh for
sam and these two sam also will be
rewarded for his efforts with the pcr
test but uh on in all seriousness a
great effort uh by by sam
indeed and sorry to interrupt you there
just wanted to
clarify that game is also a draw we've
got three draws so far uh now we can go
back to the video game because we have
an explosion on the board vidit has gone
c4 and he has decided to strike
precisely at this moment because the
rook on g8 can no longer join the center
uh the knights on e8 and the knight
cannot come to d6 because you're gonna
get your bishop trapped after c takes d5
three minutes on the board on the clock
for
niels this is
so hard to defend man
so what are your options now after c4 i
guess we can't really capture the pawn
or can we you probably i mean you can
try
i'm worried though that after knight
takes c6 there's going to be this
oh no white wins we're okay a knight
takes e5 check
rook takes d2 and then bishop d5 wins
the rook i mean these tactics they're
just everywhere there's no escape in
there especially in a position like this
with pieces all over the world by the
way we are only on move
30 c4 was moved 31 so nils has 10 moves
to make
yeah that's going to be rough he's
probably has to play knight c7 and
support the the d5 pawn with everything
that he's got of course that's not what
he wanted he wanted that knight to get
active but
vidit just immediately striking cutting
nipping the counter play in the bud
and after knight c7 bidded is going to
have to find a way to keep improving
so let's have a look at that knight c7
and how do we increase the pressure here
for white
well the first question is do we do does
vidiq want to go c5 and then
does he want to aim for b4 b5 well niels
will definitely go a5 in this case to
stop before
okay that's one option
another option is just to make some sort
of a neutral move you can still play
bishop f3
but but let's see what niels does i mean
if he plays knight c7
then
we'll discuss the possibilities provided
he's still thinking he's now down to two
minutes
yeah
looking
dire knight c7 is there another way
knight 67 is the only way to defend upon
right
i think it is yeah i just don't see
another way to reinforce the pawn and
but it is threatening just to take the
bishop and then to take on d5
what could niels be contemplating
yeah rook takes g2 is out of the
question because the knight is always
capable of taking the bishop at the
right moment
i think he's going to go knight c7 it's
just the time situation is
so concerning here in such a difficult
position
surely he must be considering some
alternatives because otherwise it
doesn't make any sense not to play
knight c7
immediately i'm confused needs down to a
minute and a half
he is he's freezing and
well d takes c4s
i mean i that's not the easiest line to
calculate just because of how much is
going on there yeah
i completely agree with you there must
be some
option that's catching his eye
and now he's down to a minute
and it's so problem one of the problems
for nils is we saw that white's pieces
can create
a lot of threads there are a lot of
tactics in the air
but look at the white king on a3 that is
so safe there so unfortunately for nils
there are just no tactical uh
opportunities for him and tonight jumped
in the other direction knight g7
7
wait a minute
knight takes c6 and c takes d5
and vidid is as confused as i am
takes takes and is the game just i think
the game's just over that's it
no this is this is just collapsed
because if c5 you just go d6 and bishop
d5 check kind of like van forest be
admitted yesterday no this is uh
i think niels is just going to resign
after knight takes c6 and ncd
yeah and as you said i mean looking
confused as well if we put this on the
board one more time after night takes
takes i guess there is not any time and
fidet is reaching out i think he's going
to take on c6 no it's over there is no
way to take on f5
and and here yeah bishop
either bishop takes e5 or even just dc
is also winning and and there he goes we
zoomed in just in time to see knight
takes c6 appear on the board
no i i'm not sure what it is nils
halluci and maybe we'll find out what he
wanted to do after cd
but
maybe it was just panic he just didn't
didn't spot knight c7 and yeah after
knight c7
black black was surviving the game
wasn't totally over that's the problem
though with getting yourself into this
kind of time pressure in a bad position
it's a double whammy and look at meals
like
i mean it really looks like what you're
saying he must have missed something
easy because he's now shaking his head
and in this belief
yeah he's got the the what was i
thinking head shake
what
total hallucination here and then it is
going to win another bounce back we've
had a lot of people with a scoring
bounce back wins bitted after that very
painful loss yesterday against van
forest
big big win
today and very convincing game straight
out of the opening for against nils
for sure and vivid and anish giri if
anish can win his game the two friends
advance learning hand in hand both of
them looking to get to five out of eight
but at the top uh well magnus he's on
five and half at the moment but shakia
he is closing in uh i think we'll stay
here for now because we might just see a
resignation nils is not even looking
anymore so much at the board but i think
he was looking at the scoresheet which
we see happen so often
and this look of where did this go wrong
yeah he's been really struggling to find
his footing in the tournament he's had
problems in the opening he's a very
creative repertoire a lot of ideas but
they haven't been working this
tournament
and uh
you know the kind of opposition that he
faces is absolutely brutal in that
regard and now i think just d takes e6
no but this is this is totally
resignable takes and
you can take with the rook
or take with the bishop actually it
really doesn't even matter
so yeah
is a little bit too far advanced there
will be no stopping that uh so
i think
i don't know if we should stay here i
don't think this is going to reach the
first uh time control because we're only
on move 33 so still seven moves to go
um maybe we can
very quickly bring up the bird's eye
view and see what else is happening
elsewhere as we're inching closer and
closer to the first time control
shakia has indeed decided to trade work
for it
sorry
no go ahead
i just i didn't hear you but yeah
he is looking like he is going to win
his game same for v that where we just
came from uh
dupoff well we can go there later
because i think they are past move 40
and let's quickly go back well i guess i
say panko is also on move 40 so shall we
stick with with it for now or where
should we go let's let's stick with the
minute let's take because we're going to
see a lot of moves there pretty fast i
think i think we're going to see a
result
i think so too d take c6 is on the board
and after the rook trade i think as you
were just saying dania
vidit can recapture whichever way he
wants the problem is just uh well white
has two extra points for starters and
one of them is on on c6
and by the way we're probably going to
see a result in the chakra game very
shortly as well but and there is the
resignation
uh by neil so another tough game for him
it really hasn't been his tournament but
forbid it a huge bounce back victory
indeed it is and a very convincing game
particularly in the opening when he
played that early e5
this will be a very interesting opening
to explore i'm wondering who was in
preparation and when both players exited
their preparation but that early knight
f5 sacrifice very inventive sharp
energetic play by the indian grand
master sure well deserved victory indeed
indeed and let's go to shakira
mamedyarov maybe which you were saying
looks like it's going to end very soon
as well
it it it does and
uh the point here is that um
okay so knight takes b2
now chakriar is i think going to just
collect
all of the pawns i think he's going to
play knight takes f5
king e6 knight takes h6 now prague is
going to go after the a-pawn so
it looks like black has counter play but
that's an illusion because why can go h5
after knight takes a2 knight takes g4 b3
it's literally just one threat as soon
as it stopped black and resigned because
now these pawns are completely
unstoppable i think shakur has
calculated that he's got plenty of time
and this is the pathway i think the game
is going to go down yeah and well
actually knight takes b2 is move
39 so only one more move to make for
shakia and there he goes he has just
captured the pawn on f5 and he is going
to get an extra 50 minutes here which is
plenty more than needed
yeah he won't need them he's going to
take on i mean he's already calculated
the line until the end
and i despite the
the time uh the added time i think the
players will continue to execute their
moves pretty rapidly
and that leaves us with only well let's
go back then to yasipanko and aneesh or
do you want to start with the rook
ending first
um
no let's look at let's look at the the
irish game
so aneesh
we haven't missed too much except for
the the black pawns they're really
getting closer
and closer
um
a4 is a move dania i'm a little bit
surprised to see it on the board because
if i were white i would feel like i have
to do something to actively stop the
black pawns but maybe there is just no
such move in this position
yeah and and i guess what andre is
saying is that well
at the moment he is more or less
stopping the pawns from progressing
further giri could play h3 but that
could end up being in fact that is
counterproductive it gives the knight
this huge square entry three and now
white is the one who's playing for a win
and if you play g3
then the rook
well actually it might be the case that
andre wants to
sacrifice on g3 this might be the end
game that andre is going for the lesser
evil and yes black is up a pawn but
winning this is going to be very
difficult white's rooks are active and
so geary might end up delaying g3
and instead sort of playing that cat and
mouse game on the on the queenside maybe
throwing in p65 just making some
improvements
uh and and milking esopenko's clock
yeah it's very interesting uh well yes
panko he has just gotten in his extra 50
minutes so plenty of time now but it can
go down fast and well let's check in
with the last game uh that is uh duboff
against duda
and it looks like indeed daniel has
found
his way
to a draw here
it it does look like that it does look
that way indeed and he actually decided
to go back to f2
rather than forward to e4 but it's
similar set of ideas now
here's the thing
what approaches does black have black
has two plans he can try to get this
king to b8
or he can try to push the h pawn and
neither of them produce the desired
effect so after h5 the king will come to
g2
if you play h4 y can push e4
and then if you play h3 check this is
the crucial part white cannot take on h3
of course uh because of rook h1 but
white just hides behind the pawn this is
a famous idea
and
you're inevitably going to get
liquidation you're going to get a
position like this and then this pawn on
g6 is a big big strength because white's
always going to be able to win g7 at his
convenience
uh so that's one option and if sorry if
just in this line if
the moment that white hides on h2 in
this line that we were just looking at
what if black in this moment tries to
bring the king
yeah so so it's going to be the same
idea well it's going to go f5
and black needs to be careful in fact at
this point mike has to liquidate because
if you go to c8 after f6 white's already
winning white breaks through
so uh yeah very interesting to see that
even black here cannot take all the
liberties and let's look at the other
possibility that black has which is to
bring the king
so again you don't want to go e4 because
of rook h1 and then the skewer so you
want to start with king g2 and if king
c8 here come the pawns e4 can be eight
yeah the rook has to move away but if
the king starts moving up toward the
rook white already plays f5 and again
white's already better so this threat of
pushing the pawn to f6 essentially
forces black's king to remain in the
center and on the king side
that means that black's
play essentially evaporates judah is
coming to that realization right now and
really yeah kudos to duba for
incredible defense you really just gave
him no chances and uh big has prepared a
little quiz for us
and the quiz is called guess the legs
oh man
okay
[Music]
let me think about that
is that
could that be prague it's hard to really
hard to say what do you think i think
that's i was thinking yes it panko maybe
but the panko yeah they're tall prague
is i don't know how tall prague is maybe
prague yeah maybe you're right
it could be geary i'm gonna go with
prague though let's see
i think you're right danya and shaq is
making the suspense untenable
get out of there yes
[Laughter]
yeah this is how i know i've earned my
rightful place as a commentator
wow yeah prague i mean we're just having
a bit of
fun here but of course
he is in a some
uh a in a dire situation
uh with a position that is just lost and
this one here duboff as you've just
shown us he's done a great job
of not losing his cool after
the fast draw that we were expecting
slipped into a position upon down
um but
now yeah as you said dude is coming to
the realization that he is running out
of tries here
yeah and it's totally understandable
that he's taking as long as he is uh
these types of positions
you know they're very sharp they're
possible to calculate because the number
of options for both sides is quite
limited but dubai putting faith in his
own calculation and rightfully so
for sure let's go back uh quickly
to my media of maybe we update that one
last time and
maybe we'll take
a quick break after that so let's go
back here nothing much has happened we
saw as you called shakia just taking all
those king side pawns and
if
black goes after a2 as you are
highlighting
and tries to use his own b pawn white is
just going to bring the the king
to help stop the b pawn yeah this is a
very easy line to calculate b3 king b2
and then if white black pushes yeah h6
a4 h7 and black is not in time flag
tries to stop
the pawn with his own king of course
white's got way too many pass fonts e6
check
is simply overwhelming and dania very
shortly we're going to be hearing from
vidit uh and let's go there immediately
fit it you just beat nilsgrandelias um
it was a very eventful game um like in
the opening it seemed like a very crazy
game as well
yeah it was very pretty to play this g4
i think
this is the second game in the
tournament where g4 has been kind of a
surprise
um and it was very nice knight g3 knight
f5 he has to be accurate to you know get
a good game
which he did not play i think
the best moves and i got a good
advantage after that so it was all
preparation
uh until some point i mean i don't think
you can just play g4 over the board
um
and after that like what were the key
moments of the game
yeah um after that
i'm i for sure knew i was better but the
problem was i had so many choices and it
was not easy to pick the best move
because i don't know which is the best
first of all and everything looks
approximately similar
but i did allow him some defensive
chances in time pressure um for example
he could sacrifice bishop f5 and then my
rook is trapped on f5 something like
this of course white is off better but
yeah it would have been much easier for
him once he allowed me this bind with
pawn on f5 and my knight on d4 then it's
just positionally very very good for me
um
yesterday you lost your game right so
like was it hard to bounce back
it was very
hard yesterday because um jordan had
played a new idea um
and i reacted well i found all the best
moves until certain point
and then okay i misplayed he misplayed
something like this but at some point i
was just better in
fact and the problem was very very low
on time and
because of that i made some moves which
are not uh let's say 2700 level
and that allowed him chances it was very
painful for me to
have that loss yesterday especially
because i think i played good until a
certain point and i felt like
i should have at least drawn the game
um you're here with your coach uh alan
greenfield how is um how's your
collaboration
uh he's uh wonderful like i know him
since
i think 2004 or 2005.
he had come to my place in nasik and he
trained me when i was i think 2100 or
2200 something like this so we have a
very
uh long relationship um and it's great
to have him uh here right he just gives
me a lot of positive energy and strength
um
a couple of weeks ago um you tweeted
something about world chess and like the
sponsor logos um has this issue been
been resolved
i think
some talks have been going on
i don't have the complete information so
i don't
think it's best for me to comment on it
without knowing what's the status going
on my team is handling it actually and
while looking at your shirt is there
still some space left for new sponsors
always please write to me
okay well good luck and enjoy your essay
thank you
you heard it here first if you are a big
company looking to sponsor with it get
in touch with him i thought it was
really amazing what he said he's been
working with alan greenfeld since he was
20 rated 2100. that is a long-standing
history
that it really is an incredibly long
collaboration always heartwarming when
you have that kind of a relationship and
it really shows that it's it's not about
necessarily the rating of the coach it's
more about the quality of the
relationship it's about the level of
trust that you have and the level of
experience that uh your coach has so
great stuff from vivid and of course a
phenomenal win against niels rendelius
absolutely bouncing back straight away
uh dania we're gonna go uh on a quick
break we still have three games going
here in round eight so don't go anywhere
and we will back
soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bobby
yeah robert
can you read devretsky's end game manual
to us one more time yeah now we got to
get
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it
[Laughter]
um
you
ready that away
that's what i said
i told you
let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
stays in salt lake
exactly
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert can you read devoretsky's
endgame manual to us one more time yeah
you guys have to
[Laughter]
go okay okay okay
i just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time but you made it funnier
like i thought you was a one-time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next year
just so i'm mentally prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
i want an omelet with brie just [ __ ]
eat it
you eat it
[Laughter]
i wasn't expecting that that wasn't
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess sounds like
a great future credit card faster card
yeah wasn't it fast or hard
[Laughter]
no no it's that card
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or hard bobby oh boy i i can't
be with you two anymore
okay
i mean i think it's it's hilarious don't
you think people would would buy this
i don't think anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
keep it rolling okay
same thing
yeah and we are danny
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're going to be right back
bobby
yes robert
can you read deboratsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
i'm sorry i just can't
[Music]
it's so funny
isn't it cool when i predict the moves
you're going to say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so if one can give us her
thoughts on the uh
on the pet shop go ahead ephon
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
fubbie
yeah danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to say that you're
not supposed to say this if you start
the bet if black's a6 pawn was
transported let's say
good night guys
good night dad i've been fabi
[Laughter]
should i not set it
i think it's funny people say good night
dad i mean bobby but we need to be
instinct
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round eight
here at the tata steel chess tournament
and danya we still have
three games remaining although the first
one that we expect to be over
maybe it's a close toss-up between
memorial and prague and dubois and duda
but they will end in two very different
ways
indeed they will looking over at the top
left we have mom and drag and
that game is going to end any second
let's start with that one let's go in
sort of
chronological order
oops and uh let me pull that up for you
here it is
okay so it is a case of too many past
pawns we've all been there but prague
actually doing as good of as good of a
job as he can
uh sending his knife back to try to stop
the h-bomb that's the point he really
has to stop now here's the point fiona
h6
would be a terrible blunder because of
b3 and it turns out that white's king
can no longer stop the passer well
because it's going to promote because
the knight defends the promotion square
so chakriar has to remain very cautious
and he has to play king d2
prague is going to give a check
and then swing the knight back to g5 the
reason this is completely winning for
white is because shakur is going to go
h6 and then knight f6 and he's just
going to push all of these pawns off the
board and they're completely
overwhelming i have a question could i
not have gone instead of going to c2
could i have gone to d3 instead with the
idea of maybe bringing the king to c4
and then just try and push the d pawn
immediately
excellent point i think this is even
more accurate because now you just stop
you also just stop both puns
uh at the same time this is even more
efficient i completely agree yeah this
is this is even better and chakra has
indeed got king d2 yeah indeed and well
this game i think will be over um very
shortly as you said just too many uh
pawns to deal with and prague
he knows it uh so we'll come back here
but for now let's quickly go to the the
rook ending between duda and
dubois and see is
making any tries here
judah has been taking
very long amounts of time really trying
to figure something out and to no avail
he's just played h5
going down the first path that we had
described uh daniel can simply go king
g2
and the moment that duda gets his pawn
to h4
white can send the e pawn down the board
and
ultimately black can transform this into
a position where he's up a pawn but the
issue is just that it's the wrong pawn
and even after something like rook a7
and rook takes g7
not look f7 rook takes g7 white's pawn
is active enough to guarantee an easy
draw this game will also end very very
short
shortly
here comes king g2h4 and i am fully
expecting daniel to go e4 in this
position preparing f5
so those two games we expect to end
quite soon and that leaves us with uh
andrey sepanko against anishgiri and i
heard during the break that apparently
magnus mentioned
off the record so it wasn't during the
interview but that he was quite uh
impressed here actually with anisha's
idea in the opening
yeah this night i mean this is cool uh
bishop sacrifice in 95 and uh
obviously at a super grandmaster level
uh you're almost always fine with the
draw with the black pieces so
uh you have the freedom to play these
kinds of ideas that contain within them
the possibility of a four straw
but look at this dania after a4 anish
has really gone into the tank here
for
probably well over half an hour at this
point
incredible
and he's definitely thinking about
whether to go g3 i mean that's that's
the key decision just go g3 does he try
to improve
[Music]
[Music]
draw in this endgame than a black
victory
uh but it's it's a very hard position to
evaluate and gary not showing any signs
that he's ready to make a move just yet
yeah so uh anish still contemplating
i think really what he's thinking about
most likely is just this endgame here
what are his uh winning his winning
chances uh here
and
if we
i think we should we'll just keep
jumping around
waiting for one of the other two games
to finish i guess the first one that
we'll finish is mamedyarov against
uh prague
uh as prague has just given the check on
e4 so we can go there and check he's
going your way king
yeah i know i i definitely king d3 was
more precise uh but
this should be plenty good enough as
well
yeah i mean prague could probably start
with a5 here
h6 knight g5
knight f6
no it's over well a4 h7 knight f7 and
the knight temporarily stops the pawns
but now white's knight can circle back
to f4 in order to dislodge the kinks
that white goes e6 and
it's only a matter of time before white
spawns promote
you know white pushes
any of the pawns actually g4 was also
good there
yeah and this one will end
quite
quite shortly and really there isn't
much to say about uh this position which
one would you like to focus on which
will we focus more on anish and shall we
see on the bird's eye view duboff maybe
that's actually the first one to finish
because duboff has
gone yeah a lot of moves are being
played here
and i actually think that uh jan is
going to go rookie one in this position
uh let's switch over to that game so
rookie one in this position i think he's
going to play
or rook f1 i mean rook f1 is the other
way that he can win upon temporarily
takes
takes but here actually white has a very
nice idea rookie 8 check king e7 and
rook a7 check and this draws on the spot
because king f6 runs into rook f7 check
so probably a better try is to go to e1
yes
definitely and then we're expecting and
there comes the rook i think he's gonna
e1
indeed yeah
he's gone rookie one rook takes a two is
about to happen oh and address has been
offered and agreed
and another and mommy jared also won
simultaneously we had some results at
the same time
we had to draw in this game and chakra
are winning at the same time
is so two results we see those two
players daniel he made life difficult
for himself and prague they didn't waste
any time jesus
we come back and they're both gone
already
and yeah dupe off uh one more time we
thought this one was gonna be over hours
ago then one reckless moment uh by duval
overseeing dude that's possibility to go
a b5 and he had to suffer for a lot
longer than planned but in the end
holding on to the draw
yeah good stuff from dubai very
professional attitude not losing his
mind you know when he blundered that
pawn
and just proving the dictum that all
rook end games are drawn to begin with
so
a a a relief for sure a relief for
daniel dubov
and for do a solid result going into the
rest day of draw so we've got two
decisive games so far mamedyarov beating
prague and vidic beating grendelius
neither result particularly surprising
but for mamidyarov a great game it was a
little bit topsy-turvy he gave products
some chances in the end game but it was
never really in doubt
yeah and uh well with his victory
shakira mahmedirov he is now has joined
a certain wranglers carlson in the lead
uh he will be making the most of that
rest say i'm just trying to think have
the two
played yet i think not but my no i don't
think so
and that's always a very interesting
matchup
for sure i think magnus used to and
actually dania is just having a quick
look they will be playing two days from
now after the rest day with carl carson
with the white pieces so that would be a
huge huge game coming up
yeah magnus will definitely try to make
the most out of that game and for prague
it's been a very difficult experi
experience at tata steel so far
but once again we have to keep
reiterating how young he is
and how nowadays very often the
expectations are
are just not very realistic you know and
i think people forget that experience is
still incredibly important even though
uh grandmasters are getting younger and
younger
it's one thing to have a certain rating
it's another thing to have
a wealth of experience playing these
types of tournaments
absolutely for sure no matter what
happens here in the remaining
few rounds prague is going to walk away
with so much more experience and not
just that but also the fact that he will
have faced magnus over the world in a
classical game uh i think he said it was
also his first game against a couple of
other players maybe fabiano or some
others that is going to help him so much
in his uh future
development and um at least he has that
one win against nils nobody is going to
take that away from him because
sometimes this is an event oh and we
will be hearing from shakir
shortly so we're getting ready to jump
there and after we come back from the
interview i'd be curious to if we see if
we can try and zoom in on anish's clock
and find out just how much time has he
spent here
and let's go to shahia now
you just built
you just beat pragananda in uh
quite a crazy game like what happened in
the opening
okay
i played very interesting move in queen
a4
is normally is queen never go early i
mean
queen info but okay i played good move
interesting of course it's not very good
move
it's just interesting move to play for
win
uh and i think after move 10 11
it's absolutely winning position for
wyatt because this
is black kings it was very bad but
we played i think more 40 moves because
i missed something i don't know maybe i
don't miss but i just want to play
accurately because maybe some
maybe
i have
i don't know maybe i choose not very
good lines i mean
it was looks
very bad for black but we go end game in
game it was very bad for black and we
play i play just accurately and i will
prakananda is so young and you're you're
quite a veteran of of the fields
do you change your strategies to play
against younger players compared to
other players
no case form is not easy to change my
style
my styles every time to play interesting
chess and fighting chess it's not easy
to change style when you play young or
older all this player but
i just love to play chess for
fighting chess and very interesting
chess for this reason it was not
important he's young or not young i just
play normal chess
in the next round you will face the
co-leader magnus carlsen
how do you look forward to that game
okay i play
against world number one of course is
world champion he's very strong he's of
course your
very strong chess player of course
we will play
just chess
it will be not easy because also black i
will play with black
but
we will try we will play good chess i
will try to show my best
we will see i mean
i am ready for
to play good chess and to try to play
uh
i mean i don't know it's not easy to say
something before the game but
i will try to show my best what is your
uh overall result against magnus i i
remember of course that
game you played in bill which was like
the start i mean the the first game
before his long winnings or not losing
streak
okay
not very good results i think i won
just two times
in my chess career against him but it
was
six games maybe minus four minus five or
more i don't know but more than 10 draws
okay i think everyone have minus against
magnus because he's worth number one
uh but this is only one game it's
different tournaments and
okay i mean
i don't want to think about negatives
and
i will try to play good chess okay i
wish you all the best thank you very
much thanks
i always love hearing from uh shakhia
such a great guy such a fantastic jazz
player and danya he's not too stressed
it seems about his upcoming game against
magnus carlsen
he is so nice and the reason i know him
very well is because uh back when i was
living in california
uh he would come for several summers in
a row to the bay area uh to teach at uh
a camp that i also taught at so we met
we had a lot of fun conversations he
never let me pay for him
to pay for his lunch he is just uh so
much fun great company and obviously an
absolute genius chess player and a great
blitz player of course as well
um i had a lot of fun getting crushed by
him in blitz
for sure i also thought it was really
interesting what he said about today's
game
against prague you know did he do
anything different because his opponent
is so young
and he said no young old doesn't really
matter i just play my chess and i said
it's difficult to change his his
fighting style and it is what we love to
see and he is in the joint lead
um meanwhile anish giri after a long
long long thing he has played the move
a5
he has and he has went for option two
option one being the immediate g3 and
i'm to say a word
that i think most people are not going
to associate with this position but
allow me to explain the word is
what are you what are you saying white's
got 800 pieces left on the board well
here's the thing
let's take every one of white's pieces
consider its role and see how moving it
away from its post changes the position
of black's favor the king
the king obviously holds back the pawns
if you move the king back to g1
then the move g3 becomes a lot stronger
g3 followed by king g4 is extremely
scary
and white doesn't have the possibility
of sacking back on g3
okay the rook on f8 the rokan f8 holds
down the f-bomb if you move it away from
f8
black is going to play either g3 or at
some point the move f5 and if you go
rook f8 black advances one file upward
which is obviously undesirable okay what
about the other rook well if the other
rook moves it's the same exact problem
the move f5 becomes a very serious issue
so that essentially leaves white only
with his queen side pawns and if he goes
before black can just reinforce the
problem with the move b6 and
i believe that white is actually a in
zuson here even if white goes after the
b-pawn black doesn't care f5 and if rook
takes b6 i was calculating this during
the interview i think after f4 black's
pawns are completely overwhelming this
has been a fantastic decision by geary
and his time was not spent in vain
wow i mean i did not uh when you said
let me tell you one word i thought it
might be
and like i'm sure many other viewers i
thought how how is that possible but
yeah andreas penguin are now finding
himself in a very
uncomfortable position and some
concessions
will have to be
will have to be made here
which of the moves you looked at do you
think is the the lesser evil
i think you should definitely start with
b4 and for the record i'm positive that
with top computer play this should be a
draw it's just like i just have the
sense that if white plays with mega
accuracy
these positions usually can be saved but
man oh man is this difficult practically
so i would throw this in why would i
throw this in because i feel like at
least this forces black to weaken some
of his pawns you know
and now okay the engine suggests the
movable rook a8
and the point of this is that f5 is met
with b takes a5 and now black has a lot
to worry about on the queen side
um so this necessitates by taking on a5
ah takes a five takes a5 and now rook a8
makes perfect sense
so i'll play rookie five
and you can keep harassing me with rook
c8
and
probably i will
close my eyes and just start pushing
these pawns
takes an f4 this type of position i mean
this
is so nasty to play
yeah this is not what i wanted and
instead if i don't go to c8 but i go
back behind the f-pawn
you're just gonna push the f-pawn i'll
push up i mean this makes sense and then
you can just play a move like king h2
again orienting yourself toward
the sacrifice and ultimately i guess
black will have to play g3 at some point
and go for this
type of end game
and then a move like rook d7 in order to
get the rook to d3
50 50. i mean white totally can save
this but i can also see andre
making one more mistake and slipping
into a lost position
i also think that uh
very often i don't know if you would
agree but anish has spent so long now on
a5 and very often we see that kind of
being uh
recip what's the word reciprocated
by white
and um
because it is a very tough spot here for
andre there's so many different
uh
things i mean he always has to calculate
this ending that you're talking about if
anish
goes g3 does he want to take that pawn
probably yes but so much
uh
to figure out here
and what i was gonna say that the time
could at some point start ticking down
very fast uh because we are only on move
41 only one move has been made and
forget about reciprocating the time use
because v4 is on the board but maybe b4
was the the first the more obvious and
after that things will get more tricky
yeah i think before is
it's very natural to throw this move in
it's not going to hurt
um for anish i i guess a takes b4 is a
viable candidate move
and after c takes before
i'm not really sure but the thing is
again it's black to move here and now
black is in a weird way kind of in swan
because if black plays b6 and tries to
wait well that's no good white creates a
pass spawn of his own and this is the
last thing that you want to allow white
to do
so i'm anticipating b6 and there it is
b6 played quite quickly
and this is a big moment for for andre
he has to decide which piece he's going
to move
and
at the same time he cannot take too long
he can't really even take longer than 15
minutes i would say on this move if he
drops
below 20 minutes
he's got 18 moves to make
it's not gonna he's not gonna make it
happen so he has to keep himself at
least i would say 20 minutes to
calculate and maybe we can once again
here just try and go through all the
possible
moves that white can make the different
pieces he can move because the options
are quite limited
yeah and i think we can use the process
of elimination to prune uh the tree of
possible moves
um
king h2
i i just i think this is actually not
such a dumb move i mean i know it looks
ridiculous to walk into a fork but again
if you know that you're sacrificing on
g3
um i think this is a viable candidate
move and also the point is rookie three
check can be met with rook f3 very
important otherwise you'd lose c3
um
so that's one possibility and from
black's perspective that the computer
proposes this mubrook g6
uh with the idea of defending f6 so that
this other rook is going to be free to
move where will it move too well it can
go to e1 and activate itself or it can
go to e4 and start harassing white's
queen side pawns
so i don't think andre is going to go
king h2 though i just don't see that
happening i think he's going to move
this this real kind of fate
i think this is the rook that he's going
to move and
probably he's going to play rook b8
and i think that we're going to see this
position on the board if i had to guess
which looks uh terrific terrifying to
let one more pawn advance
but maybe just
not so many other options adania while
we wait for andres panko to make what is
a big decision we're going to listen at
what sam had to say after holding magnus
currents into a draw
[Music]
sam shankland you just played a draw
with magnus carlsen um it seems like you
were pressing the whole game like i was
pressing the hook i think so i felt it
was sort of back and forth i mean at
some point when i played uh bishop b2
bishop before i had missed some detail
that i just can't go rick c1 he has
knight takes a two and it's at this
point i already felt like my position
was uncomfortable i calculated a lot of
direct lines like queen b3 with a3 and
none of it was working
so i took c3 for damage control i
thought it was already a bit worse but
then i was very surprised that she took
with uh the bishop i thought taking with
the rook was much stronger and then
i was basically fine pretty early on uh
but once i played e4 e5 and then knight
d4 e6 at first i thought my position
should be very good but
then i started thinking after queen take
c6 check king h8 was on the board and i
didn't really
see a great way through it at some point
i was like how am i going to save this
f2 pawn and so um
uh and then what i actually missed a
really nice detail when i played queen
g3 uh i thought that after rook d7 i
could go rook takes b7
uh with the point rook takes b7 queen g6
is just draw on the spot but after rick
txb7 his bishop takes f2 check first
it's a very important move order rook
takes f2 uh rook takes b7 queen g6 rook
b1 check and i get mated by queen d1 at
the end so after that i was actually
surprised that um
that he couldn't put more pressure than
he did it felt like it should be
unpleasant but i guess i held pretty
easily did you expect magnus to play a
gambit
uh yeah i mean this is only sort of a
gambit i mean uh but
yeah like i i didn't expect it at all of
course
i wouldn't have played so terribly in
the opening i guess and maybe i would
have put some more pressure on if i knew
this was coming because i don't think
this is supposed to equalize but i
haven't checked it recently
over eight rounds um how's your
tournament so far
uh it's been lousy i mean the uh
so basically six of the games have just
been sort of normal draws that's fine
but the two games that stand out is i
was dead winning against neil scandelius
and i drew that game and then against
vedic i got some very unpleasant
position and defended it all the way to
equality and then started to relax the
next thing you know so
it feels like if i had been on better
form i'd be on plus one instead of minus
one so it's just been a frustrating
event especially to still be winless and
you know seven draws and the loss is not
great but i'm still think playing
reasonable trust at some moments and
certainly enjoying the tournament it's
really great to play with such strong
guys
um
any plans for the rest day
not really i'm not even i'm not even
sure how much we're allowed to do but uh
you know it's
i'll think about it i'm i haven't
thought about it yet okay thank you
that's my pleasure
and sam shanklin there despite the great
draw against magnus carlsen he is being
quite hard on himself dania
yeah he always has been and you know
that's an ingredient
necessary ingredient for greatness and
we saw that he admitted he hadn't
checked that line in a while and
you know magnus's opening choice had the
desired effect but
yeah i i have to agree with sam i think
it was back and forth i really i don't
think sam sam definitely wasn't better
the entire game if anything uh he was
concerningly slightly worse toward the
end and a great job just holding
everything together
against magnus never an easy task for
sure and i think he had the right
feeling
that magnus could have put on more
pressure there was this one moment maybe
later on we'll have a chance to briefly
go back there where magnus maybe could
have put
more
problems than he did
but for now we have only this one game
remaining here in our masters group and
andrei sepanko as you predicted he is
still pondering uh his next move after
b6
yeah they're they're clearly at an
inflection point at a critical moment
i mean i don't envy andre i'm just gonna
sip my coffee and watch him uh make this
decision because
man i mean
between b takes a5 rook v8 rook a8
knight t2 king h2
there's five or six candidate moves
and all of them could you could see a
case being made for all of them
and those are the hardest decisions to
make the ones where you really have
three or four options
and it's hard to calculate anything in
this position it's kind of a weirdly
it's a weird position or black has a
bunch of improving moves
so andre's gonna have to trust his
intuition and i think the worst thing he
could do
is is really go under 10 minutes i mean
i don't see him defending it
for the next 18 moves if that happens
yeah for sure i mean it's always
we always feel we are so far away from
the next time control when we hit move
40 but it's gonna happen uh way faster
um
especially if your andre issues the
minutes here take down so fast and
18 moves to make is a lot of moves
27 minutes already isn't very much time
for all the moves he has to make when
every move is a crucial decision
exactly and i remember a game
remember a game from the i think 2015
us championship against ray robson
uh we got into a crazy time scramble
and then we barely made sudden death on
move 40.
we both got 30 minutes
and uh he thought for
29 of them on his next move and then i
thought for 28 of them and then the time
scramble literally continued so we got
up went to the bathroom refilled our
coffees
back to work put the album back on you
know
start working working on it again
it was a crazy incident and i ended up
losing the game
that was crazy but here i mean something
very similar is happening right now the
players had gotten 50 minutes and
uh half of that allocated extra time is
already gone for andreas panko
yeah i mean the time just evaporates so
quickly when you when you when you're
thinking about these
super complex positions you can take
five minutes on on something and then
realize there's an easy refutation
uh because things are so hard to
calculate
and it's funny that the move king h2 is
a viable candidate move that's a
ridiculous looking move and who would
walk right into a fork and yet that
under some circumstances might actually
be the best move but for anish uh the
thing that makes his task easier is that
he does have a pretty clear pathway
toward improving his position he wants
to play rook g6
and
free up the other rook and he always has
the possibility of going g3 whenever he
wants to and essentially forcing knight
takes g3
yeah frustration there for andre he just
seems irked
you gotta feel
sorry in a way for andre who's gotten
himself into quite a bit of trouble you
also gotta have respect for him making
this a decision early on to play on
but now he is going to have to dig very
deep dania we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be back with the
conclusion
of this game in a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome again in vikrance a shrek stands
for forbidding for bending here in the
dorp in vaikanshay my oak on the shark
fence over
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
indeed fiona a
major major turn of events
let's
uh debrief everyone on what just
happened and why black is now completely
winning if anish finds the right pathway
now
after b4 b6 andre deciding to take and
go rook a8 and fiona we explored this
option
geary defending the pawn with rookie
five this is the critical moment andre
had to return to f8 and anchor the rook
once again to the f-bomb but
what did he do he played the move knight
d2 well that looks totally reasonable
he's preventing g3 he can't play g3
because there's going to be a four
wait a second what i just said is the
lie you can play g3 why can't you play
g3 because after knight f3 check which
andre is banking on
there is the move king f4
and all of a sudden white ends up in
massive trouble if he takes on e5 then
black takes the rook with check after
king takes e5 f2f takes e5 this is of
course
winning because of black's past pawns
okay well what are the other options
available to white if the rook moves
aside then h3 check wins the night the
rook has to go to f1 and this is what
andre was relying on
the move that i'm sure he missed
is h3 check brilliant move
and i think anish
i think he is too
and just to complete this line after
king h3 g2
the game is simply over the rook is
attacked black stroke is coming into g3
i think anish sees this and if he plays
this line he is going to win this game
oh
sorry my apologies i'm not muted i just
left the mic lying in my bag after
dinner now you're good
oh man this is like i was blind but now
i
see okay i'm back back in the game
cool cool okay so
anish is
yeah no i think i think we can hear you
now
i think so yeah although they should i
can hear you i'm just looking at the
chat
i'm not they're still saying
that
no i am back i think i think they're
trolling welcome welcome back everyone
welcome welcome welcome
okay so again g3 wins the game on the
spot
can anish calculate this line out
accurately and he's got
oodles and
oodles of time
and you see this is where his time
management comes in so handy 29 minutes
and he's reaching out
and he does not need
any of them
there it goes
and wow
what a win that is going to be i've
already sold it as a win of course the
game isn't over but now that anish has
found g3 and of course we're curious to
see what is the reaction going to be of
andreas
panko and
yeah he's going to play knight f3 check
of course that move is absolutely forced
but did you see the slight shake of the
head a bit like we saw with nils earlier
maybe
some shock as he now realizes
that he might have missed just what you
were showing that that line with h3
and there are several possibilities for
what it is exactly that he missed
it might have been king f4 maybe he
thought that he hallucinated knight
takes c5 with check and what i think one
shouldn't do is say oh well the computer
was giving it a draw to high depth how
could he have blunted like this let's
not forget that they've been playing for
five hours andre has been suffering in
this end game for well over two hours
and uh these players are only human you
know you espec these are the kinds of
positions where the gap between computer
play and human play is perhaps the
widest these positions where there's a
million options they all look tempting
and uh no matter how sharp you are for
the human brain to work through the
complications is
uh well not impossible and it's also
possible that he missed h3 just one more
thing fiona if the king drops back to g1
the win is even more straightforward but
also very pretty g2
rook f2 and now we want to
sneak this king right into that gap
there with king g3
if knight takes e5 that is very very
pretty pawn mate
indeed
and if white starts with the rook takes
32 track in order to get this pawn off
of h3
then it is all very easy knight e5 fe 5
and
the game is over black just pushes the
the e pawn
and in the event of brook takes a5
there's checkmate in two moves anisha is
gonna i know she can calculate this in
his sleep he's seen it
and you can see andre looking off to the
distance really did i just wonder that
yeah tough to see him he's gonna be
in a real hard spot tonight we talked
about this many many hours ago at the
start of the show and maybe we can very
briefly once again for the people who
might have joined us later dania just
put that one moment on the analysis
board um
where uh andre had an option he could
have
uh gone for a perpetual check
or forced a perpetual check
anyway and um
we were both saying we wouldn't you know
be shocked if he if he went for the draw
it makes sense especially before west
that you were saying especially with the
white pieces you don't want to go into
the rest day
on the loss and this was the moment here
after amnesia's move 95
yeah and you know i was sure that he
would do it also because of the speed of
anish's play andre knew that anish was
still in this preparation and clearly
andre wasn't so as gutsy as it was to go
for that end game
it might not have been the wisest
decision given how carefully any studied
this line so knight takes c5
uh and black is forced to deliver
perpetual check king g1 queen g3
and uh there's nothing black can do
other than that if black tries bishop
takes f2 white is always going to have a
move like this and black has simply
sacrificed too many pieces and of course
if bishop takes e1
um then
there is queen takes f7
and there's some other queen g8 i don't
think this would have been in gary's uh
plans
but
he went knight h2 sheltering his king
and after queen g6 bishop c2 knight d3
uh andre
was essentially forced to give up the f2
pawn but in return he got a queen trade
and this is how it all began these three
pawns you know in my experience
almost any position like this where you
have these three pawns against the piece
these positions are so so difficult to
play even though the computer initially
even shows a tiny little something for
white i don't believe it
yeah and um andre probably now he is
remembering that moment
hopefully he's not gonna walk away
thinking
why didn't i i mean we were all of
course very happy to see him uh play on
it didn't pay off this time but that's
not to say that it never pays off
and there's that f3 check and we are
going to see an ish very quickly play
king f4 the move is absolutely forced
and there he goes king f4 is on the
board
yeah no it's uh
i mean provided that he finds h3 what do
you don't want to do if you're a niche
after rook f1 uh the move rookie two
check
uh does not win because of king g1
and white threatens a discovery with
knight d4 and you've just seen it so
yeah i think how it's going to transpire
and
yeah just you gotta feel for freezing
maybe the position was difficult uh
anyway
when the the blunder happened with
knight d2 um
you were saying the engine could
probably hold it with best play but here
in uh into the six hour
of play with limited time on the clock
i think he was already in a dive
situation but now the game is really
coming to a brutal conclusion here
without question yeah it's white's
defense has come to a screeching halt
after rook f1 h3 check just to show that
key line again
what is the purpose of h3 what happens
if i take takes it well this is just a
deflection sacrifice you go g2 white can
never take the rook because black takes
on f1 with mate
and
if rook g1 then you lose the knight and
if rook f2 there's multiple things that
black can do so rook g3 check is winning
but
uh not as clear as the move king e3
with a beautiful detail now this attacks
the rook uh white's knight still can't
move from f3
and if rook takes g2
king takes f3 sacrificing the rook but
of course there is checkmate
awaiting on h5
i'm really stunning lines here uh that
andre must have just missed we don't
know what exactly was it h3 he missed um
was it just sort of a
slip and a blind spot like it happened
to fabiano a couple of days ago
against anish but all i know anish he is
gonna get a third
uh consecutive win to move back to plus
two
very impressive and anish he's had a
topsy-turvy event quality wise
um even fabi
mentioned that anish really didn't play
well against him at the first part of
the game
um and and i guess
wait i knew she has three wins in a row
around now right three wins in a row
yeah he lost one game
earlier in the tournament um
against magnus and which was of course
his first loss here in vicanzade to
magnus and i said moving back to plus
two but that is incorrect because he
wasn't there so he's moving at two plus
two and putting himself in contention
here with five rounds to go
yeah and this really might be a nisha's
best game so far this tournament
excluding the game against dubob which
was
um so perfect that you know
there's just nothing to talk about it
was it was flawless uh but excluding
that game i'm kidding of course he won
uh by walkover after simply playing one
d4
uh but this was a very smooth game he
prepared extremely well and the way that
he handled this end game
textbook textbook fashion the way he
carefully pushed his pawns and then the
moment andre
uh you know and particularly you know
what i'm very impressed by is the move
a5 this idea to induce zugswong how many
people would just automatically play g3
how could you not play g3 and yet unis
realizing that the rook end game was
likely to be a draw and finding this
idea of inducing zugzwang from a
practical standpoint an incredibly nasty
nasty idea that and ends up winning the
game for him and andre is going to make
a couple more moves here
but
the game is hurtling towards conclusion
there comes rook f1
h3 check that's the chemo
and i i don't think anish is going to
spend too long it's really i mean we saw
the despair there on niacipanko's
face this is not he was having a
brilliant tournament he came into this
as white
um but and here it comes
here it goes
and unfortunately
yep double checking
yeah and there's no need to rush too
much but anish is not one to take
20 minutes when he's calculated
everything up there's a point at which
you just got to trust yourself and
further quadruple checking becomes
essentially counterproductive
yeah of course he still has plenty of
time on the clock but i think he
calculated all of this when he went g3
and now the look to the side just double
triple checking and h3 will probably be
played i would say within the next 30
seconds even
probably yeah
and i was just
toying around with there's a lot of
lines that involve black sacrificing one
of the rooks in order to get uh
checkmate with the other one
but let's
wait
let's hold off until onish plays h3 and
then
i'll show them
i mean andre might simply resign after
h3 that's also entirely possible
the final moment it's funny to see anish
with the mask under under the chin of
course reminder
um
the players don't have to wear a mask
when they're sitting at the board unless
there has been a close contact
and so i think we've all heard plenty of
that and big is telling uh
informing us as well that h3 is the only
move um as well for four black so
really we would be very well the only
move to win and there he goes h3 is on
the board
there it is
yeah h3 is the only move as we discussed
um
rookie 2 was actually gave up the entire
game they gave up the entire game
all right
so let's see what andre chooses will he
resign will he take the pawn or will he
go
king
one all three options i think are
equally likely i think king ju1 is the
likeliest
i agree with you i also think he might
just uh resign
we saw from his face sometimes we don't
even need to see the position sometimes
having the camera
is enough
and he understood i think as soon as g3
appeared on the board what he had done
maybe we can just one final time as we
wait for his decision just show
the lines here
absolutely so if king takes h3 this is
one can consider the main line
g2
the rook is forced to go up to f2
and now the prettiest and fastest way to
win is king e3
rook takes g2 as forced if you take the
rook
then at a minimum black can just make a
queen with mate coming
but after rook takes you to this
beautiful tactical detail king takes f3
rook takes g7 or h5 checkmate
and if white's king well if white team
goes to h1 then it's very easy black
goes g2 with a fork and if the king goes
to g1 then still g2
if you take the rook here
then takes takes
and f takes e5 with the completely
winning rook end game just up two past
pawns
uh and that forces rook f2 and really
the only thing that anish has to see
here is kingdom three but that's a
really easy move if knight takes c5
there is mate
white is forced to give up the rook for
the pawn oh and by the way
if uh white does nothing then there's a
beautiful idea rookie one with the same
ot an h2 checkmate
yeah that checkmate with the two pawns
is really very uh very cute
yeah
i'm sure
as andre is thinking
shall we i don't know whether to whether
we have time to quickly take a look at
the challenger i've got some some uh a
question for you danny from our producer
vic so we can
spend the time in that way so the
question to you then is what's the worst
feeling that you need to pee when you
only have three minutes left on the
clock or that you want to resign but
your opponent isn't at the void
um
well
i have resigned with my opponent not at
the board before i just stop the clock
and kind of flag him down
um and
yeah so no wanting to pee and and not
having time is the most excruciating
feeling now i've had cases like that i
remember when i played the 2006
under i think it was under 12 under 12
world youth
uh i had a game like that in the third
round i you know really wanted to go to
the bathroom but i was in very acute
time pressure from the opening
and i just could not afford to get up i
also didn't know where the bathroom was
um so i had to have i had to spend time
finding it the arbiters didn't always
speak english
uh and i ended up losing the game
largely because i just couldn't focus
and
uh you know it's it it closely followed
by a situation when you're at the window
seat of an airplane and you don't want
to wake the passenger next to you but
you're just dying to go to the bathroom
ah the worst
the worst everybody can relate to that
feeling the worst indeed and adani i
think we're just that this game is about
to conclude because andre has taken the
pawn on h3 and after g2 i think there
will just be no
no way to even prolong the game as mate
becomes inevitable
well the only thing the only pitfall is
and you have to find king e3 that move
is
relatively obvious but you know it can
be missed you have to see this idea of
king e3 and then rook takes you to king
takes f3 the thing is vanish had three
minutes i would allow for the
possibility that he doesn't play it with
28 minutes he's already probably seen it
but he's going to take as long as it as
long as he needs to to hammer it out
he's not going to go rook g3 here
because if you go rook g3 you have to
win the game again rook takes f3 king g2
and this is a winning rocket game but
it's
it's a hassle
it's a it's a big big hassle yeah and i
think it's a hassle he himself
wants to save himself we saw him
give a couple of stairs there there's
the third stare
in the direction of andreas panko and i
agree with you i think he has already
seen it and it will be delivered shortly
and that will probably force the
resignation
yep
and you can see the discipline all of
these top players they have tremendous
discipline they never rush it they take
as long as they need as long as it takes
to verify beyond any shadow of doubt
uh that the line
they have in mind is winning here's
anish adopting the prayer stance
beth harmon style
making the final calculations and we are
about to see king e3
yeah k3 uh i think will appear on the
board and once again i mean i've been
talking a lot about you got a feel for
foreign this will be
three on the on the trot do you say that
in the u.s in the us as well is that an
english thing say that again three on
the throttle maybe i'm just making it up
as well
on the truck
on the truck
never heard of that maybe i'm making it
up i'm sure that the chat
will either uh confirm or debunk my my
claim here it sounds real it sounds like
something a british expression
yeah
not very good for the president i think
the truth is like the gallop no it's
like
anyway thankfully anish
making the move kingy free
yup with confidence and i think andre
actually might even allow checkmate to
happen on the board which uh far from
being unethical is sometimes a gracious
way
uh to allow
the player to naturally complete a great
game but you also might resign here
it is all over game of
[Music]
a very very nice combination dania i had
some time to to google tree on the trot
isn't that's not it but on the trot is
an expression which means consecutively
so i'm kind of free on the trot
i think it's okay i think we can allow
it
we will allow it i mean look somebody
had to be the first one to use an
expression who's to say who has a
monopoly on creating expressions
um i always it's funny i really like the
expression a day but i always get it
confused it's expression is basically
see even now i'm getting it confused a
day late and a dollar short
and i always say a dollar late on a day
short and people like to make fun of me
for that
that's also not an expression that we
use too much in europe i think so it's
funny really how the the idioms uh
change
quite a lot maybe i can change it to a
daylight and a in a euro short
that sounds a lot better
right bick also has his favorite
expression i don't ask for a lighter
load
i ask for a stronger back
wow
that's deep
yeah well that's like the george bernard
shaw quote i think you know like the
adapting to the world it's like the
series of quotes that have the same
structure like ask not what you can do
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
um or like the strong
expect the world to adapt to them
you know or the weak and then the strong
adapt to the world it's like those
inverted quotes i always like the way
those expressions sound
for sure and we've gotten a very uh
philosophical here but
extremely well andre is sitting there
and
contemplating the meaning of life they
both look like they're contemplating the
meaning of life and
uh andre is asking what this position
can do for him
and getting no answer
but what can he do for this position
also nothing he can resign
yeah the position is indeed and i think
we just missed the handshake uh
so her resignation after king e3
congratulations to anish what a game for
andre yes
a devastating
loss but
he is so young as well he will be back
and we see the players there discussing
probably maybe even what was going on in
the opening
indeed it was a very
complex very interesting game with a
theoretical segment and andre he is
going to be kicking himself tonight he's
going to be replaying that over and over
again i could have made the draw
could have been watching football
all throughout the last three and a half
hours but
we have to get tip our hats to him you
know he went for it that was a very
gutsy decision it didn't pay off this
time but andreas penco has all of the
qualities of a super gm and his career
really is only beginning so
he's gonna recover he's got a half of
the tournament left uh to bounce back
from this loss and that is the final
game of the master section fiona another
very interesting day with three decisive
rounds just like yesterday i believe
indeed i thought that maybe we were in
for a choir today as the rest day is
coming up tomorrow but the players
didn't hold
anything back
dania we're going to go on a short break
after that we will be back well first
let's look at the results uh of the day
uh with anish geary we still see the
players discussing the game in the
background beating andre sipenko with
the black pieces shahid media if he beat
pragnanda to join magnus carlsen in the
lead who magnus he was held by sam
shankland and visited gujarati bouncing
back from his loss to jordan in the best
possible way by beating niels grandelius
who unfortunately is still struggling in
this tournament but danya are the things
looking at the top
chakra with a big win has joined magnus
atop the tournament standings they both
got five and a half out of eight and we
see very close behind the manish riding
shree on the trot anisha on the trot
with five out of eight closely and digit
as well bit it with an excellent game uh
we might hear more about that game after
the break we've got four and a half out
of eight rehard report on plus one and
then a big group with fifty percent fabi
karyakan essepanko van forest all of
them are going to have to take a lot of
risks in the second half of the
tournament they've got some catching up
to do and in the case of fabi he is
still definitely thinking about winning
the tournament so that's going to add a
fascinating angle
to how
the final rounds of this tournament
are going to look
for sure plenty to look forward to but
for now we aren't done just yet we will
be back
with your daily rapid recap as well as
with the pairings for the day after but
first we'll take a quick break so don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to tata steel and round
eight
is in the books and now it is time for
your daily
rapid recap and the game we are going to
focus on today
is the battle between vidit and niels
grendellis it was an absolutely
fascinating game fiona with so many
interesting moments and tactical nuances
absolutely vivid he lost the previous
day to jordan van ferece so it was
interesting to see how was he gonna
bounce back neil squindelius not had the
best start to the tournament and it
looked like uh village he sprung this
first surprise in the opening
he really did this move knight beat
knight bd2 uh not a very common line the
idea is to play e4 and transpose the
game into a perk and against d5
generally white plays this really
interesting move before this is a cool
line to explore but
neil's deciding to
stick with the perk and allow that
transposition and here fiona
normally black plays d6 but niels
castled and perhaps he started to regret
this move very shortly thereafter yeah
because by castling he allowed vidit to
go e5
which is just what vidit did and after
the knight jumped to h5
here comes the g pawn g4 appeared on the
board with it later in the interview
revealed this was all prep he didn't say
how deep it went but what a move dania
g4 just so bold it is of course very
weakening but he figures that his
initiative is going to be well worth it
and now in the night jumps out to e4
another attack on the night and one
funny line is that if the knight drops
back to e6 white goes d5 and the knight
simply has no squares so neil's
forced to make a counter-attacking move
if he goes knight d5 then white can just
continue tossing the knight around this
gets worse and worse so a very inventive
resource counter resource by niels
grendelius and here another important
moment white shouldn't take on d6
because after knight d5 if you just
gobble up the pawns this is
extraordinarily dangerous for white
because of the pressure down the e file
in fact this position is simply losing
and so vidit demonstrated a lot of
restraint
uh and
went for the move knight g3 after d5 and
fiona the next moment was really really
interesting what he did after 96. for
sure not a move that was on my radar for
sure vidic just threw the knight forward
to f5 where it looks at first sight like
what are you doing black can simply
capture that knight but g takes uh it
doesn't work or at least it's not as
good as it seems at first sight because
after white recaptures the knight on e6
is trapped
indeed it's trapped and white's going to
put a rook on g1 here black's king is
kind of toast in this position and so uh
niels correctly refrained from that
instead choosing to counter strike in
the center but now vidit used that
knight and exchanged it for nielsen's
fiance bishop never a particularly
encouraging thing to have to face knight
takes g7 and now avidit taking the time
to defend the pawn on g4
c takes d4 and now that now another very
impressive move bishop h6 vidit realizes
that he doesn't actually need to rush uh
to recapture the pawn it's a lot more
important to position his pieces well
and that bishop is really a bone in
black's throat neil's deciding to
transition the game into an end game he
gives a check
uh and after queen takes the two knight
takes it to fiona we were impressed uh
during the game with the fact that vinit
really didn't care about recapturing
that pawn at all was a lot more
important for him to build up the pawn
mass on the king side great forward
thinking forbid it indeed he understood
that pawn on d4 is going nowhere i can
win that back any moment i like and we
saw in the game after knight c6 as you
just highlighted and now with it he is
in time to play f4 defend his important
central pawn uh on e5 and niels now make
making a move we thought it was
necessary but not a move you want to
make f6
yeah i mean he tries to get himself a
little bit of space i mean if black had
gone without it then white would have
repositioned the knight castle queen
side and then reclaimed that pawn with
tremendous interest but it turns out
that even after the trade uh black's
task defensive task is extremely
difficult uh vidit castling queenside
and now an absolutely fascinating moment
so niels plays rookie eight and here it
was important for vidid uh to start with
the move bishop g2
uh force the bishop to come out to e6
and only now play the move knight b3 but
vida decides to transpose the move order
that doesn't seem particularly
significant he plays knight b3 first and
there was no harm no foul uh grendelius
played 96 and it went bishop g2 but
fiona there was an absolutely incredible
resource that was overlooked by both
players here an incredible resource and
that move is bishop f5 and that's where
all the difference comes from here once
again a piece seems to be just hanging
but if white were to capture the bishop
then after knight takes the bishop on h6
is lost and the idea of course behind
bishop f5 is to bring the bishop to that
all-important square on e4
indeed and that works out in case white
takes on g7 black still plays bishop b4
the rook is hanging white has to deal
with that and this position is probably
not even worse for black due to the
strength of that bishop perhaps i could
keep a small advantage with the computer
move bishop b5 but it would definitely
be nothing more than the tiniest of
advantages this was a massive missed
opportunity but can you really blame
them niels going full passive defense 96
bishop g2 the knight has to reposition
to c7 and now vidit deciding to move in
with f5 he could have taken on d4 but
going for a very gutsy and interesting
decision ripping open black's king
position g takes f5 and now rook f1
another important moment black could
have taken on g4 and then taken on h3
and apparently black could have survived
this position but man oh man can you
blame niels for not wanting to go for
this position no absolutely not that
black king looks in a world of pain so
no surprise that niels did not capture
instead he went king f7 trying to get
the king out of harm's way now of course
vidit simply recaptures and neil's
trying to activate his work along the g
file
indeed rook 28 but that's pretty nicely
parried but
not very nicely paired as it turns out
rook d2 is an inaccuracy and for the
second time in the game niels had the
possibility of capturing an f5 a move
that might have been overlooked by both
players this time the idea is to play
king g6 for king the bishop and the rook
and although white is undoubtedly still
better after rook f2 i think that this
would have given niels very very good
chances to save the game he's still up
upon
and uh a lion's share of white's
advantage has evaporated for that reason
uh it was better for vinnet to actually
tuck the bishop away on h1 which would
have given him the possibility of
delivering a check on g1 there at the
right moment but this was also missed by
niels who plays 95 centralizing his
knight another natural move but after
vidit reclaims the pawn uh fiona he
eliminates all of mike's counter playing
and we were impressed with vidit's
patience he spends the next part of the
game just slowly but surely improving
his position for sure although material
was uh even at this stage village has
kept improving his pieces and neil sadly
his piece is so crime difficult to find
counter play and look at vidit he's just
bringing first the bishop
back into the game
playing rook f2 to defend the bishop on
g2 and then finally improving the last
piece out comes the king
out comes the king and he's threatening
to go all the way to c5 that strains
black's pieces even further neal's out
of desperation he finds a pretty nice
idea he's trying to get this knight all
the way over to e4
and uh vidit immediately responds to the
move c4 boom time the moment the knight
leaves uh its post he attacks the pawn
on t5 and at this point niels was
already in very serious time pressure
and in this position he collapses can't
really blame him the only way to stay in
the game was to return to c7 reinforce
this pawn as much as one can
and here vidit would have still had to
work quite hard in order to win the game
the computer indicates the very nice
move bishop f1 that's actually a
prophylactic move reinforcing the c4
pawn if black takes on c4
then y can take on c6 and when
everything is said and done at the end
of this line
white plays bishop takes e5 and the
point of bishop f1 is revealed either
bishop takes c4 or rook d7 check and
guess what if the bishop had been on g2
in this position it would have been
hanging so bringing the bishop away make
sure that this line does win a piece
this would have been practically
speaking losing for black but after
something like a5 uh black could have
stayed in the game for a couple of more
moves but nils panicking going knight g7
and fiona it was all over now
indeed after vidit captured the bishop
on c6 the black position just falls
apart now with it instantly he took on
on d5 and there's just too many uh
threats here against the the black king
and rook everything is falling apart
niels tried
rook to d8
but resigned after vidit simply captured
on c6 if the trade on d2 happens uh
vidit can choose whichever piece he
wants to recapture with but
white now has two extra pawns and the c
pawn is only two squares away from
queening so dania what a game by visit
an incredible game so smooth and a
wonderful opening you know all of those
ideas with g4 it might have been
preparation but still so creative and
then the way that he transitioned into
the end game it wasn't flawless but by
and large he demonstrated patience when
he needed to be patient patient decisive
play when he needed to be decisive and
both at the very end as he improved his
position slowly and then pouncing at the
right moment with c4 vidit bouncing back
from a painful loss to jordan ben forest
yesterday scoring a win and getting back
to the top quadrant of the field a great
game by bit it today indeed kudos to it
and that was your rapid recap of the day
to conclude the action here what a day
it has been dania we just saw this game
here
in more detail once again we had two
other wins as where giri uh grinding out
a long end game against panko who
blundered in the end and shakir
mamedyarov beating pragnanda to join
magnus carlsen in the lead let's have
another look
at the standings before we wrap up here
indeed we have carlson and mohammad
yarov atop the standings with five and a
half out of eight closely followed by
giri and vidit who of course scored that
win today report the only other player
with a plus score and then a big group
with 50 percent and as we talked about
earlier those players the peloton there
report carwanna kayaking they're gonna
make a big push i can guarantee it in
the next couple of rounds speaking of
which let's have a look at round nine
pairings which will happen after the
rest day tomorrow fiona some really
interesting matchups and i think there
is only one place we can start here that
is at the very bottom where magnus
carlsen we see he will be taking on shaq
they tried to hide the pairing from us
i know it's ridiculous this is bix doing
but the two leaders are playing what are
the odds the two leaders are playing
exactly when we need them to play fiona
magnus of the white pieces he is playing
all guns blazing he wants to win this
game
for sure we heard from shakira
mamedyarov magnus has
a good plus score against
against jacques he wasn't sure how much
is it is it plus five is it plus six now
the pairing is gone that is definitely
big stirring what else do we have uh to
look forward to
anish geary he won three on the trot he
will be playing sam shanklin next and
with the white pieces he will be looking
to make it uh four
we have uh jordan went for race against
duboff two members of team carlson will
be very interesting to see them facing
off and what else dania
yeah and and grindelius caruana is a big
game for fabi who sits on 50
and he is playing a struggling niels
grandelias he has to play for a win
today was a pretty disappointing game
for him as he never really got off the
ground against jordan van forest
excellent preparation so keep an eye out
as fabi uh tries perhaps to play in a
more risky fashion than usual report and
vid it oh that is going to be an
explosive matchup both of them in great
form vid it on five out of eight he's
going to try to keep his positive
momentum going and of course prague
always fun to watch as he faces off
against sergey karjakin who also sits at
50 and also we'll be playing for a win
with the black pieces but don't tune in
tomorrow fiona right yes so much to look
forward to but not tomorrow
uh us to our producer the players you
guys out there everyone gets a rest day
to take a deep breath and then so many
exciting matchups to look forward when
we return on january 25th which round
nine it will be the usual starting time
2 p.m central european time at 5 00 a.m
on the pacific uh coast and dania it's
been an absolutely uh tremendous day of
chess a big thank you to you big thanks
to everyone watching us today and i'll
leave you the closing words
absolutely fiona well this was an
absolute pleasure as as usual uh so fun
to commentate with you in these games
they were explosive we had all sorts of
openings today we had every single
player uh playing for a win whether or
not the game ended decisively or in a
draw and games middle games attacks and
everything in between this is why we
watch and this is why classical chess is
awesome
what around it was this web buying a
flash and we want to thank of course
uh everybody in the chat and twitch and
youtube thousands of you who are
cheering on your favorite player and i
have to begrudgingly thank the producer
vic yep he does do a fantastic job i
just realized let's also give one thanks
to our moderators who are working so
hard every day to keep
the chat nice and in order so a big
shout out to you guys and of course
everyone working behind the scenes danny
it's been a pleasure i'll see you two
days from now have a good one everyone
we'll see you then
goodbye
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you